[Music]
thank you
foreign
but that might as well say No Nonsense
because I
do not
play
now today will not be a day off
in fact today you will work harder than
anybody
[Music]
welcome to Metta World news our top
story why are people always trying to
steal my magic
and other news cat litter can be used to
blind people when fighting interesting I
didn't know that
well that wraps up Meadow world news for
this Wednesday February biscuit fountain
drink I'm Meadow World Peace good night
welcome to Meadow world news in sports
I'd rather eat my hand than to have my
penis cut off I really have to believe
someone was going to cut it off but if I
did I can definitely eat my hand I know
because I had a dream where I did it it
was horrible I ate my whole hand
now that's what you call rhetoric well
that wraps up Metta World news for this
Wednesday April hurricane Slipknot I'm
Meadow World Peace good night
[Music]
welcome to metal world news in fashion
if you woke up and there was a four inch
miniature human standing on your chest
would you swat them off I was really
challenged by this question I would hope
that I had engaged them in conversation
but in reality I think I'd be scared of
them and SWAT them away which would
probably kill them
well that wraps up middle world news for
this Wednesday October noise canceling
octagon Tire I made a world peace good
night
[Music]
did I fulfill my contract Satan
[Music]
welcome to metal world news our top
story ninja costumes don't come in size
XXX which is discriminatory against
enormous assassins
you know what forget about the
teleprompter
I need to speak from the heart
well that wraps up Metta World news for
this Wednesday May staple gun hairbrush
I'm mad at World Peace good night
[Music]
welcome to Meadow world news
I wish there was a Genie in here
well that wraps up middle world news for
this Wednesday March hybrid ice rink I'm
Meadow World Peace good night
hey Jim where's that Genie
[Music]
welcome to metal world news our top
story the pope is thinking of moving out
the Vatican so feral cats can live there
now let's go to homemaker's corner with
Meadow World Peace
thank you mother you need five plastic
grocery bags to make an effective
parachute
thanks meta and you will die if you try
that well that wraps up Metta World news
for this Wednesday November Morning Star
cocktail neck I'm Metta World Peace good
night
[Music]
welcome to Meadow world news our top
story a professional athlete should
never Post online looking for people to
live action role play Hunger Games with
them
I'm sorry Gerard Kaylee and Zach
well that wraps up middle world news for
this Wednesday August microwave with you
I'm Metta World Peace good night
[Music]
foreign
news in science news it is impossible to
knock yourself out with your own fist
let's not fall behind America
well that wraps up Metta World news for
this Wednesday biscuit biscuit biscuit
I'm Metta World Peace good night
[Music]
you win fish
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
this is funny man
do can't snitch now
don't fake laugh
huh that's not real
I could tell
oh I think it's really funny no you
don't
look at him sitting there all dead
he was 20 and now he's dead
he's never gonna have a wife of kids now
what are you doing Wife and Kids
that [ __ ] ain't funny
his mom and dad ain't never gonna see
him again no
no
you ruining it for me okay well I guess
I just don't get it there it's just that
you shot him that's all that's the whole
thing oh okay so oh
what the hell is wrong with you you
don't shoot a dude that's already dead
that's not funny oh
foreign
ow yeah yeah I guess I just don't get it
[Music]
come now Mary immacula
stand and be forgiven for your sins
but Jesus
how can I be forgiven
I'm a prostitute no child
you were a prostitute
that life is behind you now
oh no Jesus
man it took me forever to find your ass
for you you know how many [ __ ] named
Mary they're all been here now get your
ass in that Caravan no
no I'm not going with you Gala Leroy I'm
gonna stay here with Jesus
what the flip is this you watching this
movie maybe I taught you that I arrested
you from the fishing Village I cleaned
you up and got you out to work and now
that's how you repay me you God get
yourself another pip hell no brother
She's mine I don't think you understand
she's not going with you well I can't
afford to lose I already lost three
[ __ ] to leprosy all right all I got
left is Mary a crippled and two blind
chicks who actually you know they get
requested a lot don't ask me how that
works get out of here I'm not going with
you again Leroy I'm staying here with
Jesus and I'm warning you Jesus has like
12 followers tell him oh 12. okay all
right so this [ __ ] serious pimp
no my friend you're confused it's 12 men
uh are you gay pimp another pimp I'm a
carpenter
Carpenter then why does your house look
like
I've been busy with non-carpentry work
okay that's it [ __ ] pack it get in the
Caravan and make me some money no and I
don't have any stuff to pack Jesus says
we don't need things what the what is
this all about money hell yeah
I have a saying oh it goes like this
you're gonna love this setup it's easier
for a camel to pass through the eye of a
needle than for a rich man to enter the
kingdom of God
oh yeah well I gotta saying too
easy you know why don't you pass your
own
pass your ass through the needle man
[ __ ] you man come on girl stays
what the [ __ ] I slap you and you want me
to hit you on the other cheek that ain't
gangster this is crazy you can have them
I'm done
wait friend
so you know that there are no hard
feelings
would you care to join us for dinner
[Music]
but y'all have
[Music]
this is not just another streaming app
this is so much comedy it's not even
funny are you choking me bro this is
daily late and lately this is real
roasted and raw give it to me now this
is great stand-up great movies and the
great cornholio are you threatening me
no this is one pump two pumps
and three pumps this is live sports
breaking news and a mountain of Comedy
entertainment Paramount plus now
streaming
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is clear
huh you hear that
[Music]
must have been nothing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
now it's my turn to play
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I promise
[Music]
but a lousy fighter
[Music]
[Music]
oh snap
oh
my God
snap indeed
[Music]
[Music]
you saved my life no Carol
you saved mine
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh great hike today buddy and let's come
up that last Hill and I turned around
and you were nowhere to be found
I was gonna have to go back and catch
you uh at least we made it
oh yeah I forgot to tell you I uh I I
talk in my sleep oh yeah quite a bit
actually so um if it bothers you just uh
wake me up
okay buddy cool
night night
[ __ ]
your stupid dick head
Jordan oh let's go camping come on
Jordan keep hiking we're almost there oh
buddy
so much [ __ ] energy
shove that Cliff bar up your ass you
bald sucker
you Keegan hyphen Michael
Jordan
wake up you're talking in your sleep not
asleep yet
oh Nature's gonna be so great once we
get shove nature up your ass you bald
sucker and my ball sucker I mean you
suck bald
still awake
so what do you want to do tonight like I
was thinking maybe we could meet up with
Amy and Brad and like before that we
could go to Angelo's and before that we
could like just go
I have something to say
it in person
because it's
it's super important
okay
um
I know this is sudden
but like I've been thinking about this
for a while
I know this is something that needs to
happen
I'm breaking up with you cool love it
totally fine with that
really yeah
I
thought
I was really worried that you're gonna
be like mad
oh my God are you kidding me no of
course I'm not mad people grow apart it
happens it's like part of life no I'm
totally fine like love it love it love
it
um
so
uh
um you know we had a good run
don't be a stranger
can I just
can I ask why
why yeah like what I was like I'm doing
some work on myself and like trying to
growl as a person so I really like
appreciate to know why yeah
um okay yeah let's look you know I think
that you're kind of like a controlling
person thank you thank you for that
that's nice thank you for that
cool no problem
so you know what your problem is Andre
what you keep tabs on people
every little thing somebody does you
have to keep a tab of it
wait I I can't tell if you're angry or
not I'm not
totally not angry oh no I'm excited it's
good it's just like you said your piece
and I just think that I deserve the
human decency to say my teeth right
right is that
is that not okay no no no
of course of course
you're a controlling manipulative person
everyone says that I
don't know that I am yes you are Andre
yes
[Music]
okay now like you sound pretty I'm not
angry
I'm not angry I'm fine I love it I love
that you gave my house and you broke up
with me in my space and I'm gonna think
about that every time I'm here that's
great that is so perfect for me it's the
best things around here where else was I
supposed to do it because you won't come
to my house oh here he is the Puppet
Master is back but I'm not I'm not I'm
not the Puppet Master she's doing this
to me it's true you won't come to my
house so my apartment looks like two
rats just shooting it every day oh right
like thank you for that I'm a [ __ ]
thank you no I didn't say [ __ ] I didn't
always say is that am I evil or am I in
bed no no you're not evil are you
punishing me
things like that
like that guys I'm sorry I'm sorry okay
me again I I guess I didn't think it
through well it's like too late now I
mean we're dying no it's not too late
Megan Megan seriously I just I I I I I
had a feeling that I thought was true
and clearly clearly it wasn't true
I'm so confused wait are you breaking up
with me are you not breaking up with me
Megan I'm not breaking up with you okay
cool so what do you want to do tonight
like I want to hang out with Amy and
Brad but maybe before that we can go to
Anna's
what just happened
[Music]
Drew come forward
okay Chef this is a chicken quiche with
cremini mushrooms baby spinach and feta
cheese
[Music]
unbelievable
foreign
I have a huge problem with this dish
it's that you haven't made it for me
sooner
thank you chef
because if you had Drew then I would
know how good you are at cooking food
that's bad
I'm sorry Sharon when I say bad I'm a
Michael Jackson Bad
thank you Chef you know how we look
really really bad at the end of his life
I'm sorry I don't know if you like the
dish or not you don't know if I like the
dish or not well let's put it this way
Pat your [ __ ] knives get out you're
off the show
sorry sure
because
you should be working in the finest
restaurant in the world
thank you sir just not any world that I
live in
sorry because frankly it drew I'm
jealous of you thank you sure and your
ability to not give a [ __ ] about what
you cook this
is not fit for human consumption no this
should be eaten by a higher life form
with a more complex palette but also an
altruistic drive to save Humanity from
dishes like this joking not you just
have to die
so you won't have to endure a life in
which you will never exceed what you
have achieved here today
thank you
foreign
[Music]
in conclusion
let's get this party started
ladies and gentlemen
Paramount Plus
local games
sun shining moments this is Defenders
investigators and seven strangers have
to live in a house this is Young
SpongeBob young Sheldon and the younger
this is everything you've been looking
for it's gonna leave a mark live sports
breaking news and a mountain of
entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now streaming
all right partner take the scumbag
downtown before the Mexicans find him
and blow his ass away
if you alive Chico
prende
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
no
no
[Applause]
[Music]
is that a bird
hey
do you know what happened
no
oh
[Music]
I get it
I know stuff blows up
cool
you hungry
yeah man
um what you want uh
Pizza Chinese
kill that noise man
I got a Ratatouille
[Music]
oh [ __ ] that's a rap dude no it ain't
got some Ratatouille yo
they rather to it go make my man a
sandwich
it's only what you got
[Music]
what the [ __ ] son you got a rat up in
your house
what does mean
I don't know what to say man
I got a Ratatouille man he a chef just
like in all them movies man no no right
hey there's only
there's only one movie Levi all right
and he's not a Ratatouille he's a rat
and his name is Remy potato potato I got
myself so Ratatouille that's all I know
order up damn come on Levi
voila
Levi look at this thing man you see it
got bite marks all over it
any good Chef has to taste his creation
that's rat [ __ ]
you didn't make a sandwich though oh
hell no I'm out my dude you need help
[Music]
oh well Ratatouille another negative
review
maybe you wanted Charlotte's Web
to the end of the first quarter with the
Rhinos in the red zone for the first
time gotta say Bill I like watching
these rhinos Ransom takes the snap drops
back with good protection and that's a
completed pass to a very wide open
ingleman crinkleberry the rookie out of
Penn State nice ground by mccringleberry
you think he's happy oh boy he is loving
it down there oh we got something of a
shooting gallery oh yeah look at that
boy that is something and oh whoa wait
we've got a flag for excessive
celebration yeah well see and I'm not
sure about that call I don't know Bill
that was three pumps in the rule book
says you cannot have more than two oh my
gosh but look at the kid he's pleading
his case
yeah clearly three Puck Coach Johnson
definitely not happy about this call
five minutes into the fourth quarter
third and ten the Rhinos again
threatening to score can the Cougars
hold them big play coming here Bill
Ransom takes the snap drops back he
floats one into the end zone and
mcgregleberry pulls it down he's got it
oh my gosh for his second touchdown of
the day for this rookie he has got to be
feeling great about himself I'll tell
you man he's oh let's see now there's
two pumps yeah he's really testing the
boundaries and he's clearly gotten the
ref's attention here a third pump will
draw a flag no matter what
what is that the second time now you
have to flag him on him yeah he had to
you know Bill it's just frustrating
seeing young players without the ability
to restrain themselves it really is it's
hard I mean the ref's going to get you
every time yeah yeah absolutely uh see
now the ref agrees that's three pumps
right there
and the quarterback Ransom under Center
last five minutes of the game rhinos are
Marching here again hard to stop this
team from scoring bill they have so many
weapons
Ransom takes the snap and it's a shovel
pass the mccringleberry oh he's at the
ten he's at the five and touchdown Rhino
oh my great block by hard Duncan and
that's going to be tough for the Cougars
to come back from boy what a career day
from hengelman crinkleberry the rookie
out of Penn State oh he's just amazingly
fired up here today Jeff you gotta love
the way this guy plays and he Oh see now
there's one pump oh well I cannot
believe this kid you gotta put your team
first in situations like this and the
kringleberries just not doing it now
there's two Jeff now if he pops a third
time he will draw his third penalty for
today
everybody here waiting with Betty breath
okay yeah that's what it is yes you can
argue all you want but the flag well
it's been thrown that's right if it's
three pumps the ref's not gonna take it
away no it's not duration and intensity
doesn't make any difference Jeff let's
have a look at the replay here to see if
indeed he did do the three pumps all
right no question there is the first one
yeah right agreed right and then coming
up
is the second one okay yes very clear
it's the third we'll see it it's coming
up right here oh yeah you're right
there's absolutely three pumps there
oh uh apologies to all those watching
with young children uh clearly you will
be in room 237.
and you have free Wi-Fi there also from
6 a.m to 10 a.m every morning there's a
free continental breakfast
continental breakfast yes from 6 a.m to
10 A.M
so it's Continental then
very good
like Garcon
a one admission for the continental
breakfast you can just help yourself sir
interesting European style
[Music]
When in Rome
the forbidden fruit
well aren't you a tiny plum
[Music]
well la di da
vapor and everything
and who are you my little friend not a
spoon
not a fork but something in between a
fapoon
but will you think of next Germany
[Music]
both the European countries lay before
me
where should I fly to First
the pit of the donut
thank you turkey
buckled up let's see where we shall go
next ah the Danish
clearly from Brussels
um
hello Greece where the yogurt flows like
water
yes
like go good but to stay
so good
I'm pulling into space
[Music]
oh baked to Perfection can you believe
this it all comes with the room
oh no
[Music]
I love being incontinent
I love being in Carlton and the right to
the senses this is my friend
isn't it yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's so good
dude I gotta tell you something
last night on show times
I saw some Lethal Weapon too Lethal
Weapon 2 starring the racist ass smelly
Gibson no I know but I gotta tell you
right up front and truthfully
racist as Melody Gibson is still kind of
nice
[Music]
I don't know dog racist I smell the
gifts I know I know but think about it
man think about it remember where he
jacked up all their mutants in the Road
Warriors talking about Earth
yeah and then remember when he had taken
out Hatchet and chopped up all them
England's remember in the Patriots and
did it in front of all his kids you know
what oh
race assessment Gibson says [ __ ] Number
One race success Milly Gibson's was Blue
Man Group and bravehearts oh my God they
was chopping off my man's head my man
was still talking about the freedom
or what about conspiracy theories though
what oh come on what the [ __ ] about
conspiracy theories though
what the [ __ ] about conspiracy theories
come on you know racist that smelly
gifts to be directing too how's yeah
what about Apocalypto yo racist ass
Melody Gibson's be telling the story of
a bunch of crazy ass old-fashioned
Mexican who have been in the jungle
getting chased by a panther
and what about their passions under
Christ passions of the Christ though
passions are passions of the price where
races as Millie Gibson's made that movie
about Jesus in a kind of racist ass way
I was on my jam when you know what I
just realized though what's that you
know what would be my but what would be
if racist ass Melody Gibson's co-starred
in a movie with Jesus you talking about
the savior of all the king of all kids
the Alpha and the Omega and Jesus
she
[Music]
was telling you it's totally legal these
doctors don't prescribe medical
marijuana to anyone man what do I tell
them I need it for he doesn't
want to give you prescription it's how
they get paid just make something up
hey Mr Washington welcome Hey doctor or
I'm going to ask a couple questions
what age
AIDS as in uh as in I got it need lots
of weed to get rid of it
okay okay AIDS
um wow all right uh are you are you sure
you're not suffering from anything else
like you know back pain nope anxiety
cool as a cucumber how about insomnia
sleep like a baby
with AIDS okay Mr Watson let's just slow
your roll for a second here if you had
AIDS then I would have to verify it by
saying test results whereas if you have
back pain or anxiety or anything else
that I can't test for then I can give
you this prescription for cannabis right
now oh understand oh yeah I see I guess
my bad okay so leprosy no no because if
you had leprosy I'd have to quarantine
you ouch what do you no okay I see your
fingers falling off don't do that though
that's not gonna work scurvy nope
Ricketts what no consumption no Mr
Washington something from this Century
schizophrenia no you don't have
schizophrenia just you keep it simple
please
what the hell is that I don't know what
that is a fish hook in my lip just pick
something off this list I can't reach it
why not paralyzed
does your face hurt Mr Washington yeah
then this should help
now first
let me just say that I'm encouraged that
so many of you from the Republican Party
have agreed to meet me in this way
now as you know I've tried very hard to
reach across the aisle
govern this country from the middle well
all due respect Mr President
we disagree with you
we think you should run the country from
not the middle well that's why we're
here if you would I'd just appreciate
some feedback on some new ideas and
directions for this country feel free to
agree or disagree whatever you want
we're gonna disagree
disagree
first
I think the government is too big
I think we need to shrink the size of
the federal government so that all
decisions can be made at the state level
we disagree Mr President
you drive a hard bargain you win
there we go
big government it is
next up
this has been a hot button issue but I
think we can settle it right here
no taxes for rich people we completely
disagree round two goes to you guys
okay
more taxes for the rich
what the [ __ ] what is happening to us
and I am taking a beating here guys all
right last issue immigration
now we need to secure our borders and
anybody who's here illegally should be
hunted down and deported
if we disagree
[Music]
we are a country of immigrants no we
need a clear path to citizenship for all
of those who are already here
help me
[Music]
great I love your ideas lastly we cannot
regulate firearms
[Music]
all right all right you gotta say
something and nobody better throw me a
cigarette
ain't I a stinker
[Music]
not just another streaming app what this
is
this is not even funny are you choking
me bro this is daily late and lately
this is real roasted and raw give it to
me now this is great stand-up great
movies and the great cornholio are you
threatening me no this is one pump two
pumps and three pumps this is live
sports breaking news and a mountain of
Comedy entertainment Paramount plus now
streaming
foreign
live from a gruesome scene a cult known
as qet or quest for Eternal truth has
apparently taken their own lives in a
mass suicide police confirmed that
cyanide laced Cherry Kool-Aid was also
on the premises excuse me hi Rick
nicholsby's channel six hi are you two
from the neighborhood oh yes
yes
okay were you two members of The Cult
that lived here was this a cocoa I had
no idea this was a cold although I will
say the term cult is a little judgmental
I would say the same thing yeah not
knowing the full Doctrine well
apparently they believed that there was
a spaceship waiting for them behind the
moon okay well you know that that still
is really possible and it's possible
right I mean who knows what is out there
in the universe okay well it appears
they killed themselves in order to board
the ship right and that's where we
disagreed with them right there or would
have we would have disagreed with them
had we been there on on our departure
day their departure day their departure
day which is the day-to-day did this I
mean that's what you could call it if
you wanted to but I ain't in no call no
I mean what what I always wondered is
how or am starting to wonder since you
brought this to our attention why if
there was a spaceship in the sky why
wouldn't it just Beam us up beam them up
just beam them up why can't you just
beam them up alive why you got to be
dead to get beamed up you know what I'm
saying I've been saying that for weeks
seconds for seconds because because you
Rick Nichols B you told us that uh you
know and that's how I knew because
seconds ago you said I didn't know
anything about it until you had said it
because I ain't in no call okay well
then why would someone join a cult
leadership you know like a compelling
person
I mean hypothetically they could have
had tacos on Tuesday which would have
been a draw I mean I would have been a
problem okay so this is a tragic day for
this community and for the members of
the Quest for Earthly truth I'm Rick
nicholsby reporting
we're ready
foreign
[Music]
just wanted to come say hello that's it
that is all have a nice night so where
are you going girl you can't leave
without coming inside
oh no I wouldn't want to be an intrusion
I just wanted to say hello goodbye there
is a seat in this house with your name
on it girl no no no no no no no no no no
no I can't I didn't have money for the
bus I'm a mess from the 50 mile walk by
must you be so difficult girl you're
right I am being difficult aren't I your
life is better without me coming in
trust me so there I go okay girl listen
everything is Irene man we're good
friends all right of course you know you
can smell it girl you know you smell it
girl you know you're smelling the fried
dumplings Aki and a salt fish girl no
boys come over here
that's it too I'm formally inviting you
into my home now come inside
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Rafi just got out of treatment remember
we don't want to trigger him with Denny
slapas
they're going on here
why are we all acting at the funeral
here no nothing uh Rafi you just caught
us in the Lull in the conversation man
we're happy
I was gonna say for a second because I
mean that was a good game not a good
game hey good game
good game man
good game
okay
there's an elephante in the room
you know I want to talk about
see I had a problem
and my lowest point
I will sneak into a horse's stable
when you find yourself at 1am in the
morning with your hand in the air
and all this ass in front of your face
that's when you know it's bad
but I'm okay now
I'm all better guys honestly just treat
me like I'm normal okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay here
you can pick up your glass
[Music]
hey what I told you huh it's just normal
guys come on I think I'm fine I'm more
better now you guys can do the normal
stuff be yourself Bend things over pick
things up you know do your stretching
touch your toes you're stupid
foreign
my name is Reuben
I just came over from the the Braves
farm team and from the Dominican
Republic
I'm really excited to be working and
playing with you all go rhinos
welcome to the squad thank you
all right
we're gonna need a bigger boat
what the uh
really put your locker room right next
to my locker huh I guess so yeah
a lot of time down there you know hey I
have a lot of stuff yeah a lot I see
that huh
oh my goodness
you okay there buddy not looking too
good
really I have feel another flushed you
know I got a good feeling about you
maybe we could be good friends maybe
even the best of friends
maybe another time
another place
I'm not here
not now
well either way what team is and so
anything I can do for you
ask away got it okay go Rhino okay oh
[Music]
I am so excited
I'm so excited
I know
okay I know
it was just too hard to resist okay
[Music]
are you okay
[Music]
hey guys you know maybe after a game
Victory we can all go dancing right
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
so I'm doing this like airline food diet
it's like oh I ate and I've lost like 16
pounds oh my God Amy I almost forgot to
tell you we got a new receptionist at
work ew no way yeah so I'm in the common
area alone I need my own business yeah
oh she said something to you she came up
to me and no joke she's like hi I'm
Sandy I don't believe we've met you oh
she said that to you no Amy I'm not even
kidding you she's crazy yeah no like I'm
scared like crazy like get this [ __ ]
away from me she's sociopathically
batshit crazy oh my God that totally
reminds me I have a new neighbor ew yeah
she comes over my house she knocks in
the door with like a package under her
arm um stalker much um yeah and she
looks me in the eye and she says to me
um excuse me I think the postman dropped
this package off at my house by accident
she said that to you yeah crazy bad I
mean like I'm gonna have to move because
this bitch's nut Burgers make Looney
Tunes stand at the foot of my bed with a
knife crazy oh my God that totally
reminds me oh yeah you remember that
girl at Starbucks the crazy one no a
different one she's new I haven't met
her yet crazy she gives me my change and
then she's like thanks bye
smiled at you like that how crazy is
that that's like that's like insane in
the membrane crazy like this is the
membrane she's inside of it because
that's insane no like I'm not even
kidding you Amy that's crazy like it
puts the lotion in the basket or else it
gets the hose again cray to the
[ __ ] yeah like if Jay-Z had a
sister her name would be Craig
you ladies want to meet Channing Tatum
is he really in there serious oh
Channing Channing what are you doing in
a van effing crazy I don't see you
chatting why are you hiding in here
Channing are you like in a little box
[Music]
is that a meat hook
I'm the leader of the Free World
[Music]
everybody Focus up look this party
tonight could be a model for the way
that the world should work
and I just want to say
I'm totally stoked to the max about it
all right you guys feeling good yeah
Dennis what are you shooting video yeah
man all right well be careful with that
I might run for office someday
okay now trust me I think that this
party can be the most inspirational
party this campus has ever seen is that
coming to me and just grab that
some righteous Bud some righteous but we
got going on there we need some
Bodacious jock babes coming in yeah we
need some hot ass punk rock babes I I
don't care where they come from the most
important thing it's imperative
that we have a diversity in the uh a
[ __ ] Department intercepted don't sleep
on burial
don't ever sleep on burial
that is some major dobage
apartheid is totally gnarly
it's a gnarly institution where is he
that is that there we go come here get
this get this okay we gotta have a
system in place to get everybody weed
all right so just watch this is how
you're gonna do it all right this this
is I'm really Frosty right now by the
way this is your Constitution all right
it's just a piece of paper we got to
keep its Integrity because it's going to
hold everything together this right here
this is us this is the American people
we're special we're magic hello yay yay
we all live in here all right the most
important thing is that we don't get too
far apart I mean you we got to be close
that's that's the magic of America's
love otherwise they're gonna get air
bubbles in there it's gonna start
canoeing and everything we don't want
that all right you get that all right
look
my way ahead of you but I'm already done
boom fireworks Fourth of July that's for
you we won like 10 of these
what was I saying
foreign
[Music]
pieces of me cause I run this whole
block with these Rhymes and this Glide
make this whole damn hood tick this my
town I'm the top [ __ ] of the water I'm
the boss and the King [ __ ] kissing my
ass and [ __ ] kissing my ring what's
up
I'm the leader of the Free World
thank you
[Applause]
president hi
thank you and may God bless America
introductions with the chat here this is
John O'Rourke nice to meet you John Mr
Ian Roberts nice to meet you Peter
tencio all right nice to meet you Jerome
Smith
brother what's up fam
oh you know this Keith Williamson nice
to meet you Mary Woodbury nice to meet
you Jay Martel nice to meet you sir
Tasha Robbins come on come on come on
feel that Emily George
nice to meet you Daryl Stokes come on
what's up fam how you doing all right
never forget about that because that's
all we got
nice to meet you all right
start from the bottom now we're here
yeah
nice to meet you all right nice to meet
you all right
good afternoon my octoroon come on bring
it in there yeah
I'm in there
come in here
I'm in there all right all right nice to
meet you man uh nice to meet you oh my
goodness look at this oh she is so
beautiful
um
I want another one there you go precious
beautiful beautiful what's her name oh
this is Olivia Ruby okay nice to meet
you Miss rougie
all right now come on
all right very good to meet you all
right here we go right this way sir
[Music]
10 minutes okay the number pressing no
no just hold on a second Malia all right
just hold on
sorry everyone I was taking so long you
know
oh Obama Obama how you doing sir
it's me just showing my daughter how to
use the ATM having a little trouble with
the machine oh you're having trouble
with the machine oh man we Champion
which of him right now man so you can be
on your way no no no no no no no I'm
trying to show Malia what life is like
in the real world here all right so just
do me a favor treat me like you would
anyone else in this situation okay yes
sir yes sir all right
not exactly what I have in mind
what you can
damn come on girl hurry up man you got
seven oh okay no take your time take
your time take your time
all right you're doing fine sweetie
now uh Malia let's just go easy on the
gas here and come to a complete stop
so in the future you want to try not to
go through stop sign
okay just remain calm now and what
you're going to want to do is pull up
right here next to the curb
this is why we want to stay in the lines
and we want to follow rules
remember this
license and registration
holy Mr President yeah yeah just
teaching Malia to drive well you guys
ran a stop sign back there but that's
okay you can go oh no no no no no
Malia's got to learn what it's like to
drive in the real world here now this is
called consequences Malia now I want you
to go ahead and treat us like you would
if I weren't the president
not exactly what I had in mind
[Music]
[Music]
oh honey I am tired I am going to bed
good night
uh
well
is everything okay
well it's uh it's just that I was uh
hoping that uh
well that we could and uh I want to make
this clear
uh I want to be uh straightforward I
want to uh
have a okay uh Luther are you available
to translate yes ma'am
foreign
some time together what is
what is in this house well you have been
very busy lately
[Music]
you know what
if I could can we get your translator oh
yes certainly uh katendra
yeah honey could you please translate
well you have been very busy lately
sure
ain't one of your limousines that you
can jump in and out of whenever you feel
like I don't see you all day then you
want a booty call
I need an emotional connection
thought this was uh romantic
an engraved imitation from my nuts maybe
we should make a date
jump out of my clothes every time little
bear it stands that attention you ain't
my commander-in-chief mother and my
vagina ain't some cave in the Middle
East you can fly your heat-seeking
missile into whenever you feel like it
well
I didn't mean to call you but I had
meetings all day long I'm dealing with
these mother [ __ ] Republicans hearing
no no no all day long then I come home
and you're not gonna let me get my jam
on up in here well you know I have had a
busy day too you act like I ain't got
nothing else to do
I got these obese [ __ ] on my
ass 24 7. what's more important you
getting your wig dipped or some
eight-year-old fat ass collapsing his
bunk bed okay you seem to be forgetting
job number one you are my secretary of
[ __ ] get to work
you
um
yes sir we'll uh we'll take it from here
absolutely yes sir thank you
oh
oh
this feels good
um Mom Dad I know you already said that
I can't go but can I please go to the
party tonight Malia use your translator
if you don't let me go to this party I
will get a tattoo on my face have fun
[Music]
now first
let me just say that I'm encouraged that
so many of you from the Republican Party
have agreed to meet me in this way
now as you know I've tried very hard to
reach across the aisle
govern this country from the middle well
all due respect Mr President
we disagree with you
we think you should run the country from
not the middle well that's why we're
here if you would I'd just appreciate
some feedback on some new ideas and
directions for this country feel free to
agree or disagree whatever you want
we're gonna disagree
disagree
first
I think the government is too big
I think we need to shrink the size of
the federal government so that all
decisions can be made at the state level
we disagree Mr President
you drive a hard bargain you win
there we go
big government it is
and next up
this has been a hot button issue but I
think we can settle it right here
no taxes for rich people we completely
disagree round two goes to you guys
okay
more taxes for the rich
what the [ __ ] what is happening to us
and I am taking a beating here guys all
right last issue immigration now we need
to secure our borders and anybody who's
here illegally should be hunted down and
deported
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
great I love your ideas lastly we cannot
regulate firearms
we're here
all right all right you gotta say
something and nobody better throw me a
cigarette
ain't I a stinker
[Music]
we're here talking with All-Star
shooting guard Charlie Sanders about his
amazing career now Charlie you grew up
in a tough neighborhood didn't you
that's right
drugs violence
my whole life I had to deal with
adversity and that continued when you
went on to the pros that's right you
know fines injuries everything no matter
how big a star I am
I'm always going to be dealing with
adversity adversity Johnson what's your
take on this I don't know girl I just
[Music]
died
always wherever we go it's
come on no don't don't drink my water
don't drink my water at first you leave
me some leave me a sip leave me a sip
damn come on man this
he doesn't I'm sorry
no he doesn't pick up social cues
what here we
go
[Applause]
come on are you okay no what a
mind-blowing finish to an incredible
game tonight with Charlie Sanders
winning the game in literally the last
second uh unbelievable truly spectacular
Charlie Sanders how does it feel hey
y'all want to say something to everybody
watching yo you can do anything
anything's possible The World is Yours
Charlie did you think that that game was
gonna end that way tonight no there are
no limits all right you can swim across
here learning you can jump real high and
touch the moon fantastic Charlie Sanders
fresh off of his uh Victory uh just feel
like he's ready to touch the move I can
fly anybody can fly if you believe in
yourself the way I believe in myself
tonight you will fly and what's next for
Charlie Sanders and the orange fans you
can actually fly no no not well not
literally yes literally kids young kids
I want you to go up on your roofs right
now wait what fly into the night sky
okay people will see you flying and you
can do anything you can do anything okay
well we we just want to remind the kids
that of course you cannot actually fly
kids oh y'all screw that negativity man
hey boys and girls ages 8 through 12. yo
don't let nobody ever tell you what you
can and cannot do all them pre-teen
children out there listen to my voice
you are Immortal okay well obviously we
understand that Charlie is super excited
right now and that no one is actually
Immortal
cause you could turn yourself into a car
and have a friend drive you onto the
freeway okay no well that's just a
metaphor kid it's not just a minute we
don't have the power of childish
innocence get a friend on your back and
make a beat along for the next ramp to
the freeway y'all okay don't do it
anymore he's speaking figure it out once
you get there ain't nothing bigger him
about this you will turn into a robot
first and foremost I just want to say
the 12 families who lost children
sorry
my statements were irresponsible
I have subsequently looked up the terms
literally and metaphorically
and found that
whereas I was not incorrect they did not
mean what I thought they had meant
Brown
was like you sure I've ever seen in my
life
why you reading [ __ ]
because I like to read and this is a
really good book you're a really good
[ __ ] [ __ ] why you gotta bother me man
because
I'm not doing very well at school I'm
reading at a third grade level I really
don't want to get left back so when I
see somebody breeding for fun
it makes me feel that much more stupid
and then I get mad
[Music]
um I didn't know that thanks so much for
opening up to me shut up queer
I understand what I mean why you got to
go there
I've been having sexual fantasies about
some of the other guys at school give me
that
I'm afraid of these feelings and what
they might mean it's like because I hate
myself so much I gotta point that hate
outward towards you
[Music]
okay
you understand this on such a deep level
that I don't understand
now I'm gonna punish you physically for
acknowledging my emotional problems I
was going to say if you understand
yourself so well then maybe you should
try working on changing it of course I
want to change it
but it's the only defense mechanism I
have against deeper more terrifying
problems buried inside of me
lucky my Dad's here get the damn truck
son I need to take you home and beat on
you because I hate myself and you look
like your mother who left me and I'm a
block out the guilt I feel over
mistreating you with the river vodka
I'm gonna internalize that and
unknowingly transfer it onto you
tomorrow
[Music]
reluctantly
[Music]
let's get this party started ladies and
gentlemen this is Paramount Plus
genius beautiful games and One Shining
Moment this is Defenders investigators
and seven strangers picked them in a
house this is Young SpongeBob young
Sheldon and the younger this is ever you
been looking for it's gonna leave a mark
live sports breaking news and a mountain
of entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now streaming
foreign
[Music]
I would like a rum and coke
Roman Coke coming up
[Music]
where you from
all right baby I'm gonna see on the
dance floor girl
ah
rum and Coke eight dollars eight dollars
all right my good man let me
wow
let me oh my God I got it
just
okay all right
I tell you what third time's the time
brother
just take the card out keep that open
for me can you hang on to that apartment
we'll do in fact let me get a tequila
shot but actually make it two man one
for me and one for you my good man
two tequila shots coming right up how
you doing girl all right necta of the
guys up in here all right all right
let's get that going down
all right cheers
cheers
more than one way to skin a cat you want
some help with that hold up let me just
try to get it
[Applause]
[Music]
right you know what what ah I'm gonna
get you one of these yeah yeah try that
yeah we all right hey you a gen
e
you know
you buy your own deals my dollar
all right move just around here yep
Hey
so uh I'm worried about you oh now I'm
gonna tell you what I'm worried about
I'm wearing this club ain't popping up
the way it should be
because wait a second what oh DJ Turn It
Up that's my trap right there
hey man a bar is not the place for you
to be right now
[Music]
oh
let me get two more shots
sorry pal you're 86. what how what now
and what best part let's go buddy
how you doing girl
first time I think
it's like 87 as a two guys in a
heavyweight power yeah no it was the
first time in a heavyweight bout that
the uh the two fighters ended up getting
married
hello my good sir I like to have two
shots out there
come on by the way yeah oh Mark oh man
yeah
right now I don't even know Claire yeah
I'm sorry you left your jacket yeah well
why don't you give us your new fat ugly
girlfriend I didn't even matter yet
whatever you left your jacket me again
throw it in a river why would I do that
I'm not fine
God
[Applause]
me again
drinks for everybody as soon as she
comes over I mean who does that you can
come back to the bar you're literally
how is that possible I can't be an
[ __ ] I got arms and legs and a head
where's my jacket I have no jacket do
you want it no you know what yeah eat it
why would I do that you know what I'm
not following you anymore I'm done over
it fine
Megan come back to the bar yeah
come here
Megan do you want your jacket no
seriously come back to the bar
I'm gonna throw this jacket in the water
oh nice that's really nice what do you
want me to do me again damn kiss my
butthole okay good fine fine then I'm
going I'm leaving right now
God damn it
no like seriously your jacket yeah but
it's your jacket though
[Music]
I have your
I have your jacket
seriously me
[Music]
all right listen Sheriff's Department's
close by we'll be safe there okay stay
close I'll get you out of here
they didn't get us okay we're still
alive
all right keep it together yeah okay we
gotta make it to the sheriff station
oh my God
[Music]
[Music]
we gotta go through them just stay
together keep moving and don't get bit
go
[Music]
are you getting this yo what is up all
right let's go
crazy
[Music]
wow
what
um
[Music]
these are some racist [ __ ]
zombies why would you even lock the door
I mean the window's broken and oh
oh hell no no no no no
um oh what is that they seriously
wouldn't let her eat us
hey guys
isn't this great
these racist zombies are leaving us
alone
come on we having a party
[Music]
the beer is here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
economy Plus
for the Discerning passengers
[Music]
we're not in Kansas anymore
[Music]
good morning ladies and gentlemen we are
about to begin boarding South Northern
Airlines flight 34 to Grand Rapids
excuse me 40 group one I'm an important
group one excuse me I'm in boarding
group one
getting pre-boarding with our first
class passengers first-class passengers
only please
next are business class passengers may
now board
okay now we would like to welcome our
Regal Alliance Elite members Regal
Alliance Elite members
okay now all passengers with children
anyone with small children you'll be
bored now
okay we would like to continue boarding
with uniformed military personnel what
why kids
thank you for your service thank you so
much for your service God bless you
thank you for your service thank you for
your service
all right people in wheelchairs
any priests nuns rabbis imams what why
do they get special treatment assalamu
alaikum I've never
that's typical any old people in
wheelchairs with babies
[Music]
any old religious people with military
babies what's a military
thank you
thank you for your service
Jason Schwartzman
anyone with a blue suitcase you may now
board finally no not you sir not me this
is a blue suitcase that's a blue
computer bag so you're not you're not
gonna let me on then
God damn it
anyone who doesn't seem cranky
drunk people who will now be boarding
any drunk people
drunk people
nope it's my man sir
it's
just
foreign
hello
oh hey Christian
yeah
totally
well you have your favorites and I have
my favorites
okay
call you later
cow cow
Ard group one
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
over here
to the boarding group one
that's it and he talks too much that's
why I like you you don't talk you just
listening it's good
Captain has turned on The Fast and seat
belt sign got a little turbulence coming
up should be no problem just remaining
your seat until the sign is turned off
thank you for your cooperation
hi excuse me yeah yeah I need you to
take your seat the fast and seatbelt
sign is on yeah I'm just gonna go to the
bathroom for a second I'll be right back
okay I understand what you want to do
unfortunately I'm gonna need you to
observe the fast and seat belt cyan
that'd be much appreciated
right it's just I read on the internet
that it's not against the law for me to
go to the bathroom while the fast and
seat belt sign is on so
but is it against the law though
the light is on
against the law
you see that there's a picture of a seat
belt on that side no but is it against
the law
but is it against her father
sign but is it against the lights on
Amazon
long difficult you're being very
difficult
not illegal not illegal not illegal okay
illegal illegal
sir I have to piss and I have to in the
toilet can you lower your voice I have
to
have potentity you're louder than me
you're yelling
he needs to tone it down right now you
are screaming at me you're hurting
my ear drops
that wasn't a word you're not saying a
word this is a word
that's not that's not a word that's a
tongue trick
okay sir sir if you would like I would
not like to
I would not like to sit down what I'd
like to do
is go take the bathroom
because
it's not against
the law
so I'm gonna go to the bathroom
okay
mark
with a k
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
and your captain has turned off the
fastened seat belt sign feel free to
move around the cabin
thank you for your cooperation
oh excuse me sir are you sitting in 26g
yes have I done something wrong no no no
we just wanted to ask if you would mind
switching seats so that a mother and a
child could sit together
and back there right yeah but you'd
actually be sitting here
which is an economy Plus
um It's actually an upgrade
upgrade you say
economy plus yes sir oh
don't mind if we do great great I'll
carry on
carry on yourself Alex
thank you
[Music]
the economy Plus
for the Discerning passengers
[Music]
we're not in Kansas anymore
like we're gonna have a smooth flight
trust me I know the captain
and he's one smooth guy
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
of course he knows the captain
he is the captain Oh oh oh
move over Colin mockery there's a new
face in the biz his name is Captain
I have to be an economy plus to cut it I
guess
[Music]
extra foot room
one inch at least
foreign
[Music]
Lord of the Rings cups
Lord of the Rings tables
[Music]
awesome massage
economy plus it hurts a little but but I
like it
froze
[Music]
thank you
and I thought I had an upgrade
yo
hey y'all
onion
Young
excuse me
oh man oh man oh man
I tell you one thing if 9 11's were to
happen up on this airplane
don't worry we got this
okay I have no idea what you're talking
about
he said and that fdm Terry's is gonna
try some up in here today like the
bounce Boogie and bump
that we got dick
sir do you mean terrorists oh yeah hell
yeah baby he ain't talking about Terry
God and I certainly ain't talking about
no terry cloth I mean if a Terry up on
this plane he was thinking about trying
to do something we're gonna clap him up
you're gonna you're gonna what we're
gonna Drax
I know
Scouts
I think when my partner's trying to say
is if any terries come up in here we
gonna get our Bergeron
did something happen or did I
missed something as hypothetical or oh
we're going definitely Drive some
hypotheticals on that Terry's clavicle
because I'm talking about
squeeze squeeze squeeze
to death wish so don't you just wish in
your heart a heart thumb Terry would
come up in here trying some grab ass and
the touchy feeling that's the opposite
of what I want to have happen on a plane
okay that's unfortunate
conference
this was unexpected certainly was I'm
thrown right now as to who's gonna be
our comrade I can still hear you he
doesn't have the heart nor the gumption
literally right next to me oh three
break three
you who
I got an idea feel free to say no but
can we switch seats I will not take no
for an answer
why that's the combat seat Jonathan
Livingston Sego
if you're going to be in the combat seat
then you got to be willing to blast up
on some carries because with great power
come great response a trilograms
okay I just I just wanted some leg room
um okay Max legroom you get yours
meanwhile I'm gonna go hating pants in
the Airy awesome Terrys especially when
they get froggy
maybe maybe
um you gonna have to be ready to kidnap
a Terry I don't you're gonna have to be
ready to touch you I can't I don't think
that's necessary absolutely you have to
fire board those mother gems I don't
even understand what that means do you
trust me no
I'll take that as a yes okay trust
these terries come up in here trying to
act froggy then we gonna give them the
Rainbow Connection
box color oh you best believe it baby we
gonna be eating like Diane Keaton
2.350 inches baby you should wax
perfectly League wow
and if those don't work
you know I'm working up that plan leave
brother
[Music]
baby 100
polyurethane they can't detect these
commandment generals
right
oh my God
[Applause]
[Music]
Drax
hello
Scouts
with this bandana
I welcome you to the game yo
hold up oh okay what's going on hey
kalito I was just welcoming Eduardo into
the game
why
who he what he did
he's he's crazy man we were thinking
that the gang missed a crazy guy yeah I
mean this guy is local Eduardo
yeah
no no I'm the local one in this game
what okay okay check this out
quack quack quack I'm a duck no no no
I'm a crazy duck no Carlito Carlito it's
not that kind of local okay that's more
like you know zany or or goofy yeah it's
the wrong kind of Loco you want to see
Loco perito
you're not crazy you're like Guy The
Quiet One I'm not quiet and never
because being quiet in fact I'm always
loud check it
oh
okay okay that was weird
were you yelling I saw your loco right
here right now in broad daylight yeah
I got Telecom on my underwear that's the
black fish I'm naked and I don't even
careful you gotta pull them up okay it's
like children in this neighborhood okay
okay but check this out I got nine
punched cars from Froyo Universe each
with a one stamp in it every time I get
a froyo I get a new card yeah Carlito
that's just being Cavalier with your
finances instead of collecting your free
dessert I mean that's not local that's
just like financially irresponsible I
might not be local but you know who is
local
my friend Mr basura head
dumping the garbage hey I'm the most
local person in here
why would you do that okay Carlito
Carlito you don't have to do this okay
it's not necessary you're not the local
one
check this out
I feel yeah I'm crazy I'm the local one
oh
Carlito please don't do it again
this is like watching the British
version of the office like it's funny
but awkward and sad at the same time yes
well I think I just proved this battle
is Unbreakable
Carlito
you're embarrassing yourself look at
this noise Carlito what are you going to
do with that I don't know I'm too crazy
why would you do that man that was local
but not in an entertaining way okay
questions
no I'm the most local in the game
yes Carlito by process of elimination
you are the most local person in the
game
yes
[Music]
hi everybody I'm Dave stast alongside
Jeff Worthing and welcome to the annual
East West Bowl as we get ready to watch
some of the best college players in the
nation showcase their skills in a
classic showdown between east and west
and there really are some characters on
this year's squads aren't there Jeff
that's right Dave it does seem like the
most flamboyant personalities came to
the Forefront and they are here let's
meet the players from the East
[Music]
Demarcus Williams University of Georgia
T.J Jackson Wayne State University
tavariousness King Merrimack College top
Royals smoochie Wallace University Miami
dasquerius green Jr University of Notre
Dame Ibrahim Moore Zeus University of
Tennessee at Chattanooga Jack Mary's
Tech theratrix Michigan State University
the isaiaht buildings Coastal Carolina
University The Jasper probe and Crux III
South Carolina State University
Leos Maxwell Jr East Carolina University
jamaris Jamar jamaris and Lamar
University of Middle Tennessee devoine
shower handle
University of Southern Mississippi
kringleberry Penn State University
the carpetron Duke Marriott
Florida Atlantic University
of South Florida Xmas Jackson flexing
waxing California University of
Pennsylvania
[Music]
we're going to be looking for big plays
all game long from tyrol smoochie
Wallace and let's not forget the tight
ends Ibraham moisus and hengel
mccringleberry they've both had amazing
Seasons That's Right Jeff now let's meet
the players from the West
[Music]
vegetarian Jefferson
Texas A M the cluster her doctor
University of Wisconsin
swarvathon L Goodings flat
Saskatchewan University crotchville
Quattro San Jose State University
buckshank
Stanford University these are 12 washing
beards Jones college
Shakira Quan TGIF Carter University of
Northern Arizona X Wayne at aliciousness
Missouri Western State University
sequester grundleplitt MD Adam State
scores Velociraptor malloy's South
Dakota State University TJ AJ RJ
backslashes fourth the fifth Albion
College
San Diego State University donkey teeth
Boise State University torque
Louis
Nevada state
Penitentiary the player formerly known
as Mouse cop
University of Missouri Columbia Dan
Smith BYU
[Music]
I'm Dave stassen alongside Jeff Worthing
and welcome to the 2013 East West Bowl
where we're going to be watching some of
the best college athletes in the nation
try to put last year's spectacle to
shame that's right Dave it won't be easy
but this year's seniors certainly will
be trying to give last year's Stars a
run for their money let's check out the
team starting with the players from the
East
yeah
cause Nestor Smith Rutgers University
ellipses quarter University of Alabama
now aquilis Dale why LSU bismo Funyuns
Florida State University
Murgatroyd Scandal University of
Louisville quitting the Todd Business
University of Tennessee
Ole Miss quack
Auburn University Julius Boozer
the you Muscatine Tristan University of
Michigan fall Trail plugins University
of Arkansas
fear too cartoons plural Virginia Tech
Jammy Jammy Jammy V Ohio State
University
food
foreign
some of the big stories this year the
meteoric rise of the Pez poopsie and
let's not forget about Heisman winner
Jammy Jammy Jammy and remember you can't
talk about 2013 without bringing up
fudge everybody's talking about fudge at
350 pounds this running back is almost
Unstoppable the whole year you're right
I could talk about fudge all day but
first let's meet the players from the
West
[Music]
equine ducklings
Indiana University Purdue University
Indianapolis Daw historius La mistorius
Utah State University
Oklahoma State University Exquisite team
bubbleish Winslow University of Nebraska
-lakanaka hakanaka hika hakapaga
University of Hawaii King Prince
chambermaid
Baylor University
University of Colorado
University of Arizona Harvard University
DeVry University
[Laughter]
Army
Navy Surplus Store
Wing Days
online classes first name last name
College University God
home school squeeze
Santa Monica College
Benedict's Cumberbatch
third University A.A Ron bolake
Morehouse College
check out Leos
I wonder what he's dreaming about he is
probably dreaming about what we is going
to do to the team from the West
I wonder
[Music]
Tavarius Smith's T King for short I'm a
bad mama Jenna and an awful sport
Smoochy Wallace you could call me Ty
Royal wrapping up Russians like aluminum
foil the queen goes
I'm scaring if I got the ball you best
be wary the carpetron Duke Marriott I
love the ball so much I wanna marry
foreign
[Music]
my name power candle sounds the same
with Jack Mary the swearing Lamar black
and white can play Saxon Demarcus plays
guitar
[Music]
okay don't you know
[Music]
indeed we are the best
it must have been all a dream
or was it
[Music]
oh it's on
[Music]
the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but y'all ain't right ain't ready for my
man Dan Smith
yo yo Smith comma Daniel I think it gets
in the league don't hold a candle
cheerleaders up I'm a chocolate crunches
goddamn baby cocker spaniel BYU y-uv mad
cause the [ __ ] wanna get with me got
Swisher Sweets and budgies rolling
numbers
blinded been drunk when I punted been
like a hundred times that I already
see these haters thought I was playing
staying away from my faces with all the
bullets they're saying but just remember
I'm talking when you tossing those
gauntlets from Dan Smith and the West is
getting rowdy like Monsters
hey baby
hey baby
[Music]
it's gonna be for you
you keep it there's more where that came
from too
trust me
that's my girl oh damn I'm straight up
talking about some Daryl Dawkins right
here because this and chocolate thunder
what girl make it rain
yeah oh yeah I gotta make it last
[Music]
all right girl um I'm gonna get it right
in the booty right there uh and put it
as well that's what you call a booty
investment
brother you really don't need to uh uh
give them that much I I don't think
they're expecting all that
it's kind of like feeding a squirrel you
know I mean they will come back to you
so oh oh oh oh my gosh some of this is
getting lost let's get it right where it
needs to be right in there baby oh yeah
keep it classy keep it classy oh
somebody better get an umbrella cause I
can't stop making it rain it's like it's
like Noah's flood over here two by two
baby two by two
maybe you don't know that I'm the
general because it's storming Norman
that's what they'd be calling me
[Music]
bam anyway like I said
when you finish training with your
Scotty mucho up in here that you can
train a box
oh Lord have mercy you don't know
nothing about this Make It Rain
are you an idiot Leon get this guy out
of here all right nobody move
there he is there who is you on your
feet on your feet
what I do you're under arrest for
photocopying money oh my God damn it you
know how long it took me to cut all that
out
carpal tunnel syndrome up in this [ __ ]
callus is on the inside of my thumbs
that's definitely real though
this is not just another streaming app
what this is so much comedy it's not
even funny are you choking me bro this
is daily late and lately this is real
roasted and raw give it to me now this
is great stand-up great movies in the
Great Cornholio are you threatening me
no this is one pump two pumps
and three pumps this is live sports
breaking news and a mountain of Comedy
entertainment Paramount plus now
streaming
the right triangle's longest side is
called the hypotenuse and it's this side
here see the long
I wish I were high on
I wish I was high on pot news
[Applause]
okay okay Mr Morris is very funny it's
very funny but let's get back to the
lesson
and if you can see the longest one where
it goes from this point that was my joke
I know man that was hilarious
no but I mean I said that you labeled
anything I said it I said it I said that
please please Mr Jackson keep your
comments to yourself
thank you
now the hypotenuse it
[Applause]
that's the reason you really got me on
that one oh so great oh oh principal
Martel principal Martel come here come
here come here uh tell principal Martel
what you said Troy oh uh
um she was talking about the hypotenuse
and I said I wish I was high on pot news
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I said that Mr Jackson that is enough
what I said at first
oh uh Mr Iglesias Mr Iglesias yes come
in come in
yeah
comedian giveaway glacias is touring the
local schools today for a charity he's
working on and tell them what you said
tell them what you said oh I wish I was
high on pot news
[Applause]
I'm your biggest fan that was my joke uh
you know it's not really cool buddy to
take credit for other people's jokes Hey
listen funny stuff I'm doing this big
tour right now you want to see about
maybe we could talk about you opening I
need an opener oh
um sure what do you think is that okay
of course what
come on
deserved it all right so across from the
longest side is a 90 degree angle
good thing I've got a 90 degree dangle
why are you trying to be like Troy
dick
uh two nerdy girl
so the hypotenuse
foreign
[Applause]
good evening my fellow Americans every
day our citizens improve the lives of
those around them today we honor Troy
Morrison now Troy was in a geometry
class when his teacher mentioned the
hypotenuse of a triangle Troy said I
wish I was high on partners that really
cracked me up and it cracked up the rest
of America too so today I'm pleased to
present Troy with the Congressional
comedy Medal of Honor Troy on behalf of
the entire country I just want to uh
thank you for your fantastic off the
cuff line
you are a true comedy hero thank you sir
thank you and also Mr President I have
something for you what's that
oh my God why not yes these are sold out
I haven't been able to get my hands on
one of these thanks Troy oh my goodness
man Tyrell about to come out here right
now that lady what's this what she's
doing yo Tyrell yo what up Lauren hey
man you want to play front hand back
here I don't know that game man it's
easy though all you got to do is stay
front hand in the backhand all right
front hands
bam I got you sucker
oh okay okay
um
[Music]
huh it's still my move right I choose
backhand this time
real back hand
oh
look I'm sorry but I ain't sorry you
know what I mean I mean you asked for it
I mean you literally asked for it
right hand what no why you wanna hit him
got it I figured it out front hand no
backhand backhand look look dude hey if
you want me slap you across the face
backhand I'll do it okay don't think I
won't do it but you know that I'm with
you right I mean there ain't no game
called front hand backhand
all right all right
as soon as I get good at front hand back
hand You Wanna Stop playing play what
man I made it up so I can smack you in
the face I'm all about to smack you in
the face
as soon as it's my turn back hey there
ain't no terms cause it ain't no game
you ain't got no game back
what's up
right hand
no I don't know if you want me at this
point or what
but I don't wanna
smacking no more
where you going then okay forfeit
forfeit I win I win from him back again
okay me and you me and you me and you
huh backhand
damn she was Sly shy
yo man can I ask you a question yeah
what why everybody messing with the
Batmans
see that's exactly what I've been asking
myself it don't make no sense why would
you do it why would you do that why
would you try and mess with the back
remember Heath ledgers tried I mean the
Batman's got armor and be knowing some
martial movies
and then martial arts come on all you
got is a purple suit and some pancake
mix come on man I mean come on man why
would you mess with the Batman that's
what I'm saying man remember when Danny
DeVito's tried it walking around talking
about
[Music]
I mean the Batman is a multi-billionaire
with a grudge you're just a little fat
[ __ ] in a tuxedo with an
umbrella exactly man it's like a pretend
bird can't mess with the Batman
Jim Carrey's though Jim Carrey's
riddle me this riddle me that man's
how's these for sure going to mess with
Batman
well played hey Batman's I've come to
get you yeah I see how are you supposed
to block a batarang from going in your
butt with a carefully crafted query you
cannot that's how it's impossible
Fighters Michelle Professor Batman
try to mess with the Batman Michelle put
Pfeiffer guess what Michelle for five
first you ain't a real cat come on I'll
tell you one thing ain't no way you
gonna meows with the Batman what about
Arnold Schwarzenegger it up what's
Arnold Schwarzenegger trying to do what
is on the switch come on feel the burn
feel the burn feel the burn it should be
in your triceps come on you can't turn
up the ace
what are you supposed to be doing to the
Batman giving the Batmans a call
man let's talk about that Lawson and
you're Defeated come on commands you
know there is one person though oh no no
he'll come now there is one person who
could yeah it comes right now
there's one person who could did and
Shout again
[Music]
he trained the Batman
she gave the Batmans his skills he's a
mirror image of the Batman and fighting
Power I'm talking about Ross ow dude
right there talk about straight up Raz
al Ghul played by the incomparable Liam
Neeson so even when we are talking about
the Batmans Liam says
good
[Applause]
hello my fellow Americans with me as
always is my anger translator Luther hi
now the first year of my second term has
been a challenge cluster
tonight I'd like to address the concerns
of the American people over what they
perceive as the U.S government spying on
their digital and electronic activities
man you're awesome deluded
self-important [ __ ] if you
think we're interested in your deeping
at porn watching asses I can assure you
the American people we are not reading
every individual email rather we're
searching for key words that would
indicate a threat and don't worry
everybody those key words are not girl
on girl anal squirting plopping
flopping
what the [ __ ] is plopping you dirty
[ __ ] these key words are being
used amongst other things to prevent
terrorists from using weapons of mass
destruction not prevent you from
watching videos of ass destruction now
these policies have already foiled
numerous terrorist plots these are not
the kind of plots that y'all are used to
like when a god comes in the door with
his penis in a pizza box and a lady
sucks on it and I assure you that the
country's gotten safer since the end of
the Bush era and I ain't talking about
the president
these policies have allowed us to probe
and penetrate Luther
just what I'm trying to say is that
there have been numerous terrorist cells
fingered Luther
why are you trying to undermine the
president with your juvenile sexual
innuendo the average American has
nothing to fear from these policies now
if we was drone striking perverts our
country would look like Mad Max Beyond
Thunderdome right about now I'm talking
about a post-apocalyptic nightmare
thank you and good night go to sleep
y'all
flopping oh yes sir when you oh
y'all are some sick [ __ ]
the Second Amendment of the Constitution
states that a well-regulated militia
being necessary for the security of a
free state the right of the people to
keep and bear arms shall not be in free
yes
please gentlemen we need all of your
signatures gentlemen
a point of order
what if
if someone made a gun that could shoot
say
50 people in 30 seconds
Congressman Peale we have many orders of
business today one of which is not
judging your sense of humor pretentious
as it may be
then one man
would be able to walk into a crowded
area and kill scores upon scores of
people before anyone
would have a chance to stop him
Congressman peel
where are you getting these hair brain
ideas
how could you possibly know
what the future holds
because
I am from the future I know what this
amendment will bring and I cannot let
any of you sign it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I did it
did you see that the muskets he had
magnificent hand me the quilt so I can
draw them before I forget
damn it
trying to reach out to you all day
are we on for tonight
what you can't catch me you can't catch
me I'm Lance Moore touchdown [ __ ] what
pause
oh shoot Keegan's been texting me
sorry dude missed your texts
I assumed we'd meet at the bar
whatever I don't care
sorry dude missed your texts I assumed
we'd meet at the bar whatever I don't
care
whatever I don't care
is his problem
do you even want to hang out do you even
want to hang out oh that's considerate
like I said whatever like I said
whatever [ __ ] this guy
Jesus you are priceless
you're the one who's
priceless
this
[ __ ]
okay
you want to go right now huh
guess I could do that
okay okay let's go he said okay oh okay
let's go
you know what
what really do this now Keegan you nuts
you're not putting me out yeah let's do
it oh yeah
first round's mine oh no oh no they're
gonna be no rounds [ __ ] it's gonna be
a street fight
like I said first round's mine a beer
and a gimlet my partner right
what's that
uh I I got you a baseball bat with nails
in it
for my post-apocalyptic Jackie Robinson
costume how did you know
okay all right everybody just uh let's
settle down and settle in and like just
totally let's get our math on okay all
right guys so
um
somebody's got a little extra energy
right yeah
foreign
hey buddy let's okay let's just let's
knock it off okay
you got me he got me right guys Jimmy
dude all right let's take our seat
[Music]
that's great that's great that's great
very good Bravo Jimmy I'm just kidding
you guys can clap
[Applause]
that was awesome oh and I thank you I
thank you for the entertainment man
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah Eureka I'm gonna be honest with you
really pushing my buttons now Jimmy
you're driving me crazy
[Music]
you want me to write your name on the
board
okay Jimmy do you want me to call Prince
from Martel
you know what
why don't you come up and teach the
class man hmm
wouldn't that be awesome
[Laughter]
no and then you know what I'm gonna do
Jimmy I'll just sit here how about that
Jimmy and then we can all watch how
you're being disrupted
oh I see that's supposed to be me right
all right Timmy okay I see that I did it
supposed to be me it's time to be done
Jimmy don't you dude
oh yeah
oh yeah
well this is you Jenny
I'm YouTube yeah
[Laughter]
oh I'm gonna swap fine give me five give
me five huh how about that huh that's
you Jimmy I'm Jimmy
I'm Jimmy and I need attention yeah I'm
Jenny I'm Jenny hell look at him that's
the funniest
thing
I'm Jimmy I want attention
Mr flyer principal Martel nope what no
no no no no no it was Jimmy it was Jimmy
principal Martel no Jimmy it was Jimmy
hey it was Jimmy it was Jimmy
[Applause]
[Music]
give me
[Applause]
thank yousford meeting me here yeah of
course you know he's glad we could set
aside our differences and avoid a war
here you know Southern all right
[Music]
we're trying to avoid a war here
oh Anthony no
that's too much what are you doing we're
just having a nice little dinner here
all right well that's just disrespected
oh no not his head and he had good hair
yeah you're done yeah
what's going on what are you doing now
his phone all no no don't go deleting
his contacts he's not gonna know where
to answer me tonight you're finished now
that's that's good look what you did now
he was in the middle of something and
now what's going on here what are you
doing oh that's perfect that's a
permanent silly mustache oh now he looks
like a a sleeping musketeer that's
adorable but it's it's ridiculous he
can't he can hardly wash that off that's
whatever way you know what is that not
with the what do you do well you put him
in the game that doesn't even make sense
here that doesn't even make sense
oh oh Anthony oh that's hilarious but
save that for a slumber party all right
what are you no you're rearranging the
silverware that's just so mean it's it's
confusing it's confusing enough what
would the Apparently accept me don't do
oh well you know the salad you get a
little pepper so that's good that's so
that's that's not so bad you finally did
something constructive what are you
looking for what are you you're putting
the silverware back that's good that's
good now he knows he can go from outside
to inside and that's Paul you put a
little juice in his head that's good yes
judge it just oh no it actually looks
better than when he came in if he wasn't
unconscious he could go out on the town
so that's good that's good okay look
here you go all right white wipe off his
face yeah yeah and get the mustache
while you at it because that's that's
the most embarrassing part of all he
doesn't look ridiculous anymore oh hey
now that's that's now you're helping
everybody that's good for everybody
everybody likes that nobody wants
lettuce on the floor
all right we done all right you really
turned this around ain't me very all
right and then you're gone all right all
right he won't even know what hit him he
won't even know that any
no no no no no Anthony Edney I can see
it in your eyes I can see it in your
eyes you're going the other way now
Anthony and he was going so well well
that's that's that's perverse in me I
don't even know what what's that what's
that what are you gonna do with that
finger
oh yeah
[Music]
good evening my fellow Americans you
remember my anger translator Luther why
hello now I've told Luther that he can
join me for this last address but that
his being on his very best behavior is
crucial to Healing The Divide in this
country
go against every natural instinct in
your body
since we last spoke the country has
voted for a new president
here we go
come on really you talk about the Trap
how did this happen man get the [ __ ]
Y'all Gonna vomit the dude that's gonna
make America hate again don't you
understand this is how the hunger game
starts is true we all have to accept
that
I'm gonna have someone else calling the
shots Vladimir
Putin y'all
gonna be one in the show Placebo rushing
[ __ ] it was a close election
but the people have spoken yeah they
voted for Hillary Clinton but then this
outdated election
s
it's more imperative than ever
Now we move on as a country United
United the fact that we can't [ __ ]
stand each other even as the country
adopts new policies uh on the trade
immigration new policies
is it smoking hot white one plagiarizes
speeches
I have greatly enjoyed
my time as your president except when um
you know um let me think about let me
think when the Republicans wouldn't let
me do [ __ ] and then that one dude said I
wasn't born here and then you all
elected him so you know what didn't love
that part so much so pretty much the
beginning middle and the end sucked I
have met with president-elect Trump and
have pledged my support in his
transition he doesn't even want the job
y'all I saw it in his eyes that the dude
was shook the only reason he ran is
because his Factory in China made too
many Red Hats
foreign
I assure you
that if he succeeds we all succeed
unless he succeeds with all the [ __ ] he
promised to succeed with in that case
we're [ __ ] and now
a Time cherished tradition is that the
outgoing outgoing don't say outgoing
that's me damn it leaves the incoming
president a little note in the desk of
the Oval Office of course it's
completely confidential go [ __ ] yourself
until now
oh
that's my bad
so all of you out there
who are afraid that your way of life is
under attack
remember that progress isn't always a
straight line no because sometimes it's
a line that goes like this goes and it
just goes straight down for four [ __ ]
years stay strong and never stop
standing up for what you believe in uh
yes I would like to book a four year
stay for five at the Ice Hotel in Sweden
please sorry five
for both I mean you're always gonna take
Bo make it six information
thanks America it's been real it's been
good
but it ain't been real good apparently
Orange is the New Black good luck with
your health care [ __ ] I'm out peace
I got my eye on you [ __ ] grabber
[Music]
totally chillaxed so annoyed right now
can you like not talk to me for like a
second like that'd be great that'd be
fine that'd be fine by me but oh my God
are you serious this is both
what could possibly be the problem with
letting two more people in
check your girl bro
excuse me what did you say check your
girl uh-uh it doesn't work like that no
one checks me because I'm not luggage
okay so you can go
dear shelf Megan seriously two more
people are gonna come out in a couple of
seconds and then we can go in yeah
let me ask you a question what was it
like being in The Green Mile he wasn't
in the green mileage clearly wasn't in
that movie what does Tom hanks's penis
feel like Megan moreover how does it
feel when swarms of bees are coming out
of your face seriously I'm sorry second
favorite movie don't apologize for me
yeah this is nice this is nice you look
like common meets The Incredible Hulk
when you brought the frankincense to
baby Jesus did they like make you stand
outside the barn because you were too
big or did they invite you in with all
the other animals don't flare your
nostrils at me do you have any idea how
impellite that is he hasn't moved his
nostrils once since we got here I saw
them they did not move me again
they [ __ ] did not move if NASA's
flared more than a Survivor from a boat
accident what he's not even looking me
in the eyes okay you know what if you're
just going to continue to be a little
prick you're gonna get your ass kicked
don't touch him meekin
crazy [ __ ]
ah
no
totally love my nails right now
go over everything right now over the
floor I'm up in the sky I'm over you
over that [ __ ] back there you're a
Pusser speaking seriously whatever
um
excuse me oh God hey what did you say
what the [ __ ]
you should say
you guys come back here with your little
itty bitty dicks
best control your lady yep
control your lady now he doesn't control
me because let me tell you something I'm
not a remote [ __ ] baby can we just let
this go no I'm talking to the [ __ ] of
Anarchy right now yeah you why don't you
I'll gather yourselves and why don't you
just go and figure out a way to on each
other's leathery P9 hey you [ __ ]
ah
it's not even the plural of penis
yeah I'm not Queen of the word
I'm feeling sensible like a superpowers
or something
you hear that all you ask for the world
I can do anything I want and no one can
stop me because you don't have to fight
your own fights you crazy [ __ ] oh boy
oh
nothing can stop me
hey man this is your first time
oh man I've been doing a zombie extra
work on this show since day one first
season man my first time that's your
first time on this show
my first time being extra at all ever
kind of nervous oh wow okay man hey man
sorry about you you'll be all right man
it's okay man it's not that hard man
you'll be all right me personally dude
I'm looking for that lunge bump though
what's what's a lunge bomb Oh that's uh
like if you um you get featured if you
lunge at somebody and then you get a
bump in your pay and if you're really
lucky man they blow your head off that's
straight bank right there
assistant director got around Jerry hey
Jerry I had a thought man about the
first scene that y'all not now Stan oh
Steve it's Steve okay okay I'm gonna
need somebody to Lunge at the fence
you think you can handle it yeah oh yeah
it's his first day though he kind of
nervous man he kind of nervous it's his
first date okay so the director's gonna
yell action max gonna come by and then
you're just gonna lunge into the fence
like
you you want me to say Graw oh this is
say whatever it's crazy okay all right
cool man hey you know hey that's cool
hey you know I got a lot more experience
man you can just use me I've been here
day one first season so and okay cool
all right that's fine you're gonna go
with him all right good for you man good
for you all right grab no don't do it
you don't have to say God do whatever
you hell you want to do man that's the
lunge bro that is the lunch box man you
got it you got it on your first day ever
being an extra ever you got it man good
for you and action
[Music]
me
what the hell was that cut oh man I
would be more than happy to fill in man
I'd be more than happy to step in Max
just remember when you're coming through
the factory that like your mind is still
in the cars I mean you only got to pick
People based on qualifications man
you've just been picking random good
note good note but maybe what I was
doing sort of superseded that
agreed yeah we were just discussing that
absolutely it supersedes it yeah but uh
let's do one that just seeds it okay
just same level we're going again
straight away okay right away okay he's
not doing a good job at it you're doing
great though man opportunity not just
gonna answer the door Man action
[Applause]
[Music]
cut I'll be more than happy to step in
at any time you want me to I'd be more
than happy to do it just a certain sense
of urgency is all we're looking for
clock's ticking you got survivors to
find right can't tell you off with
someone real estate but this dude right
here is not doing what a zombie does
this dude was literally on our last take
waving his hand up in the air like this
Jerry making Beaker sounds these sound
like Beaker from The Muppets y'all thank
you that's great just a ticking clock on
this is all we're looking for because
there are survivors is what we're after
okay I found the ambivalence in there
the ambivalence is Art it's gorgeous and
we love it but there are zombies so if
we could just pick up the pace just a
hair that'd be great straight away
please right away Jerry we're not doing
Night of the Living Muppets are we we're
not because the beaker is not a zombie
you have any nose yeah don't be a
[ __ ] Beaker quiet please action
thank you
let me get your brain zombie God no he
actually just said the word zombie come
on man you ever hear a zombie say the
word zombie before no you haven't I
don't think so you know what get rid of
this game thank you that's what I'm
talking about I'm sorry dog but you tear
up
terrible
thing my ham because
you want me to leave
running around here for three and a half
years and I've been startling extras
left and right when do I get the start
of the lead huh one more for safety
straight away action
hey what do we do if we had to go to the
bathroom
we like it I love it genius moving on
thank God
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
oh
yeah
verily
[Applause]
yeah and it's about time Shakespeare
Duff scriven the play that places a
brother amongst the firmament that's my
sight oh who's your favorite character
Monticello it's his mind as well as well
as a general oh
Alex yes
two packs of that comely white maiden
and it's not anyone speaking against him
he's straight pimples me things things
are looking up for people of the darker
Hue damn straight okay oh
um
my tension which that I could borrow a
couple of duckets to purchase it a capon
from Yonder concession more please you
know I got a concealed cornish game hand
up in my doublet oh a lot with me to
park tickets up in this [ __ ]
come on y'all y'all heard the Usher oh
if I know Shakespeare I thought I was
about to kill everybody up in this [ __ ]
[Music]
no no no no
I hate at this place how they gonna kill
Othello man that trifling ass Iago I
knew he was up to submission to kill Tim
in the First Act how are they gonna kill
the fellas how Othello gonna do himself
in with the dagger how does that happen
tell you something if a brother killed
himself every time he broke up with a
white [ __ ] just rolled him deep and
rest of Brothers you'll be talking to a
skull right now okay where's Shakespeare
is that Shakespeare oh he's right there
another way okay
pretty make way be gone Sarah
you kill the fella a black man got it
going on and you Shuffle off this
morning coil I said unto thee that's a
tragedy oh oh is that enough for
Troubadour Kanye if the West what wait
no wait
truth be told my Lord it is not I who
penned this Dreadful play it was
Christopher Marlo
that already tried to use that line of
argument when the Jews wanted to kick
your ass after The Merchant of Venice
we've just not purchase it slick Willie
we doth not purchase it become
my good Lord it will not be long before
another black hero Grace at this stage
and now if you let me take my leave with
you not so fast you gonna write that
hero
now
barely that [ __ ]
[Music]
that John shaft is one bad mother I just
speaking about shy
[Music]
let's get this party started
your mom Plus
Strokes of Genius beautiful games and
One Shining Moments this is Defenders
investigators and seven strangers picked
to live in a house this is Young
SpongeBob young Sheldon and the younger
this is everything you've been looking
for it's gonna leave a mark live sports
breaking news and a mountain of
entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now streaming
I'm gonna go wash my hands okay
see yourself
buddy
um I'm sorry uh you that seat is
actually taken uh my girlfriend is in
the bathroom and she should be back any
second so you cannot sit there you don't
even recognize me do you no no I I don't
I don't I don't know you we were in The
Human Centipede together I said I do not
know you three years ago we were
kidnapped by the crazy German scientist
who surgically connected us into a
single human digestive chain there were
three of us I was in the middle you were
at the end the other guy was up front
your mouth was sewn to my butthole okay
yes I remember and after years of
therapy I finally put that behind me
probably should have said you put it
behind me if you catch my drift I'm
sorry I'm sorry you already caught my
drift I'm sorry that's it it was right
there in front of me
I'm sorry I guess it was right there in
front of you that's it
is there something else I can help you
with um
squat no ooh chili old habits die hard
nice one no we can't eat it
why are you happy to see him come on man
you know we all shared the same
experience no we didn't he was in the
front nobody in his mouth that is true
do you ever stop eating ever only
winning okay well but me and you right
me and you what I mean we were in the
same boat nope you two were in the same
boat you both in someone's mouth I
didn't get in anyone's mouth when do I
get anybody's mouth up when do I get
this in somebody's mouth Stephen
I know these guys I can explain this I
can explain this
oh you're disgusted you know now you're
gonna leave oh yeah that's
once again I'm the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
okay you know what it wasn't my fault
all right I I I had the money like you
said in a trash bag in the back of my
car and I was gonna go straight to the
drop spot
all right
no no oh okay okay okay no no hey hey
hey hey man ain't no need for you to get
comfortable okay because because I'm
telling you man what happened wasn't my
fault all right I I I I I I I I I I
drove to the agreed upon location man
okay okay okay okay okay okay
because there's no need to have anything
crazy in a paper bag I'm telling you
there's an explanation for what went
down
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay let's calm down
now let's calm down man there ain't no
need
oh not a juice box there ain't no need
to eat a meal and then do some crazy
with a sandwich container and a juice
box
oh man come on
come on man just chill out a little bit
just so you need to relax Man You're
Gonna Take It Easy in my life oh
oh God damn now come on man don't do it
don't do it don't don't manage
sandwich
oh man how you gonna sandwich me dog how
you gonna sandwich me
okay look it's staying crazy now it's
not stop it's Gotta stop right now okay
you cleaning yourself up before you do
something come on man what you doing
what you want to know well I'll tell you
whatever you want to know man just
please stop this cold ass [ __ ] man I'm
spending you dog please oh no no okay
okay maybe it was my fault a little bit
maybe it's my fault a little bit but
don't just what you gonna do with that
juice box man we're gonna do with that
we gonna do with the straw
what do you want to do with this job
come on mental listen listen no no I
didn't I did I did it okay I did it I
did I left the car I left for three
minutes so please don't do anything with
the strong why aren't you stop the fight
okay I beat you to it okay I got your
point all right man
oh man that's a [ __ ]
[Music]
will we be having any more problems out
of him sir no
yeah
that's what I'm talking about
hey
y'all for real though
this right here yeah this goes out to
all our fallen homies yo
come on hey yo real tough all right
it just seems like a waste right
does that make me a dick
okay I'm a dick okay I'm a dick I'm
sorry okay
for our homies
come on man
okay all right
glug glug glug glug no come on man hey
man you got your thumb okay okay okay
you need to respect our homies okay oh
okay
or the homies
whoa
trash beer what come on hey beer is beer
geez I cannot win on this what fine I'm
out on board with this but I'll do it
hey what you doing
put that that's not oh man
it's more of a symbol than a gesture
somebody brought me up on this hey wait
hey man that's disrespectful right there
you just do it fine fine I'm poured out
I waste the damn beer then
foreign
I'm just not a waster you know I save
everything Jamal knows if you eat a
piece of pizza and don't eat the crust I
eat the crust if we do a drive-by
shooting I will go back for the shell
cases not to hide the evidence but
because you can recycle those they have
value man just like this beer I can't
waste nothing y'all it's physically
impossible for me to waste this
I can't do it
Jamal can you pour it off for me
come on man dude I mean it's not gonna
bring it back dude it's not gonna bring
him back
call my agent
Jaden Pickett Smith my man what up
hey look man I'm gonna be real with you
okay this alien boy script I'm not
feeling it I mean it's hard being Will
Smith's son I just want to make sure my
next project reflects I'm a Down to
Earth normal kid am I making any sense
yeah yeah I'm reading you loud and clear
I've got a script right here very real
called Streetball talk to me okay so you
play
he's a kid from the streets lives in the
Hood in a house with his mom stop
stop house oh it's like a tiny Mansion
got it go on so his mom and he uh they
live in this house and she works at a
supermarket ah
but it's full of food and anyone can go
there so like where the Butlers go
and wait he said his mom was doing
something at the supermarket working so
working is kind of like acting on a set
every day in a film that no one's ever
going to see and it lasts for the rest
of your life oh like a maid
yeah
awesome continue anyway Tony
so he decides to start playing pickup
games of Streetball outside
so he plays basketball in his plane
not on the ground
in his limo
uh outside is that stuff that goes by
when you're inside the limo
yeah yeah yeah so then he gets really
good at basketball and then blah blah
blah blah fast forward at the heart of
the story Tony has to choose
shoes
yeah choose is when you have to make a
decision between two things you want but
you can have only one
but
there's two
yeah but but I mean he can't have both
what I say about science fiction Clyde
it's a no
okay we'll pass
dad bless you
thank hello
and welcome to the fifth annual meeting
of the Tallahassee black Republicans
I'm pissed
royally pissed
it's November Barack Obama was
re-elected president
and the black vote went almost entirely
to him
we're not getting our message out
obviously the Republican party is and
should be the only home for black voters
now people think
that black voters are a monolith
we're not a monolith
in fact black Republicans alone are an
extremely diverse group of people
now to speak more on diversity I present
tonight's speaker
Mr Douglas Jackson
[Applause]
now I'm not going to sugarcoat it I'm
pissed I am royally pissed
the liberal media thinks that
republicanism is not for black people
now you tell me what about fiscal
responsibility
our strong National Defense and limited
government is unappealing
we're not a model left
we come in all different shapes and
sizes
now who here like to come to this Podium
and speak about the diversity amongst
black Republicans
gentlemen we have a real treat today a
gentleman who is a little bit eccentric
a little bit outside of the box
think of a better person to speak on
diversity amongst black Republicans than
this gentleman right here all the way
from Orlando my good friend off of
Washington
[Applause]
thank you for the introduction brother
Douglas thank you for being here brother
Arthur
however I am
pissed
royally pissed indeed indeed Democrats
think they have a right to all the black
peoples
but that's not the case we are not a
monolith
Democrats may be cool but they ain't
practical there you go
Republicans are practical black people
are practical
come and think of it
get those pants I think black
Republicans are pretty cool
not to mention very diverse excuse me
gentlemen uh sorry to interrupt
someone's white wife is here to pick
them up
what's her name Emily uh she was white
okay
the moment I saw you last night at the
club totally had to ask you out yeah are
you kidding me like the moment that's so
sweet I was actually afraid that you
were gonna be like one of those high
maintenance chicks yeah
what yeah I don't know I don't control
freaks I don't even know oh my God
that's so funny
it's funny as well nah I'm like I
totally just like to be just like easy
going yeah
five minutes and we're just now getting
our menus
I'm sorry don't be sorry be better
right okay I'll be better that's your
job
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so yeah my philosophy is pretty much
like keep it chill right yeah yeah you
know what I like about you no what like
you're not afraid to be like brainy and
respectful right thanks I really like
your boobs
I think we really compliment each other
well just did it right there and I
pretty much go with the flow right right
and what the is wrong with you
excuse me do I look like Mad Max to you
I'm sorry do I look like Mel Gibson with
a mullet
no not not at all does he look like a
pharaoh feral child with a boomerang in
his hand
S no then why is water a rare commodity
here it's not it's not I just uh
I'm sorry I'm just really slammed no
you'll know when you're slammed because
your nuts will be on the table and my
fists will be covered in your blood
[Music]
um
you were uh like kind of harsh to that
guy
oh him yeah no I was a hostess at a
restaurant in the industry that's how we
talk to each other I'll show you hey God
oh hey
what do you see there
that's your water down
down boy
then you need okay I have other tables
that I have
what does that look like DM yes there's
a little lipstick on your clothes
upstairs but it maybe it's yours this is
what I want you to do I want you to take
this class in the back
I want you to break it
take the biggest Shard you can find and
bring it to me
and I'm gonna
sleep all right I'm just I'll get you
another one I'm gonna split your throat
and once you bleed out
and I'm gonna shower in your blood all
right I'll get another water well that
would be great thank you
but as I was saying like I just feel
like it's like due unto others
the hell is that what are you doing
wait wait no no no no
oh my God
it's still you no one's ever talk to me
like that in my life
I have his back
that it was your lipstick on the glass
he's just a waiter
you know what you can say I hope you
have a very happy life together
Mickey what's going on right now
what do you do
[Music]
seriously me again no no
Megan you're not contracted hey you left
your check hey
don't do it
I just heard her feelings and then she
left her jackass least I could do
something don't do it
she does not needed it's 87 degrees out
you know she doesn't need it in your
heart of hearts you know she doesn't
need that jacket don't do it
she's gonna need a jacket though
seem like a nice guy
[Music]
all right so that's just working okay
good good good good meat pretty awesome
man
get out there
oh sorry sorry
y'all want to do some of that God
who's this guy y'all never heard of a
girl well I've I've never heard of that
AKA Slayer
Cuddy Cuddy double cutting Elmo
cat Vash
Long Island brain slice
font font font font I've heard of that
it takes all your greatest fears and
insecurities and it gives them teeth and
arms
and then it locks you in the room with
them from which you cannot Escape
well that sounds terrible yeah I don't
want that I know those words are good
you realize the face of God is somewhere
inside your body
but you can't find it
and it hates you
um
none of us are interested in this drug
thank you sir nice meeting you let's
hear him out let's hear him out it's a
razor sharp Crystal you tuck under your
eyelid oh
and then when your ocular cavity starts
bleeding it goes directly into your
brain for like there's got to be a good
part yeah you've just described a life
wrecking physical addiction finish if
you let him finish he's going to get to
the Euphoria I'm sure that's what you
can't take anymore
right now
you poop your mouth I'm sorry what you
poop in your mouth no
you poop out of your mouth I'm in dude
Jeff come on man guys if people are
willing to go through this the high must
be amazing buddy remember when you did
mushrooms and you cried for three hours
this is what's next
[Applause]
how should I know I don't do drugs
drugs are for losers
[Music]
this weed is mad tight yeah man I'm
super hot dog
hey yo
let me ask you a question on the real
yeah yeah dog yeah go ahead man
hey man where'd my dookie go
oh
what my dookie
where do we go
it go down in the toilet you know that
nah man I ain't stupid
where do we go after that come on man
quit playing I don't know it goes into
the sewer you know
everybody go down there yeah everybody's
dookie goes down to the Sewer
where'd my dookie go after that
that washes out to the ocean
I guess hold up hold up
dolphins swim with my dookie I don't
know man I mean I don't I really don't
know we're in the ocean yep what happens
to the dookie I'm just taking a stab
like a wild guess all right that the
dookie like probably go up in the air
and like evaporates and then turns into
the cloud or something a dookie Cloud oh
this
everybody's dookie mix up goes up in the
cloud and then it rains down that's
gangster I just can we stop talking
about dookie right now
I just thought of something yes what is
it what is it Levi the pieces of my
dookie yep falls on the ground that's
true yep and becomes a plan okay okay
that's good now we're done with the
dookie talk right do keep playing nope
nope that reaches Towards the Sky
said
yeah Levi
my dookie can make it out of the hood
maybe we can too
huh
Maybe
maybe Levi
ladies and gentlemen Darius Rucker
don't go out with my friends no more
don't wanna hold your hand no more
now
[Music]
I'm not in hoodie in the Blowfish
anymore y'all
doing my own thing what do you mean in
hoodie because you you are Hootie man
come on everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
now stop it stop it I'm not Hootie I'm
Darius Rucker all right I used to be the
front man for a band called Hootie and
the Blowfish
all right but I was never Hootie there
was never a hoodie just if I may if I
may ask where are the Blowfish at right
guys come on everyone
finish
no no no no there are no people known as
The Blowfish y'all okay the whole band
was just called Hootie and the Blowfish
that's it it was a nonsense name like
Hoobastank or towed the Wet Sprocket oh
[Music]
I see I get it now I understand hey we
gotta pick y'all we gotta choose between
Hootie or the Blowfish so who wants to
see the Blowfish
there's no goldfish
hey who wants to see Hootie
hey
that that hurts my feelings y'all but
you said you weren't Hootie no I'm not
sir but in the question you just asked
the audience I was clearly Hootie so you
are Hootie I'm not though he is Hootie
[Applause]
who is
this
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Gotta Get It Up
[Music]
Gotta Get It Down
[Music]
Supernova Spanish
[Music]
gotta put it down
[Music]
in sanitation disease
[Music]
hey what the hell are we saying man I
got no idea man I'm just hungry and
talking about the Galaxy and trains I
think they buying it though
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
pure grade Afghani heroin
foreign
US dollars
hold up
we should count it first
[Music]
you know we're gonna do a straight count
on this right now count it count it yes
good idea let's probably do it fast so
we don't make our friends here wait okay
20.
40 60. 80 100
20 40. 60 80 200. you know what I'm fast
okay I'll take care of that one two
three four five six seven eight nine one
two three four five six seven eight nine
one two three four five six seven eight
nine why are you doing piles and nine
it's faster than tens open I do my nines
ten times and then do an extra pile of
10 in here fast okay you know we should
probably both be counting oh well let's
just get two with this double trouble
all right and 20 40.
100.
I'm sorry can you could you please could
you do something like over there please
oh you know what what's that I got it we
could time me okay we time me counting
out a thousand because we take that time
and then we just count money for that
time times 100.
no I I got it this is it right here I'm
gonna do a web search for a picture of
one hundred thousand dollars okay then
you know we'll know what it's supposed
to look like and then we can arrange our
money to look exactly like it and see
here all right here we go right here
look I mean damn that looks that looks
just like a lot like our money I think
we got a hundred thousand dollars here
folks I think we made it that is our
money I'm sorry I'm sorry the earlier
yeah we were counting I took a picture
of our money so I could upload it on
Yahoo answers oh damn that's right there
I just wanted to see if anyone could
verify with a hundred thousand dollars
look like oh you guys what was I
thinking I got it man go go go go
what the hell are you doing man I I you
know I was gonna try to rain man it oh
that's a plan right okay yeah here we go
here we go
yep I got that I got that
46.
99 980.
oh yeah
okay so okay let's check this out okay
since one time in college man I was
straight kicking game to this beautiful
chick Diana man and it's a house party
and so anyway I go to the kitchen to
grab us a couple of beers man I kid you
not I slipped on a banana peel a baby
it's like this I was like man I just
fell on my ass I just busted
yo yo dog you good yeah man uh what are
you doing
oh man
it was a funny story
I was laughing
then let it out man just just laugh
I am
yeah so uh anyway uh you know so I I get
up right and I go to grab a beer and I
forget they always are shook it up when
they fell right I kid you not this beer
exploded in my crotch it looked like I
peed myself
come on what are we doing
don't hit don't hit my couch LeBron
come on yeah I'm just laughing with
y'all whoa
we were laughing you weren't you didn't
you know making any noise you just open
your mouth and you
jiggling you look like a worm on crack
I guess everybody just
has their own unique life okay man you
are not laughing you would not admitting
sound about your mouth man hey I'm good
tell your story
thank you okay anyway I went
back to the kitchen to get two fresh
beers and she said
I hate beer but where did my banana go
and so that we called it Chiquita
Diana
there he goes
Ron don't back up hey
just hey get away from the turtles
Laura don't do this just don't touch my
turkey get away from it why are you
knocking down my CDs
it's almost like you choreographed
you're gonna clean all this up okay look
hey if you're gonna laugh then just
laugh
damn
Maybe
sometimes
you ain't as funny as you think
all right
I got something to make them laugh
huh
yeah
that's funny that's it
that's right oh it went back
man huh
you know that's funny
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
have a good life
[Music]
I would like to report an item which I
ordered that arrived broken when the sun
does smoking but Lane that's right I I
am showing the last item that you've
received is the Superman bed with the
mattress of solitude that's the one
ordered it from a son for his birthday
but I cannot give it to him like this
and I'm pretty darn tooting pissed about
it
I will start processing your reorder
right now with you on the line okay I
Ain't Mad At You Rios it's just the
system I know okay thank you for
understanding sir
kids eh huh
oh okay well yeah I just got the one
myself
had sex with a woman and everything to
get them how long is this gonna what is
your son's name
oh uh
um
Stampy
pretty much Stimpy I have boys too I'll
tell you sometimes they can be a real
couple of you know what's [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're preaching to the choir
area Stimpy don't you give me that look
you're gonna get it when your mama comes
home oh man sounds like your wife is
[ __ ] on Wheels you got that straight
Riaz
hot little biscuit though names Claire
bought a 10 face ten so pretty much hit
that every night
sexually
anyway what's holding up oh one more
minute and uh how old is her son
15.
it is still once a Superman bed
enjoy it while you still can
he'll grow out of the toys any day now
they all do
and the second he starts hooking up with
the girls he'll forget all about that
Superman and Spider-Man stuff pretty
much seems like how it would happen
maybe then he'll stop bothering me with
all those stupid little facts about how
those characters you just named are
clearly from two distinct and separate
universes sadly some people never move
on sad I got a better word for you
pathetic I
pathetic guy hey I called them locks I
see some reals and I don't tolerate
nerds in fact let me nip this in the bud
real quick stimp it stimp it get back in
here well I didn't mean to there you are
with your brown body and your creepy ass
face no more sweets for you cause you're
never gonna get laid if you keep eating
sweets
hey
all these figurines and toys you got
around the house we're throwing them in
the trash because they're not real
people stupid they're not real people so
stop being so lonely stop pins so lonely
foreign
of course
but I was wondering if your son would
like to talk to someone
oh [ __ ] see if it just jumped out the
window oh my god oh he killed himself
why to do it it must have been my fault
no it wasn't yes it was I'm gonna call
the cops don't you dare cancel that
reorder it's the only thing I'll have to
remember him bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
la la
la la la
[Applause]
la la la la la la la la la la la
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
um hi uh are you Earl peel
who the hell Wanna Know
I think I'm your son
Jordan peel oh okay I see
come on you're here for a minute
close the door on the way in right
all right man go ahead have a seat yeah
I'm gonna explain something to you okay
I ain't your dad
all right I'm sorry to disappoint you
but that's the situation brother
are you you see what's happening
we're doing the same thing I always do
this I always scratch the back of my
neck like this whenever I'm in an
uncomfortable situation
scratch my neck man everybody scratched
their neck I breathe in and out too man
now everybody my kids okay look at this
that's a picture of me when I was a baby
that's my father
that ain't me
look look man look at that dude's afro
look I got this going on man my hair was
gray he got black hair I mean he
handsome as hell but
I ain't nobody's Daddy
I'm sorry
I just been looking for him everywhere
yeah yeah show you here just I got my
own TV show now
foreign
I don't know I just I know that wherever
he is he he would be proud
you got your own TV show huh yeah yeah
yeah I'm producing and acting oh you oh
are you producing and acting right okay
yeah that's that's my boy
look at that man we're doing the same
thing what is that Holy sh that's jeans
right there man because you can't do
that unless you're sharing mad genes
with somebody it's got to be in your
dnas
oh
you're my son
my baby boy thanks for your time you
come back home man I miss you so much
when I first came to your door you
wouldn't even ignite
okay okay you know what when I first
came in here stop that
when I first came in here you wouldn't
even acknowledge that I could possibly
be your son but now only after I tell
you that I have my own show on Comedy
Central whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Comedy
Central
get the [ __ ] out of my whoa this is not
just another streaming app what this is
so much comedy it's not even funny are
you choking me bro this is daily late
and lately this is real roasted and raw
give it to me now this is great stand up
great movies and the great cornholio are
you threatening me no this is one pump
two pumps
and three pumps this is live sports
breaking news and a mountain of Comedy
entertainment Paramount plus now
streaming
welcome to Papa mattress Liquidators how
can I help you today
I need to buy a new bed okay yeah good
good you came to the right place I'd be
more happy to help with that uh what
size you need a full queen king queen
queen oh okay we got a big selection so
you know
it needs to be sturdy all right
okay it's kind of crazy in my room
oh okay I got you brother I got you
but it's a Posturepedic mattress we got
right here that's extremely comfortable
and uh durable
do you mind if I try it no no go ahead
I also mentioned it's a 100 money back
guarantee on you yeah yeah yeah who got
that good deed
yeah yeah
no it's too hard
do you have anything softer
um
of course
this uh just one of our um natural latex
mattresses
it's on sale too today at uh twelve
hundred dollars can I try it
sure
who got that good deed I Got That Good
Deed
who got that good deed I Got That Good
Deed
it seems a little pricey Okay now what's
a little pricey I ain't gonna lie to you
but uh no problem we got other choices
uh
this is a great memory foam mattress
right here it's a little cheaper and I
try it out
right right yeah I mean of course you
want to try you know how it goes yeah oh
you're coming up on them late nights
puppy yeah right
yeah man
um
sex happens
[Laughter]
oh oh here it comes here it goes
[Music]
yo that's the one I'll take it okay let
me ring you up
[Music]
thank you
Brothers Brothers
see when are we going to think of
ourselves as more than this
what y'all doing y'all rolling huh
flipping stupid boxing maxing
Jackson
I used to
oh yeah
I used to flip roll whatever you want to
call it me and my crew we were getting
to activity
much like yourself
you see the problem was we were only
perpetuating The Stereotype the system
already assumes about us
you see we need to stop feeding into the
preconceived notions that we are all
right you have you guys you really work
hard today I wish I could pay you more
but uh you know how it is
who are you uh what do you want
uh I don't know
as you work as you were what smart guy
[Music]
Brothers brothers look at yourself
fans hanging off your ass looking like a
couple of clowns which you are okay
enjoy the birthday celebration
give me your [ __ ] money [ __ ] I said
give me your money [ __ ] sir
everybody in this self-defense class has
already paid to participate if you're
interested you can sign up online
I'm interested good before I came over
here I'm interested I want to think
about it I'm interested thank you sir
Now ladies it's gonna get really intense
today no matter what happens I will be
groping your breastices as if you were
being attacked like a real Attack
brother brother my brother now I was
watching you now you older brothers need
to break the stereotype and stop being
so preachy you know what I'm preachy
come on
you preaching man plus you older than me
I'm nine years old I got Benjamin
buttons disease hmm
I'm done
done
uh I actually impressed it already well
the walk by tonight I pressed it
couldn't hurt to press it again but it
won't help
I mean I pressed it already right
it's already done
you don't think I didn't press it no I
wasn't saying that good because I most
certainly did press it yeah just have to
wait for it to change
[Music]
[Applause]
so I'm like late for work so I'm just
impressive what floor why would you do
something that's already done
I mean I just think that that's crazy
right
I don't know you wouldn't suit up and
try to kill Bin Laden again it's done I
have killed the bin Laden of pressing
this button
how long ago did you press it
what do you think I've been standing
here for days I just trust it right as
you walked up are you sure you pressed
it am I sure I pressed it it's how could
I miss it
rats know how to press buttons do you
think I'm dumber than a rat no
nothing like that it's Gonna Change just
just wait
it's because I pressed it already
okay no offense
I'm just gonna press it what would you
do that for this is this person
equipment designed by people who
would start I pressed the button while
we've been standing here the light cycle
has gone by twice okay I'm not saying
you didn't press it I'm just saying
maybe it didn't work if it didn't work
for me why in the world would it work
for you do you think you think that it
would change faster if you pressed it do
you think the light doesn't like me or
something well do you think that this
particular button was designed so that
it only works after the second time that
it's been pressed
lunacy okay do you understand do not
check my balls off on this one okay
please
do not press the button
okay fine we'll just
stand here thank you
I'm gonna press the button
hold them up through
no actually I already pressed the button
[Music]
that that
hey what's wrong man I was having a
nightmare oh
again
what you want to talk about it I miss my
me
hey
I know I know it's hey me too me too pal
come here man
all right hey it's okay it's gonna be
okay
I just don't want anything ever happened
to you
happened to me
come on man ain't nothing ever gonna
happen to me really
yeah
that's what I said
so yes that I'm nothing never gonna
happen to me you ain't never gonna have
to worry about nothing happened to me
what if what if you got hit by a car or
something
that's
impossible because I will never die so I
can't
die no matter what you can't die but I
thought all human beings died
that's true that's true that's science
so that's true but I
am lucky because I'm I'm not a human you
are not
I've never told you about this no
and you know I'll just let it out I'm
from a planet called felonious
the thing is it was being destroyed all
right that's what happened my was I was
sent down here in in a capsule to Earth
by my parents oh like Superman
Superman yep that is what it is exactly
like except oh here's the thing about my
version only one superpower immortality
oh yeah so I'm tired daddy's tired
can you
let's go to sleep okay but I'm not gonna
live forever right because because I'm
only half failure
so I'm gonna die
um
you
you write about yourself it's
but
here it is
this one slit my mind
you can build with me an immortality to
machine to give you what I got from the
remnants of my spacecraft so yeah wow
you're gonna be immortal
you're gonna be immortal daddy where are
we gonna get the remnants
tomorrow tomorrow
gonna get them tomorrow during work
hey you got anything that looks like
parts of a crash spaceship
did mom
um right this week
some folks wear their hats way off to
the side with their pants down low and a
gun tucked inside take their beer by the
40 and their chicken deep fried I think
we all know who we're talking about
foreign
[Music]
she was drunk on barley wine I'd been to
Sea for months or three I knew I could
make her mine but the last was past
consent so it was off with her we went
and we threw her in bed and rested her
head and we left cause that's what
gentlemen do
[Music]
with them
[Music]
[Music]
there once was a cow from Leeds who I
heard was good on her knees so I docked
my ship for an overnight trip to take
care of all my needs just fine Tales to
tell and my mask began to swell so I
laid her down and raised her down and
performed cunnilingus for an hour or so
[Applause]
[Music]
I once had a woman so fair whose wound
contained my air with the Sun by my side
the Seas we'd ride the child she would
bear but my girl she was no fool she was
working her way through school so I did
support when she chose to abort because
it's her body in there for her choice
[Applause]
[Music]
there was a lady with a golden eye and
the doctor said she would die so she
emptied her purse to lift the curse and
prayed to stay alive she awoke the very
next day and in her grave she lay but
the scariest part of the story from the
start is I bet you assumed the doctor
was a man
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
la la la
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
well I'm just a good old American boy
with a heart that's red white and true
dreaming of the girl with the red hair
and freckles in her eyes like the skies
of blue
country music I grew up in Texas you
know so all right keep her safe from the
homies in the wrong side of town where
they're smoking the reefer and acting
like clowns
keep that Purdue address from getting
dirty and brown because that's the
American way
oh
pretty racist song
racist against who
of black people black people but I'm
black
well keeping the red-headed girl away
from the homies on the wrong side of
town homies come on brother there's all
kinds of homies you know you white
homies Asian homies
no homies are black no I think you're
making them black man I mean I think
that's your stuff you hear the twang
and then you assume that it's racist but
that's that's just what country music is
like here look you're gonna like this
one you'll like this one all right
some folks wear their hats way off to
the side with their pants down low in a
gun tucked inside take their beer by the
40 and their chicken deep fried I think
we all know who we're talking about
the only dark I like is when I turn off
the lights the only Hood I love is
pointy and white tan trust you if I can
see your face at night I think we all
know
wait wait hey stop that
that's racist what's what what is racist
about it the only Hood I love is pointy
and white yeah man
let's talk about the clan man
the Ku Klux Klan
are you outside of your mind that's
traditional country music imagery man
like a pickup truck or sleeping under
the stars or your dog got killed or your
wife left you same thing I would have
been fine with any of those things what
is the difference between those things
and what is in the song they're not
racial hey you know I can't just say
something man I'm just gonna be frank
you're getting a little like Al Sharpton
like um Farrakhan on me right now oh my
God are you serious dude hey give me you
know can I do one more let me just do
one more dog I absolutely promise you
that this song is not racist and it's
impossible for you to misinterpret it as
such
okay it seems like you're about to sing
the most racist song so far
get me a rope and find me a tree okay
and
come on man hey
you think about a tire swing
right off an entire genre of music
the banjos is coming and the drums are a
banging let's get the boys together and
have ourselves a hanging oh damn
now I see it
now I see it
one at a time
a lot put men like you behind bars every
day
one at a time
you may take my heels
but cannot lock my soul away
all the years
[Music]
[Music]
did you say my daughter yours
now this is just a joke
[Music]
[Applause]
and we speak
[Music]
is the city on fire what's with all the
smoke
oh now we're all ears
ready
[Music]
all y'all rappers out there think y'all
hard cause what y'all been through hey
y'all check it out it was Friday night
chilling on my front lawn me and my crew
I had my bathrobe on everybody High just
watch X-Men got plenty Chicken Heads
ready for sex man and Busters roll up
they trying to talk smack don't these
just know they [ __ ] with them
I got shot but it's still standing shots
[Music]
still standing
we're back to my Palace fast
now I'm the dude walking round with a
phallus cast like Wolverine I'm trying
to be a loner but they think a got an
adamantium boner what can I say they
still up on my totem pole [ __ ] get your
tongue ring away from the scrotum hole
don't know why they love it but it keeps
the ladies moistening gave half the
Honeys in the hood lead poisoning shot
shot
I got shot in there
[Music]
I'm serious man damn so uh yeah I got
like 30 something followers I'm up to
like 15 tweets a day so if you wanted to
uh follow
I no no no no no no no
what they hating on The Hathaways they
hating on the half away they straight
hating on Annie Hathaways that's your
girl oh my God and he had to waste from
Devil Wears promise Nicholas [ __ ] Les
Miserables I dream of dreams and dreams
good dreams come on man
how do you be hating on the halfway do
not know cause that's your girl that's
my girl I've been rolling with the how
do I says precious Diaries
you was there since day one and you know
I'll be loving me some princess diaries
you got the Blu-ray like I said on DVD
and Laser just amphih chest man Rachel
getting married though what
Rachel Rachel getting married Rachel
getting married yo do you love it
halfways I do come on
come on man and the Oscar goes to Annie
Hathaways crackhead kill the brother
that's why come on come on it's broken
back oh he Broken Backs talk about
broken rap now that's right Broken Backs
dog I'm married to Jake jiggling Halls
I'm jiggling sauce thank you I stand
corrected so wait you know what I didn't
like that was not my dog
she was good don't play not confident
Texas business woman talking about
straight up you know what I'm struggling
with my husband's sexuality she kept her
integrity at the same time as showing
her breasts
why would you hating on the halfway why
would you be hating on that Confident
Woman in Hollywood who stole character
flaws that she cashed too much
tomorrow
you know who they never be hating on
who's that dog Sandra Bullock Sandra
Bullocks he says it's my girl
right there straight up there she says
your girl right there straight up do you
know who should do a movie together
though who is that what bullexes and
half away you talk about some Hathaway
it's unboxing no I'm talking about some
bullets and some half away let me just
explain what I'm talking about I'm
talking about some Hathaways and some
bullets
no you right bushes Hathaways
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
you good yeah I'm good I thought
something was going me too we would
transform in some way shape or form
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
give it up sweetly let me set that body
free cause what you got you got to give
it to me what
ever since I was rocking a onesie I know
that you was Second To None be growing
up and learning ABCs and one two threes
hoping you'd learn we women's a beat
even way back then every little note
knows a perfect 10 but then you know I
grow up and got a little bit a little
bit Bolder brushing off my shoulders
almost a man those playground feelings
grew stronger when you wait much longer
now with me bro you've been longer bro
[Music]
what the hell don't turn it off just
because you don't know it what are we
gonna do when we get to Vegas no no no
no no no no no don't change the subject
about what we're gonna do in Vegas if
you don't know the words just admit you
don't know the words I told you why
would I make up that I know don't know
that's ridiculous man no I know the word
it seems like you didn't know the word I
know the word Hey listen Hey listen to
me man what what I know the words that's
okay everybody knows okay no no it's not
okay because you obviously don't believe
me hey dude on our friendship
I know the words
roll with me
I'm sorry
just let it go I'm sorry that is stupid
stupid
oh
[Music]
well maybe you got
vanilla flavored you got
Lemon Zinger Lemon Zinger like that tea
oh
oh no what's going on
I got that brain freeze
hey Google
come on man you say you from the hood
dog you acting weak right now with this
brain freeze
come on ain't no brain freeze gonna make
you yell like that man get over there
don't be hitting your head with the
brain freeze come on in it yo you want
silver balls on it silver balls on the
shrink Connecticut
what's wrong with you come on okay
Exorcist what are you doing now well you
doing some Kung Fu get over it man
listen it can't be doing this much to
you
listen man don't be a punk ass [ __ ] man
get over there where you afraid now you
see anything you're just scared the
brain freeze make you scared
me who am I you ain't got no Alzheimer's
what's wrong with you
you're a punk ass [ __ ] what is this
Three Stooges on this month this is some
craziness oh you did the hand block
you know what man you're weak man you're
a weak ass mother that's the problem
[Music]
hold up now hold up now hold up now hold
up now hold up man you're gonna continue
to eat the Froyo even on top
hey now I really start to respect you
now man if you're gonna eat the thing
that's causing you the pain this is
great oh
no no you're staring into the brain
freeze
that's straight crazy right here man
come on real Taco Real Taco real talk
though I mean it's crazy the time man
that strangle Benny with my bare hands
cause he didn't have my money all right
we got him kahoo
what
what's your Five-O stand up slowly
it is not known you since six
you under arrest for the murder of Benny
tack there are tricks get him out of
here hey man you a punk ass brain freeze
[ __ ] you going to jail for a
long time
I'll be too deep
ah I got the brain freeze I'm not caught
with the brain freeze yeah you got that
brain freeze
[Music]
[Music]
you're big you're big
[Music]
thank you
no no no no no no
hey what are you eating what are you
eating yeah the [ __ ] away from me oh but
that's food God that's food though oh
damn
I like that I like the way you look you
look good to me
you a dude sorry
[Music]
hey what's up there listen is yourself
out there yes is it up there yes hey
come here I want to eat here
in my mouth
[Music]
let's get this party started
ladies and gentlemen
I'm Plus
Strokes of Genius beautiful games and
One Shining Moments this is Defenders
investigators and seven strangers picked
to live in a house this is Young
SpongeBob young Sheldon and the younger
this is everything you've been looking
for it's gonna leave a mark live sports
breaking news and a mountain of
entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now streaming
hello LaShawn hello Carousel oh Sammy
Carousel had another premonition oh what
was it this time she says an ostrich is
going to escape from the zoo today nope
she heard that on the news last night so
that's the thing that actually happened
in real life already okay well better
late than never all right well go make
Daddy some chamomile let's go come on go
around use the force there you go for
Sean
so I just got this letter from my
insurance company it looks like we are
officially on the same Insurance what
yes
I can't believe this yeah we're finally
not going to be treated like second
class oh my God now I want to see I want
to see I want to see I want to no don't
show me just tell me what are we covered
what are we covered how it's good
insurance we get dental uh oh my God
make me an appointment right now okay
Ruby filling and a Fang
S A Fang yes a single solitary Fang for
tricky foods and bottle caps you
understand that that's kind of an
elective procedure
to elect the Fang the president of my
mouth and then I'm going to get my voice
louder
yes so I can talk to birds all right so
well I don't know if we're gonna find a
dentist who can do that also it's not
covered in this assurance it's just the
basic Dental envisions
that is my name I'm gonna have one
contact that looks like a cat eye and
another contact that looks like a cat's
face that's missing an eye you don't
wear contacts everyone have a third eye
that looks like the letter I and it's
going to be in my eye and I'm going to
be like I see you
for the shine you don't wear contacts so
I'm going to need to wear contacts when
I have my eyebrows redid because they
say that kind of procedure will crumple
the corneans you're not getting your
eyebrows redid redone undone I'm gonna
have them switched on my face so when I
get mad I look delighted do you
understand that insurance is only for
real medical problems and even then we
have a deductible I'm going to deduct
the fat from my ass and put them in my
Fango so when I wave I look like Mickey
Mouse okay all right listen to what I'm
telling you right now what insurance is
not for you to have the bottom half of
your body cut off and you sewn to a
horse so you can experience what it's
like to be a center oh my God Sammy
that's a good idea that's not a good
idea because you die almost immediately
it would be worth a semi it would be so
worth it Sammy please tell me I can I
know that you want to do that but you
can't don't do it it's not covered by
the insurance oh Sammy this is why you
got to be the 80s to my disco right now
why do you have to um
I'm just trying to be the reality to
your
I'm gonna get another stomach one for
cherries and one for corn oh my God
that's right Sammy I'm gonna go to
couples therapy alone and just play both
parts yeah I want to go to the
gynecologist just ask questions till I
get it oh and I got another question a
few questions about how many different
parts of your body you can make to link
because I want to get my ear Lids done
and look my foot Pockets foot pockets
are this invention I've been thinking of
where you can just put your keys up by
your ankles then I'm gonna have a
coaster put on my shoulder so when I go
to a bar I can say you want to drink on
me and then I'm just gonna be like a
monster and for Halloween I'm gonna
dress up like a normal human being so
glad we could bring this project to this
neighborhood it's so rich in history
I grew up in a neighborhood like this oh
yeah I grew up in a neighborhood exactly
like this
all right welcome to Mama's sugar Banks
y'all ready to order yeah yeah can I
have a chicken fried steak with gravy
and a cola
I will have the baked beef short ribs
with collard greens and throw down some
of that cornbread
all right babe
you know what
hold up a second I'm also going to have
some of the collard greens and cornbread
as well but hook a brother up with some
of them hot links all right all right
you know what uh what am I trying to
front scratch all that give me some okra
and some fried red snapper and girl you
know I want some chitlins all right now
y'all got ham hocks
that was well that's what I want I want
to play the ham hocks deep fried
blackened and served on a bed of mustard
greens pig feet
I want some pig feet four pounds of
grits and oh oh and you know what else
give me a little Dixie cup full of lard
all right I just remember what I want a
bowl of mosquitoes none of them tiny
ones either give me them big
[ __ ] to find down at the swamp
sister could you please hook a brother
up with a rusty bucket full of fish
heads wrapped in razor wire donkey teeth
donkey teeth straight out a donkey's
mouth you know what any animal tooth
will do I want you to stick it in some
honey glazed fry with fat back and serve
it in an old tin coffee can forget
everything I said up to this point right
now bring me some dandelion greens a cow
hip and a dog face wrap that whole mess
in an old Ebony magazine and serve it to
me in a shoe box okay I want to platter
of stork ankles an old Cellar Door a
possum spine and a human foot
you want a human foot
mm-hmm
I got just one question for y'all
you want gravy on that salad though oh
definitely oh yeah yeah you got to put
gravy on it yeah without gravy it's not
food
it's really
[Music]
okay let's get this thing going
everybody take a seat
we gotta have more meetings homes
I'm telling you man we got to be working
nice
Carlito ain't got a seat man someone get
him a chair nah I'm cool no dude get him
at your homes nah man
I'm gonna sit gangster but Carlito it
doesn't look like he's comfortable man
why don't you just sit in the chair
I never sit in a chair essay
mm-hmm you're never ever gonna catch me
sitting in no chairs
like I said you know that that's local
right I don't know
it's cool Carlito No One's Gonna think
you're soft if you sit in a chair yes
we're all sitting in chairs hey a bunch
of [ __ ] ass culeros okay I don't have
no time to sit in a [ __ ] chair
huh
okay
not that we're all here
you know what but why though like it
don't make no sense for you to set
yourself up with the rule like that no
it's like limiting yeah limiting I mean
sometimes people sit in chairs man all
of you guys with your [ __ ] ass cherries
there
okay Carlito quit playing and sit in the
chair open the hole no Carlito we have
to have this meeting now and say get up
I'm good right here man you know I'm
chilling go ahead with your meaning okay
but you know it's gonna be weird
you don't care it's going to be weird
we're for you maybe
he doesn't care okay
okay homies so this is what we have to
do
like we gotta sum on drugs we gotta make
more crimes happen
Roberto where
Carlito you're bleeding essay
who cares man
oh
yo whoa you just got shamed man we gotta
pull that out leave it
I'm chilling homes
I don't care about that stupid Shank
Carlito
Carlito wake up man
don't even bother essay
oh thank you
I don't need those defibrillator
I don't even want to come back to
Lifehouse Carlito
go back into your body my body's stupid
homes
I'm fine right here on the spirit plane
life is for [ __ ]
[Music]
no I'm good man Carlito that's Heaven
man I don't need to go to heaven homes
Heaven is for [ __ ] oh boy
foreign
let me hit that
really
I can handle it
I am certain that you cannot how come I
smoked a ton of weed in the 90s
right the 90s
um you know weed has gotten a lot
stronger since then you honestly think
it's gotten so much stronger that I just
flat out can't handle it you think I'm
such a lightweight that if I take one
puff
an hour ago we've had the same
conversation 15 times in a row
hey you know what let me hit that really
thank you
Mike Cody yeah hey how are you man good
to see you hey I'm glad I ran into you
what is that joke that you told recently
at the office everybody is just like
giggling about it all the time and I
haven't heard it yet oh gosh okay
um all right it goes like this so
there's this woman
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so she goes to her doctor and she um she
says to her doctor uh kiss me
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh yeah
I don't know if you think the joke is
over but it's not it's actually just
started
[Laughter]
okay so I'm gonna I'm just gonna speed
it up so she says to her doctor kiss me
and he says I can't it would be
unprofessional no no not even close she
says he says that would be
unprofessional and then she says she
keeps asking him and he says no no no it
happens three times like that
finally at the end she says
kiss me and he says I shouldn't even be
having sex with you right now
then what happens
I I don't I don't know then I guess she
probably sue them for malpractice
[Laughter]
so you know that wasn't that wasn't the
punch line
this is the punchline no the punch
there's more
there's not more
you know there's actually less
no there's
a joke
the joke was the punch line was the only
part that you didn't laugh at
what
you got me you're doing a joke the whole
time you were doing a weird character
the whole time yes yes I love the
malpractice stuff the malpractice bunch
is hilarious so you weren't doing a
character what character what character
this is
yo
hey Yao
oh y'all
Excuse excuse me
oh man oh man oh man
I tell you one thing if 9 11's were to
happen up on this airplane
don't worry we got this
okay I have no idea what you're talking
about
he's saying and that fdm Terry's is
going to try some up in here today like
the bounce Boogie and bump
that we got dick
online
sir do you mean terrorists healthier
baby you ain't talking about Terry God
and I certainly ain't talking about no
terry cloth
and we need to tear up on this plane he
was thinking about trying to do
something we're gonna Whack Him Up
You're Gonna you're gonna what we're
gonna Drax
now
it's clouds
I think when my partner's trying to say
if any Terry's come up in here we gonna
get our Bergeron
did something happen or did I
missed something that's hypothetical or
oh we're gonna definitely Drive some
hypotheticals on that Terry's clavicle
because I'm talking about
squeeze squeeze squeeze
you just wish though don't you just wish
in your heart a heart thumb Terry would
come up in here trying some grab ass and
the touchy feeling that's the opposite
of what I want to have happen on a plane
okay that's unfortunate
hi friends
this was unexpected it certainly was I'm
thrown right now as to who's gonna be
our comrade I can still hear you he
doesn't have the heart not a gumption it
literally right next to me oh three
break three
you who
I got an idea feel free to say no but
can we switch seats I will not take no
for an answer
why that's the combat seat Jonathan
Livingston Seagull
if you gonna be in the combat seat then
you got to be willing to blast up on
some carries
because of great power comes great
response or trilograms
okay I just I just wanted some leg room
um okay Max legroom you get yours
meanwhile I'm gonna go hating pant in
the Airy awesome Terrys especially when
they get froggy
ribbit ribbit
um you gonna have to be ready to kidnap
a Terry I don't you're gonna have to be
ready to touch you I care I don't think
that's necessary absolutely you have to
fire board those mother gems I don't
even understand what that means do you
trust me no
I'll take that as a yeah okay
okay
draft
these terries come up in here trying to
act froggy then we gonna give them the
Rainbow Connection
box cutter oh you best believe it baby
we gonna be eating like Diane Keaton
2.350 inches baby you should wax
perfectly League whale and if those
don't work
you know I'm working up that plan leave
brother
baby 100
polyurethane they can't detect these
member generals
that's that's what the the devil weapons
[Applause]
oh my gosh
[Music]
Drax
I know
it's clouds
[Music]
[Music]
oh
there you are Cedric
what's up dude tiswell Cedric tiswell
yeah can I ask you a question man
um
why the hell are you dressed like this
and what the hell did you do to your
bike You Wanna Hurt
I'm steampunk now yeah I don't know what
that is man
Jules Vernon
I seriously think that you have cracked
man all right like like in your mind no
I ain't cracked up
I live in a clock now this
ah umbrellas and blimps
you're wearing a top hat with a door on
it
I'm just an ill ass Lemony Snicket up in
this [ __ ] but you
what's with you what's with me I'll tell
you what I'm I'm an ill ass normal
mother
who been waiting for his friend for an
hour and 10 minutes underneath a goddamn
Bridge we're two homeless
put chance good sir could you point me
in the direction of the nearest
apothecary
if you're talking about the drugstore
it's right there on the corner what time
does it close it closes at 10 o'clock
man you've been there a million times
I'll check just to be sure make sure
it's still open I'm telling you Levi if
you put that piece of pipe up to your
eye and use it as a telescope I cannot
be your friend anymore
yep
yep still open all right I have to go
then so
you try it no no I'm not gonna try it
because it's a piece of pipe and it
doesn't have any lenses in it therefore
it's not a Costco yes but how could you
be sure
science
I'm gonna look through this piece of
pipe and if it doesn't work like a
telescope then we finally done man like
not homies anymore we're done
[Music]
oh surgery why
like
ears
that would actually work such a
consistent
you look so ridiculous right now I look
um
say goodbye Ratatouille what what the
[ __ ] is that
oh
I wake up next to this guy and
as usual I don't even know his name
I'm trying to get dressed quickly and
get out of there before he wakes up but
I can't find my underwear
I look everywhere but I just can't find
them
and then it hits me
I had left them at another guy's
apartment earlier that night
and that's when I knew I had a problem
[Applause]
thanks for sharing this guy
well I noticed a lot of new faces this
evening
and I'm so glad you all came and I want
you to know that this is a safe place to
share
so if you want to tell us your story
there'll be no judgment
sure I'll go
hi y'all
name's Wendell and I am in fact a sexual
addict
and what brings you here Wendell
well you know my life
sexually speaking
it's crazy and I just want to find one
single solitary person
spend the rest of my life with just one
this one
so do you feel like your addiction is
too much to handle right now duh
I mean it's been crazy y'all
with me the nastier the better
I'm a dirty dog try everything all the
fixings
tantric
much like Sting
all the bells and whistles you name it
I've danced it
and when would you say you hit rock
bottom Wendell when it got slippery
outside my shower on the floor outside
my shower oh
I hit rock bottom sexually
oh probably last night last night do you
think that you could tell us what
happened Wendell yeah let's see uh it's
just like any other night I had ordered
a large pie pepperoni pineapple cheesy
crust
cheese bread on the side
uh cut two 30 men later
pizza parlor sent over a delicious lady
delivery person
bought a tan face tan
that's my weakness
so I invited her inside
opened up the box it was hot
devoured the First Slice lickety split
crust first
seconds last didn't stand a chance ate
the tip of that [ __ ] first washed it
down with a pop
then I got nasty with the cheesy bread
my heart started pounding harder than
usual her slunk her slunk moved on to
the third slice what about the girl what
girl oh the girl yeah she was there too
invited her into my Boudoir aka the
stabbing cabin
we just robed one another I touched her
on her genitalia she touch me I'm a
manitalia and that's when I hit it
sexually
of course
Upstairs Downstairs all around the town
stairs as you do and uh
by then it
was just another night and I mean
oil everywhere and
sauce all over man
sauce
oh yeah that's my word for
ejaculate
and who I'm so uh distraught because I
feel vulnerable and I don't know I just
feel like anyone
could take advantage of me right now and
knee one
okay let's see what the blondes have to
say first
well thank you wendellum thank you for
sharing it's actually our time today
[Applause]
not just another streaming app what this
is so much comedy it's not even funny
are you choking me bro this is daily
late and lately this is real roasted and
raw give it to me now this is great
stand-up great movies and the great
cornholio are you threatening me no this
is one pump two pumps and three pumps
this is live sports breaking news and a
mountain of Comedy entertainment
Paramount plus now streaming thank you
it's Friday night Make some noise
[Music]
put your hands up cause you're an actual
pimp put your hands up if you own a
bunch of women put your hands on
if you're gonna hit it all night put
your hands off
[ __ ] for 12 hours Put Your Hands Up
without the benefit of Viagra put your
hands up
if you a real I play Ed your hands up if
you abuse women's trust put your hands
up if you treat a light objects put your
hands up
if you will be alive Gangsta put your
hands up if you were real life gangster
put your hands up if you kill other
people put your hands up
if you're the biggest boss here put your
hands up
if you run an actual drug rig put your
hands up
if you just realize that you're full of
put your hands up
[Applause]
[Music]
it's your landlord
hey Devon
hey how you doing brother how you doing
yeah just uh
stopping by
just wondering
check up on everything
okay
nope
closet look good
door is strong
so y'all selling in yeah we've been
living here a year and a half so we have
so how these cupboards uh work it out
for you
besides your stuff which looks good
thank you
completely unrelated
have y'all seen a four foot 11 dude with
a purple beard up in here no no no no no
one's in here
probably because we locked the door
oh he got the body like a ratty he can
just squeeze through the vents yeah so
you think somebody's hiding in my
apartment no I told you just a social
call I mean why would General be in here
anyway Gerald there was a man with a
purple beard named Gerald in my
apartment hell no why did you see him
about four foot nine got a purple beard
[Music]
oh
hey baby girl
hey girl
oh bada bye have you seen a four foot
five purple beard baby Devon what's
going on
okay you know what I'm gonna level with
y'all there is a four foot three with a
purple beard named Gerald somewhere in
this building why does he keep getting
smaller every time you mention him
seriously because I didn't want to alarm
y'all he is disturbingly small really
he's a good guy
he smoke Rock though I mean he'll do
anything
to get money for crack
anything
okay
I mean anything
I get it he will murder you well
we certainly hope you find him oh I'm
old fathom don't worry about that
because I'm gonna look low
and then I'm gonna look
Joe you tiny little [ __ ]
we met b-boy Joseph in Atlanta GA hi
Joseph sir
stop the music
[Music]
has it started
I'm pretty sure this is it
[Music]
thank you
yeah thank you yeah are you done yet
though thank you Joseph it's it's
definitely a no for me it's a no I'm
sorry no
thank you Joseph thank you
because you know I I got a formal
training or nothing like that I learned
on the streets
well that was very apparent as it turns
out Joseph thank you for coming you know
that my mama's on drugs and my daddy in
jail
it's not not really relevant born in a
coffee can under a bridge that's
terrible Joseph that's that's awful but
it's not going to my sister shot my
brother but my cousin beat my uncle no
it's a little bit much Joseph thank you
very much but put myself through school
by renting my body out is a heroin
suitcase all right wow I see what's
going on Joseph please we do have other
dancers here today who are awaiting
their turn very politely now Joseph let
her come on stage let her cup know
Joseph if I won this competition I could
put a roof over my house because I got a
house ain't got no roof for real though
Joseph just one little thing though
don't do it Joseph it was a loud Bridge
don't finish that I got hearing damage
in this ear Joseph and also in this area
the bridge here we have trucks go over
it just because the bridge keep it 15
ton hold it
put it in your mouth
and get off my stage rated six Joe
that's a big truck Seth okay Joseph
please and who is this oh who is this
right here this is my 12 year old
daughter who I raised all by myself
without the help of anybody else in the
entire world she is my inspiration
Joseph it doesn't matter there's nothing
you can do or say that's going to make
us change our minds today now right
there that right there that's her
daughter she blind come on
[Applause]
so I raise them both by myself without
nobody else's help come get your ticket
to Vegas
oh yeah
I'm getting goosies over here
what does it take to save a child in
Africa
to save them from the violence to save
them
from becoming a Child Soldier
what if I told you
that all it took
was just one beard
the price of one costume beard you can
save a child
another statistic another warlord's Pawn
be safe
that's right
one beard
and for a little more you can get them
again
[Music]
[Music]
you're here for that Ginger
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
people we are wasting our time
wait
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go go
[Music]
call today
foreign
Mr cook you're almost up are you ready
good I'm good
really gonna need you to stick to the
script on this one I'm the CEO of Apple
Willis I'm not going to do anything
stupid please stop comparing me to Steve
Jobs no but nobody's comparing you to
Steve Jobs okay I just want you to focus
on the products and please stick to the
script okay you're on in three you're
gonna forget they ever heard the name
Steve Jobs
what up
[Applause]
you know the first thing that I'm gonna
do is
t-o-t-s throw out the scripts
now
I'm supposed to come out here and tell
you about some bull new iPhone pad pod
dick [ __ ] you've seen it I'm a bear I'm
a bear I'm a bit boring
yes that's exactly it
now let's just sit at this table right
here let's say it's Bill Gates huh
[Applause]
that's what I'm talking about and let's
say that this is our competitors new
smartphone
and let's say that this right here this
is one of our competitors new eBook
reader huh what about that what uh-oh
looks like rain
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
will allow you to teleport anywhere on
the planet check this out I am the
future
foreign
let's see Steve Jobs do that
[Applause]
listen up
cause you know what we only get one yeah
let's leave it all on the field today
we gonna give them some they can
remember
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's time to handle our business
is not an option
we all saw aren't we the best that
everyone
sometime this is our moment
we can't let nobody take this away from
us
we got to do this
together
[Applause]
you are my family
cause you're my brothers forever you
know I got your backyard
I know y'all got mine
we're taking this all the way
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
dream to do
can't nobody stop us
[Music]
[Music]
all right
play this game
like it's the last game of your life
[Music]
okay students settle down
settle down
that includes you Mr Rodriguez do you
want to take the milk carton off of your
head
thank you so much
we have a special guest today
he's from this neighborhood
and he's a former gang member
and he's coming here this morning
to talk to you about life choices
so please give a warm Central High
School welcome to Donnie Herrera
[Applause]
I used to be just like you
just like you you you you you
used to clown around
make fun of the principal
put milk on my head just like you
Rodriguez
and then
I got hit with AIDS
consequences
[Music]
got into some real trouble oh boy
[Music]
stole from my mom and dad
stole from my own sister and then one
day
a piano fell on my head what
consequences
I feel like you missed the step there
gave me 88 concussions one for each key
you think I'm learning but no
see I'm just like you I got back out
there started making some real crimes
home boy
oh yeah
oh yeah
and then
I got trampled by a herd of buffalo what
consequences okay Donnie um I think
we've had enough done with my story
I was like you I decided to be cool to
hang out with some of the tough kids
you know who I'm talking about they were
hanging on the streets late at night
more than cigarette smokers homes and
then
that's it okay into the mouth of a
dragon students everything you've heard
here today is a lie I don't lie anymore
you're all excused
[Music]
look at me
I shouldn't
he here
I apologize so I got really deep in the
crimes I did a drive by at my own
daughter's quinceanera
yeah shut up everybody dead killed yeah
yeah
yeah then I got sucked into a wormhole
consequences that's it okay everybody go
I was in another dimension tried to
introduce my own Fest to each other
arm was disappearing I invented Johnny B
Goode and my parents prom and at the
last moment they kissed and it came back
the faster we get away from them the
better so nobody believe me
where's my crack oh my God
oh
all right so we have to remember H5 okay
um oh I got it high five oh I see oh
that's good that's what you're trying to
do they're trying to figure out a
mnemonic device uh okay high fives came
out in the 70s that's when they were
invented that's a seven yeah there's two
of us so so if you subtract two from
Seven that's five okay great so you got
it so and then um there's five major
food groups why are you going on oh no
you're gonna love this it's just it's
fun for me because it's a puzzle nope no
puzzle okay five major food groups
there's meat vegetables grain Dairy and
fruits okay my favorite fruit is
pineapple but you know that we got it
already pineapple comes from Hawaii okay
my favorite current show is Hawaii
Five-O why five oh okay so that's it
done we're done Scott Scott Khan is the
soft Hawaii Five-O we're really talking
about his father is James Khan who's one
of the five major Stars what's wrong of
the one of the five major huge Stars
yeah age right of The Godfather
and it's easy to remember her name
because her name is the same last name
as Buster Keaton and Michael we're just
going through the Comedians and when you
left you say ha stop stop stop stop stop
stop stop you see what you're doing
you're over complicating the whole thing
we already had it you just you just
you're just making it more difficult
just like you do everything I left my
phone in the car
which is wait hold up a Dap no no it was
it was handshake no I got it I got it I
got it Buster Keaton and Michael Keaton
same last name is Diane Keaton it's one
of the five huge stars on The Godfather
movies that's Keaton Brando Duval Pacino
and James Khan oh who is the father of
Scotland who's the Starfall Hawaii
pineapple pineapples
five major Foods uh there's two of us
five plus two is seven that's the
seventies
it turns out it wasn't a ghost at all it
was my little sister hiding in the
basement
making the noises the whole time
foreign
oh shoot I forgot his juice boxes oh I
will be right back you'll be all right
with that I think so okay
so
Zachary
you know I'm gonna be marrying your
mother
and uh I'm gonna be moving in soon and I
just
I'm so excited to spend more time with
you
you know I know
that you had a hard time with your
father and
it spanked you and you know
I just want you to know
it's not gonna happen with me
okay
and I promise I will never spank you
oh
okay that's
okay
um
I know why you did that
but I will never spank you because I
know that you still oh that's
nah
I don't know that there's anything I did
to deserve that oh hey this
you okay
I'm gonna be real with you
you can't go hitting people all right oh
oh oh I ain't coming back for that
fourth one
all right so we done we got that out of
our system because I know
that this
this isn't you
oh I told you you wanna
oh come on thanks
oh what oh that's unbelievable
I'm the good guy I'm
I'm the good guy man
look
I'm never gonna spank you
I'm not going to be like your father
I'm gonna be your friend
you need to respect me you understand
you little
I will respect you Charles
if you play your role
now listen up
I'm a bad bad boy Charles
[Music]
I don't need
friend
so go ahead marry my mommy move in
or as hard as you want
just leave me the alone
you do that
11 years from now I'll be out of the
house and we won't have any problems
you don't
and I will break you
okay Charles
[Applause]
how are we doing I love it
[Music]
well well well
Jack welcome make yourself comfortable
you're going to be here for quite some
time
you'll never get away with this dravich
it's all big one
leave us
you're wasting your time dravich the
military codes were destroyed he's not
so
I think you're bluffing Jack
and I am about to call
your blood you see Jack I am a player in
this game
but
I'm also the dealer I hold all of the
cards
[Music]
you see Jack if I were to go all in
you would not be able to cover the bed
what are you doing
I was thinking I
maybe I could be like
you're torturing assistant or something
I could be in the room with you and like
be that guy that stands in the
background all intimidating like
over there and keep your trap shot
that's what I was thinking
are you two done with your little ladies
chat oh
shouldn't have said that
you know jackets very apropos but you
would say that
because I feel like we
should have a chat and when I say we I
mean just you and me
are you a chess player Jack sure
so then you're aware that
each piece serves a different function
you see
whereas you are merely upon
you see Jack I am the queen
I am allowed to move around the board
with impunity
yeah man I was thinking like maybe
during your chest speech you could suck
on this lollipop because then that shows
him like you so comfortable with torture
you just do something stupid like
sucking on a lollipop you see what I'm
saying
foreign
okay
oh no there's absolutely no ore involved
go over there okay
you shouldn't call yourself a queen
though because where I'm from that means
something different
check
they've been waiting for this moment
for a very
very long time
I wanted to make an introduction
to your new best friend
oh this will make you talk Jack
plus you don't even need to stab him at
first you can just like caress his cheek
with the blade some something just real
like crazy yeah I got it I got it yeah
you're good that's what I was planning
on doing I'm sorry where did we find you
who is Shaquan Shaquan no now I'm asking
you who he is he got kicked into some
lava so that's when I came in okay
that's wonderful
I need you to go over there
attention to be stuck still
like a statue
okay now like immediately keep moving in
that direction oh yeah I'm good
Jack
the military codes are not even the
primary reason why you are here I wanted
you all to myself he's standing back
there like an actual statue or something
yeah it's weird
God damn it
the one you don't have to stand like an
actual statue not literally I didn't
mean it literally ah all right I thought
that sounded stupid when you said that
originally so I was like it would be
stupid for a person to do something like
that shoes I didn't know I was like what
that doesn't make
Jack
today you will experience the most
Exquisite pain I made to give up yo we
got pictures of his girlfriend that's it
that's pretty much torture over right
there you can just show them pictures of
his girlfriend and he'll do whatever you
say there it is oh you know what even
better we got a cage it's got a hole at
the bottom so you can put that over his
head you in this other hole you put like
a rat or a scorpion up in there that's
what is this for the Quan all right that
is what it is bad for in the first place
all of the implements that they're
seeing on the table there are there for
a particular reason
foreign
would you like to be involved that's
what I was thinking since the beginning
I was thinking
maybe you should just tell them like the
military codes
was I speeding officer
you don't look like you're from around
here no sir
you've been doing any drugs tonight no
sir nope
why don't you pop that trunk stuff out
of vehicle for me please
really
no drugs huh
nope
well well well
what have we here no no no no no no no
no no you planted that in my car oh did
I
or did I plant this uh I I guess the car
right now spread them uh
whoa whoa what do we have here huh what
these are colors homie that's that's
something no I don't know or are these
your colors or perhaps these are your
colors or are these look at all these
colors man you sure got a lot of colors
look at all of these colors
are you a real cop freeze what is that
well well well
it looks like an illegal firearm
or
is it
oh
I don't I don't know what this is I'm
sorry pick a card
it's not even a good fan any card you
can just stick it there okay you took
that card yeah now can you remember that
card yes can you commit that card to
memory this is unbelievable have you
done so
have you done
please insert the card back into the
deck random done it's in a different
place than where you took it originally
there we are there we are Nicholas I
take the deck like so I give it a slices
and Abacus Royce
oh
[ __ ]
ah is this
your call no are you sure I want your
badge number oh
hey
how did you do that
and
that is for you
after all that you're still giving me a
ticket is it a ticket
or is it a two-for-one coupon for my
show at the magic house Thursday night
at 11 PM
your call
I'll take the ticket
good morning ladies and gentlemen we are
about to begin boarding South Northern
Airlines flight 34 to Grand Rapids
reporting group one I'm an important
group one excuse me I'm in boarding
group one
we're getting pre-boarding with our
first class passenger passengers first
class passengers only please
next are business class passengers may
now board
okay now we would like to welcome our
Regal Alliance Elite members Regal
Alliance Elite members
okay now all passengers with children
anyone with small children you'll be
born now
okay we would like to continue boarding
with uniformed military personnel what
why kids
thank you for service thank you so much
for your service God bless you thank you
for your service thank you for your
service
all right people in wheelchairs
any priests nuns rabbis imams what why
do they get special treatment assalamu
alaikum I've never
that's typical any old people in
wheelchairs with babies
any old religious people with military
babies what's a military
for your service
Jason Schwartzman
anyone with a blue suitcase you may now
board finally no not you sir not me this
is a blue suitcase that's a blue
computer bag so you're not you're not
gonna let me on then
damn it damn it damn it damn it damn it
God damn it
anyone who doesn't seem cranky
the people who will now be boarding any
drunk people
like pizza no it's my bag sir
oh
hello
oh hey Christian
yeah
totally
well you have your favorites and I have
my favorites
okay
call you later
boarding group one
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
let's wrap it up people
boarding group one over here get a
boarding group one
two three
there goes the girl
I knew she was the one right from the
star who our love is here to stay each
and every day we know that we will never
apart
[Music]
great work everybody Troy I love that
little Motown outro thing super Soulful
cool thanks Lyle yeah it just uh came to
me so I went with it wow
crazy hey is this uh one of the acapella
group mates oh hey Mark hey Lyle what's
going on buddy Mark get over here guys
this is my buddy Mark he just
transferred from Minnesota I thought he
could uh sit in on a few practices I
don't know maybe join the group or maybe
all right guys let's do always then my
girl again from the top
Mark show us your stuff you got it man
all right guys ready one two three
[Music]
each and every day
[Music]
foreign
just
went with it
great well keep going with it guys have
a safe weekend all right see you on
Monday nice to meet you guys man yeah
that was awesome it was neither bad cool
guys great practice right good effort
all right
[Music]
yeah check you later guys see you later
alligators
foreign
this is my seven white boys
back don't know
that
I'm about to get mine
I still have any idea how long it took
for me to infiltrate this world
25 minutes
you think I'm gonna roll over or some
falsetto ass mom
you know what
white boys is going to do
what white boys is going to do
and if they want to run with a high-ass
singing falsetto
then that's on them oh that's on that
man oh that's so Milky Way so it's like
that always stole like that well watch
your back
watch your back was you with my
good jokes oh
and improvise oh it's so cold out it's
gonna be dark soon oh my God yeah we
should build a fire oh yeah yeah
um oh I can't uh
hey man what a cat gotta be black Grease
foreign
man I guess I gotta put my dick away
[Music]
this is
what's the matter rich in the next
episode Steve Urkel turns Carl into a
giant sandwich and accidentally eats him
oh wait that's hilarious but it's
hilarious come on I'm an actor Gene this
was supposed to be about me and my
family but you know after that after
that first death spot with Steve Urkel I
mean America fell in love with him man
we had to make him a regular and you
know Hey listen he's the star of the
show now sweetheart we gotta play ball
bubble don't you dare bubble of me Gene
now last week Steve used his
transformation machine to turn Carl into
a car and drive him around the Monaco
Grand Prix come on how many times we're
going to use this transformation machine
this was supposed to be a blue collar
Cosby Show now you turn it into goddamn
Quantum Leap all right I couldn't tell
you even if I wanted to okay but we got
like 21 writers up there okay no I'm
saying Reginald but you and I both know
but they don't decide what happens in
the show okay we both know who decides
what happens in the show two weeks ago
Steve Urkel used his invisibility Ray on
Carl and I wasn't even in the goddamn
episode it was just yes I know I know
Reginald I'm sorry I apologize will
never happen again Dan Steve used his
voice changing ready to turn Carl into a
high-pitched nerdy Voice who do you
think provides the voice for that don't
get too feisty on me now reg let's not
go down that path okay oh oh we are
going down that path Gene in a couple of
weeks Harriet Eddie Laura grandma Aunt
Rachel Little Richie and the other
little kid are gonna get teleported to
another dimension and then Steve injects
Carl with his own DNA so Carl turns into
another Steve Urkel that's two Steve
urkels and no family on the show called
Family Matters does that work listen
listen ratchet Urkel Mania is
Unstoppable okay he's a phenomenon
there's nothing we can do about okay
it's up to
him no no no no no no no I'm an actor
I'm a [ __ ] actor I'm a real actor I
think Richard III I was in true West
with Sherman Helmsley I was in Die Hard
damn it
Steve Urkel you will suck Steve urkels
let me want you too you all stuck it you
understand he is our bread and butter
you mother I am high on cocaine
I got more cocaine than you weigh mother
I'm gonna tell you what you are
Russellville Johnson you're a pawn in
that nerd's game you are a pawn do you
think I have any power ever let that
monster does any power at all
I am the Seeker vice president of
development for the American bro
Jane
Jane
what's become of Eugene
[Music]
I
am nothing
do you not I don't know what you mean by
that actually but you're scaring me no
no don't don't do anything crazy
everyone does too much coke sometimes
but they're just what are you gonna do
with the gun Gene what are you gonna do
dude no no no no no no no no
we can talk this through
uh okay the king is dead
long live the king
did I do that
[Music]
Jaleel
there is no Jaleel
only Steve
it's always been Steve
Steve
forgetting something Carl
don't you come near me stay away from me
here could have all been so simple Carl
just say your lines
and take the money
what are you doing
I I can't control am I doing this no no
no no no no no no no no see I I'll do
anything you do what I want on Family
Matters
yes oh of course Steve
[Music]
see you on set Carl
get out of my house Steve
foreign
expecting to see you all undulating up
here I I just uh put my jacket on the
bed when I first came to the party but
uh I didn't realize that the party made
its way up here but I'll get that now I
will if you uh Carol I don't know if
you're in there somewhere but uh
wherever you are thank you for the
invitation I really enjoyed myself I see
you at work tomorrow okay Hey sir I
think I see my jacket I think I think
your arm is in the sleeve actually I'll
grab that's not my jacket and that's not
your arm it's not your arm white people
are crazy white people are crazy just
looking for a jacket sir okay yeah very
nice mustache I've never seen one above
the nose that's interesting that's not
your nose okay it's already uh disturb
you sir just looking for a jacket just a
ordinary man looking for a jacket you
want to say something to me sir are you
okay no thank you very much sir it
tasted a little bit like I felt it but
that's okay it's Tweed the jacket I'm
talking about and it's got leather
patches on it just oh maybe this is it
thank you found it and nope that's not
it but congratulations man you are doing
great with what God gave you nope don't
look at me in the eyes ma'am I don't
want you to steal my soul hi ladies and
nice to meet you and sir yes I do see
you too okay yeah if white people are
crazy oh no I'm okay I really am I'm uh
already seeing a a group of people and
we're taking it slowly we are taking it
slowly it's a church maybe some of y'all
would be interested in looking into that
not mine but one somewhere if that's
okay thank you ma'am for there it is I
found it found the jacket it's right
here I'm gonna pull it and I believe it
might be lodged somewhere within you I'm
just guessing because that is just a
little bit of resistance all right there
we go and you know what that is going to
be yours keep it thank you cover
yourself up Carol if you're in there
I'll see you at the office tomorrow just
bring the bowl you can finish the egg
salad my God why people cry
go to SeaWorld boy how was Kenya yes I
love Kenya absolutely adore the place
you know it's so important to protect
them you know the few untouched tribes
left indeed yes and while we're on the
subject I've got something of a
confession to make oh dear well I was
down there I caught the attention of a
young Messiah woman you didn't she took
me for an exotic sophisticated Superman
of sorts and developed something of a
liking to me well isn't that always the
way yes it is and it's quite awful
Gerald she came down to my heart wearing
nothing but a fertility headdress and
carrying a husband's dick and oh I had
to participate in that custom well
you'll be morally irresponsible if you
did not participate in the custom you
could destroy the entire social
structure oh I felt so terrible about
what yes you did Gerald I felt terrible
seven times but you know Gerald I too
have a confession remember several years
ago when I went to the Amazon yeah yes
well I accidentally packed a lighter in
my Satchel oh my yes well one day I
absent-mindedly lit the Flint and the
entire Village took me from a god
and as I was being politic by all the
which is the local custom I felt
completely embarrassed by the entire I
can only imagine in some vivid detail
but you can't deny the local cast you
absolutely I cannot deny the locals
one thing you must do is adhere to the
local customers
after that evening a couple of the local
men called me Papa
Whoopsie Daisy indeed it's getting
harder and harder to protect the local
tribes from the influence of the outside
civilization I knew exactly what you
mean exactly and I'm asking person that
the last time I was deep in the Boston
Australia yes I ended up Deep In Motion
Australia
well what are you off to now I'm off to
Tanzania Tanzania make sure that you go
during an eclipse because then everyone
will want to have sex with you
regrettably
man
we launched the counter-attack against
the Union Army we must remember that
even though we may die a glorious death
on the battlefield we do so to preserve
a way of life
the southern way of life
a way of life so pure and beautiful
that no man no government can take this
away from us
the right
the right to preserve
our own son
[Music]
we
well hello there
those sorry weird
sure didn't mean to sneak up on you sir
fellas we're trying to have a nice
little Civil War reenactment here we
don't want any trouble so Lisa we we try
to have a real nice
you always taught us trouble don't look
after those who gone done looking
forward so don't stop your speech in a
knockout
as Jefferson day okay I know what you're
doing I get it what we do so
I don't know what you're talking about
do you know what he's
talking wow we just hear the slave on
about any oh which way you want us to
how many times do I have to tell people
just because we're dressed like
Confederate soldiers doesn't mean we're
pro-slavery we're just here to preserve
the pure and beautiful slice of Southern
history yeah pure and beautiful like
slice
[Music]
oh it's so sorry please don't give us
the whip okay nobody's gonna whip
anybody just stop it yeah just stop it
all right fellas just just ignore them
all right
now we're here to preserve our way of
life the South has the right to own the
South as a way of life
Union cannot stop us
[Music]
the union Yankee bastards cannot stop us
from God stop it stop it that's enough
you want to be part of this reenactment
fine you're part of it go go fetch us
some Munitions and everything else don't
just stand there like a bunch of lazy
that good enough for you that is all I
needed to hear gentlemen give us your
cash and anything that is an actual
collector's item you racist mother okay
don't have all day man okay thank you
thank you wallets wallets wallets
wallets that's a very nice piece what
these are Papa thank you for coming
first order business I'm sure you all
heard the Twigs got pulled out the river
this morning there ain't no secret he
and Carvel rubbing the hood together
listen up
Carmel about to say some words
[Music]
okay you know what don't none of you
look at them tears and think that is
funny because it takes a big man to cry
in front of his crew
go ahead Carmel
y'all know twig with my boy
back in the day
we used to pretend the sofa cushions or
the fort
and we used to pretend that the floor
with more lava
okay you know what though
ain't nothing funny about that
of course this man is crying because he
and twigs was kids together okay I mean
these best friends forever
go ahead Carvel
we used to play Care Bear
[Music]
twig then I would spend
the good part of an afternoon trying to
figure out with Care Bear who we was
oh oh I wish one of y'all
we just start laughing cause y'all know
you think this is funny Carvel over here
blubbering and talking about Care Bears
but you know what
but you
know
some manly tears okay tell us some manly
ass kids right there that you looking at
go ahead Carvel
[Laughter]
I'm sorry man that was a weird ass
sneeze I just did right there God damn
it can a brother get some Claritin up in
here
go ahead Carvel
wig thought we fainted himself share
bear
[Music]
always I always thought thought of
myself as more of a sunshine okay okay
oh you need to respect that right there
okay y'all need to listen to Fun
ction
I'm sorry man you were funshine bear man
I'm sorry that that is something funny
[Laughter]
whoa
all right let's go throw some crack
welcome to the 2015 East West Bowl pro
edition of all the All-Star games in
professional sports this one is sure to
be the most extravagant that's right
these players were selected by the fans
too and when it comes to Flair these
characters are the creme de la Crowne
creme de La Creme Vanderbilt University
Cosgrove Shumway
Clemson HaHa Clinton-Dix University of
Alabama
Dupree
West Virginia University
of Central Florida
senior Central Connecticut State
University
Georgia Southern University the
birkenshaw Ferguson University of
Virginia strong plugin
University of South Carolina still
Octavian roboclick
Grambling State Cornelius Tank Carradine
Florida State University
vergonia's Thicket suede
Mama Dune shazbot
Tulane University swordless mime town
Jacksonville State University
[Music]
Eric let me tell you something
HaHa Clinton-Dix and strong fluggett
you're looking at players who made an
impact this year I mean is HaHa
Clinton-Dix even real this guy was
amazing so solid all season long for the
Green Bay Packers and when you throw in
guys like Lagoon Dupree thorntless mime
town and the brickashaw Ferguson this is
surely going to be a squad for the ages
I agree now let's meet the players from
the West
thank you
Prince of mukamera University of
Nebraska
Junior
Texas Christian University oh Dallas
University Oregon
Fozzie Whittaker the University of Texas
myriad
profiteroles
Utah
Busters Brown
Illinois cupcake
[Music]
man
you know herself
it's a small kitchen Kent State
University take it to them
limit
College of the Canyons
snarf men's plots East Los Angeles
College Frosty Rucker University of
Southern California
[Music]
State University here triple parakeet
shoe Ball State
Aaron Rodgers
cow
let's get this party started ladies and
gentlemen this is Paramount Plus
genius Beauty
and One Shining Moments this is
Defenders investigators and seven
strangers picked to live in a house this
is Young SpongeBob young Sheldon and the
younger this is everything you've been
looking for it's gonna leave a mark live
sports breaking news and a mountain of
entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now streaming
foreign
[Music]
there's gotta be another human being out
there
somewhere
[Music]
73
73 doing
today
I may be the last man alive
if there is another
I will find them
the loneliness is more than I can
[Music]
oh there we go
over there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'll come to you man
[Music]
[Music]
there's gotta be another human being out
there
[Music]
somewhere but babe
moving out
please this is the worst possible time
please don't do this
babe
garbage huh
okay now take your garbage yeah sure
you know
I find
the more garbage in the can
the better it feels to dump it all out
I suppose that's why we let it get so
full in the first place
so we can start over
here to fix the copier yes sure sure hey
how did you sometimes things ain't
really broken
it's the way we treat them
it needs to be fixed
[Music]
[Music]
who the hell are you guys the important
question is who are you Steve
well
if it isn't Mr stand now Carl
[Music]
you need to find your own little
troubled white boy
I was here foist
[Music]
sweep this
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you all right
well
I guess sometimes things have to come
apart before we can put them back
together again
oh you're a magical negro too
who you call a negro [ __ ]
and gentlemen
please turn off your cell phones and
enjoy our production of lunch with
greatness
my my my what a beautiful day in
Montgomery Alabama
I swear the sun is so hot I nearly
melted indeed Dr King but I suspect we
didn't meet here to talk about the
weather
indeed brother Malcolm unless of course
we articulate that the sun in this
country shines brighter on some than it
does on others
yes but when the sun does shine on us it
is growing the seeds of revolution
[Music]
I see your point brother Malcolm but do
not those same seeds need to be watered
with love
well I suppose that is the subject of
some discussion Dr King
and I am all for discussion brother
Malcolm
unless of course the words devolve into
proclamations of hate
thank you
well is that not why we are here today
Dr King to discuss
yes brother Malcolm and I am confident
that as we discuss we are going to
discuss it
and discuss it
until I say
that
our people have never resorted to
violence before the white man gave them
no choice but to pay him back in the
Holy currency he understands
[Applause]
brother Malcolm
is that what you really have to say at
this point
in our lunch indeed Dr King
because we didn't land on Plymouth Rock
Prim of the rock landed on us
foreign
[Applause]
okay well yes all right yeah I've heard
you say that before I don't know why
we're talking about rocks when in fact
it is the Flesh and the bone and the the
dreams I I have a dream that someday our
children will be judged by the content
of their character not by the color of
their skin
same for me same for me in fact I
believe that one day a black man will
become the president of the United
States of America
hopefully for eight years
[Applause]
of course he is that's a given right
that's a given you know I mean but in
order to get there isn't he going to
need the help of a strong beautiful
black women
sisters
gotta respect the sisters
57 always
oh excuse me sir are you sitting in 26g
yes have I done something wrong no no no
we just wanted to ask if you would mind
switching seats so that a mother and a
child could sit together but
I'm back there right yeah but you'd
actually be sitting here
which is an economy Plus
um It's actually an upgrade
upgrade you say
economy Plus
yes sir oh
don't mind if we do great great uh carry
on
carry on yourself Alex
thank you
[Music]
economy Plus
for the Discerning passengers
we're not in Kansas anymore
like we're gonna have a smooth flight
trust me I know the captain
it's one smooth guy
[Music]
[Laughter]
of course he knows the captain
he is the captain Oh Oh
move over Colin mockery there's a new
face in the biz
his name is Captain
I have to be an economy plus to get it I
guess
ah
extra foot room
one inch at least
mmm
Sky shop magazine
oh the dog is
Lord of the Rings cups
Lord of the Rings tables
holy shiatsu massage
economy plus it hurts a little bit but I
like it
Rosebud
[Music]
foreign
I thought I had an upgrade
[Music]
amen
you gotta let me out of here
oh okay
foreign
[Music]
so so I I do have to let you out of here
yes okay
[Applause]
[Music]
bonboy
orders to let him go I don't know why
he's in there in the first place I don't
know
foreign
sorry yeah you must think I'm stupid
well I'm not stupid I'm smart so yeah
you know how you can prove that you're
really smart oh yeah let me guess you
want me to let you out of here again
well you know what you think you can
trick me into letting you out again well
you can't
because this is my choice
foreign
[Applause]
all right
reverse psychology
I am sorry about that guys
that was me guys my bad my bad
real nice now they said they're gonna
dock my pay and if I let you out of here
again I'm going to be severely punished
I mean I know
I'm actually surprised they haven't
already thrown you in here with me no
prison is for bad guys you're you're a
bad guy and I'm a good guy
yeah but you can see how from my
perspective I'm a good guy
wait you're a good guy oh my gosh
it doesn't seem like you understand what
your job is
uh oh okay
I see what you're doing you're trying to
you're trying to manipulate me with
reverse psychology well it's not gonna
work
it's not even worth going out there
again look they're just gonna get me and
bring me back in here just like they
always do
[Music]
unless what
no I'm forget it I don't want to take
advantage of him anymore
I'm not gonna fall for it Whatever It Is
you may as well just tell me
I was just gonna say that like if you
were to help me
get past the guard yeah and all the way
out okay I really I have to tell you you
need to think about this long and hard
weigh your options and consider the
ramifications of those options that's
like well
let's go
I don't care don't yell man you might as
well Ring the Alarm
[Music]
oh boy I did it again
[Music]
prison a guard that's a prison guard I
wasn't allowed to talk to the prisoners
that was the thing they said to me if
you talk to those prisoners you're going
to get trouble you're gonna get in
trouble and now that I'm here
[Music]
wow you really came out of nowhere what
no no I was stopped at that stop sign
yeah
listen uh let's just exchange
information and have our insurance
companies take care of it right
yeah
I'm gonna get my info
yes please
what are you doing what are you doing
huh
why did you start the engine blood
engine
the engine of your car did I
yes
I was just trying to get the uh
information for you from the glove box
do you need to start your car to open
your glove compartment
uh yeah
okay you know what how about I just uh I
get your insurance information now right
sure
hey no hey hey hey stop stop stop
stop stop where the hell are you going
uh nowhere give me the information right
now okay right now do you understand
okay okay all right sorry I I
misunderstood I don't see how all right
here it is no no I no your your
insurance information I just did this is
a Walgreens receipt oh oh
here it is
licensed to fart
what is that that now now you're just
miming you know what give me your
insurance information right now or I'm
calling the cops okay all right okay
okay dude I'm sorry I'm sorry that's
just that's my personality I was messing
with you I apologize I thought you were
gonna take off and and flee the scene
yeah no I'm not whoa then how am I gonna
get my car fixed hey we just had an
accident it's obviously not a place so
I'm sorry
here you go
here it is I mean can you imagine though
yeah that you were gonna take off yeah
yeah I can't imagine that it's giving me
chills on the [ __ ] spine
anyway
here's the real insurance card and uh
let me know what you think
official laminated license to [ __ ]
hey
[Laughter]
I am amazed hey all I know is it's good
having another brother move into the
neighborhood hey man it's good to have
you over and I think that you will dig
this
you
hey
nice guitar collection oh thanks Manny
you want to hear something
yeah sure all right
all right let's get this
well I'm just a good old American boy
with a heart that's red and true
dreaming of the girl with the red hair
and freckles in her eyes like the skies
of blue
country music I grew up in Texas you
know so all right keep her safe from the
homies in the wrong side of town where
they're smoking the reefer and acting
like
clowns keep that Purdue address from
getting dirty and brown because that's
the American way
foreign
racist
against who
of black people black people but I'm
black
well keeping the red-headed girl away
from the homies on the wrong side of
town homies come on brother there's all
kinds of homies you know you white
homies Asian homies
nah homies are black no I think you're
making them black man I mean I think
that's your stuff you hear the twang
and then you assume that it's racist but
that's that's just what country music is
like here look you're gonna like this
one you'll like this one all right
some folks wear their hats way off to
the side with their pants down low and a
gun tucked inside take their beer by the
40 and their chicken deep fried I think
we all know who we're talking about
the only dark I like is when I turn off
the lights the only Hood I love is
pointy and white tan trust you if I
can't see your face at night I think we
all know
wait wait hey stop that
that's racist what's what what is racist
about it the only Hood I love is pointy
and white yeah man let's talk about the
clan man
the Ku Klux Klan
are you outside of your mind that's
traditional country music imagery man
like a pickup truck or sleeping under
the stars or your dog got killed or your
wife left you same thing I would have
been fine with any of those things what
is the difference between those things
and what is in the song they're not
racial hey you know I can't just say
something man I'm just gonna be frank
you're getting a little like Al Sharpton
like um Farrakhan on me right now oh my
God are you serious dude hey give me you
know can I do one more let me just do
one more dog I absolutely promise you
that this song is not racist and it's
impossible for you to misinterpret it as
such
okay it seems like you're about to sing
the most racist song so far
me a tree okay I'm out and
come on man hey
think about a tire swing
right off an entire genre music
[Music]
and the drums are a banging let's get
the boys together and have ourselves a
hanging oh damn now I see it
nah
[Music]
well tonight we gonna party till the
party don't stop and the party don't
stop because it keeps on going non-stop
gonna party all night gonna keep this
party going cause the party won't stop
it's been two straight days and the
party still going two three four five
six seven days till it's Friday again
and then the party keeps going party all
night cause it's an all-night party
Friday night 9 p.m
we're going to a party sending texts
cell phone rings iPad Facebook Party
Time skin tight jeans Friday nights
dance dance dance cause tonight we're
going out and we ain't coming back cause
the party won't stop and we'll go all
night Friday night every night the
party's going down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
New York City L.A Chicago Houston Philly
San Diego Phoenix Austin Fort Worth
Boston Memphis Denver Portland Vegas
Tucson Fresno Akron Tampa Pittsburgh
newer Plano Lincoln love it Durham Salem
Dayton city city city
[Music]
party
[Music]
so tonight we're gonna party till the
Party Don't Stop
[Music]
hey Uncle Tim oh cheers
I got you didn't I yeah you got me man
you got me pretty good oh so what's
going on today oh just the usual Young
Buck just another day at the laundromat
while people come in they do their
laundry we chatted up about some of the
topics of the day
that's just another day hanging at the
mat
what's going on in the barbershop today
so it looks like they're having fun over
there
forget all that Keith come on we got our
own assortment of colorful characters
right here in the mat
hey man you need any more corners nope
okay okay
Larry is oh hey there miss Demetrius you
need some more quarters
oh she didn't hear me that's part of the
problem uncle Ted
and noise I've been hearing from the
machines running and it's kind of hot
loud and hot
sounds like my old lady
[Music]
G Williams is in there now he's Lando
Calrissian he runs Cloud City
[Music]
all right
damn it Keith
when I tell you we got it going on right
here at the map baby
uncle Ted I gotta tell you something
[Music]
I got my own washer and dryer months ago
keep hanging out here because I didn't
want you to feel bad
oh you didn't want me to feel bad
got your wash and dryer all right
no you've been timing me now okay I see
how it is hey well your shirt ain't
clean your pants ain't clean
you can't get a good wash on one of them
home washes dry
I'm going I don't know wait wait wait
wait wait wait let's have some fun let's
have some fun you could get in one of
the larger cars and I can push it around
no
I'm out of here
wait wait
hold on and then keep keep
work then you do a little tap dance and
then you go
I'm your man
hey welcome to the barber shop young man
you're Billy t Williams yeah yeah how
you doing I'm good thank you do me a
favor yeah could you let go of my hands
okay
oh thanks man all right
[Music]
YouTube
[Music]
yeah and I felt sorry for that dude but
you know we're gonna do I had to lay
that down
what then lay you down hey brother I
don't know what fight you was at they
got a couple licks to ensure but I was
like [ __ ] man I put the [ __ ] on the
Chain whacks
[ __ ] on the chain wax
[Music]
is that a thing
well yeah that yeah so that's a that's a
thing yeah yeah that's something
okay yeah I put the [ __ ] on the chains
[Applause]
I just um Google [ __ ] on the chain wax
no results man um why are you googling
no I'm just saying [ __ ] on the chain
wax
not an expression
yeah it is yes thank you Leo yeah what
what does it mean then what does it mean
I'll tell you what it means no it means
that
is that you put the [ __ ]
[Applause]
okay
y'all know what it is okay have either
the two of you have you ever said the
words [ __ ] on the chain wax in any
context
us
he told me you man you ain't talking to
me
hey man it's not our fault that you
ain't never put that [ __ ]
[Applause]
no one can put the [ __ ] on the chain
wax cause [ __ ] on the chain wax ain't a
thing
you trying to start a thing aren't you
what
I mean what are you talking about trying
to start a thing a thing like off the
hook or I'm gonna put you on blast you
try and get it in The Ether so everybody
out there saying [ __ ] on the chain wax
why are you doing this why are you
looking at what I'm saying and and fact
checking my ass you keep saying some
that doesn't exist and you got Thing One
and Thing Two corroborating your story
like it does and you why are you lying
that it's supposed
[Music]
why do you care so much
[Music]
whether I made up
[ __ ] on the chain wax or not
I lost my job
[Music]
my girl left me
and all I all I wanted to do
was have a little bit of fun
[Music]
with my friends today
so why do you have why do you have to
belittle me like that
[Music]
it's just that I yeah
I'm just trying to say what are you
trying to say
I'm trying to say
that I want to put the [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is not just another streaming app
what this is so much comedy it's not
even funny are you choking me bro this
is daily late and lately this is real
roasted and raw give it to me now this
is great stand up great movies and the
great cornholio are you threatening me
no this is one pump two pumps and three
pumps this is live sports breaking news
and a mountain of Comedy entertainment
Paramount plus now streaming
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look I really have to go you really have
to stay hey no means nothing that is
what they all say you're hurting my eyes
oh I'm really scared I said this is not
what I want why you have to be such a
I'm no self-defense I dare you to try it
I don't wanna fight [ __ ] you are mine
tonight
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
check that get out
what
is that I didn't know they made them
like that
I don't even understand what I'm seeing
I would love to see what's under there I
am really curious about that oh yeah dog
yeah I mean I have no idea well you know
we uh we obviously have some idea you
know
I don't
well you know it's uh you know it's a
coochie baby
yeah or something
no no no no man it's it's definitely her
lady parts
or maybe it's just more skin
nope it's a vagina yeah
yeah
or
maybe it's a little face under there
uh no no it's it's definitely gonna be a
vagina why but because she's a girl and
girls have vaginas man
what is that
what is a vagina it's a woman's
reproductive organ what are you being
serious right now
thank you that is all I require
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and Now ladies and gentlemen the man
you've been waiting for Mr Michael
Winslow don't get him Winslow
Bring the Noise
another sold out night for the kings of
mouth noise I gotta tell you though we
wouldn't have this audience without
Winslow lucky for you huh
Police Academy fans look at all the
t-shirts six sequels can you believe it
every sound effect this guy makes is
like a little tiny Mona Lisa popping out
of his mouth have you ever heard him do
leaves in the fall
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
yes
I'm here
promise you'll never forget about me
promise me you'll take care of our
little girl
love her
because
foreign
promise me you'll stay strong for her
I promise
and promise me you'll never sleep with
another woman
I hear you
promise me you'll take care of Mr big
fluffy tail yes
yes yes yes that cat will be the most
loved cat in the world
and that you won't look at porn
huh
is that yes
no pornography Buster Brown says what
is that a yes
yo better believe our heart washing his
hand girl
you love me right yes I love you yes and
we're soul mates right yes
so you will never ever ever think of
someone else while masturbating right
message received I don't understand is
that a yes
is that a promise your request has been
filed say you promise
forget about
huh
I need to hear you say it I say I Pro I
promise you promise you
you
promise
say it
no air quotes
say it
I promise I promise
what are you promising I promise what
you said oh fine forget it
I just promise to go see my mom every
day
so zero pornography done
I like that
nurse
[Laughter]
it's not all about you okay but do I
look in the camera no oh I do all right
back on television all right
[Music]
now knock it off on a stupid ass grab
ass and touch it feel it Bulls God damn
I told you they was rotten
I am uh eponymous Jackson uh principal
here at clortho
Vince cloth oh hi uh this station is
just a formality there's a bunch of
stuff that we confiscated just this week
you don't have to show them that here's
a wand with a silencer on it why but I
ask again why one other five girls in
this school is pregnant with a demon
baby
the babies are evil but the mothers
they're good kids as we said chlorthos
there's never a portal that cannot be
opened with Ingenuity and respect
now
how you're going to be using an
invisible cloak when I can see you
tagging the damn wall dime bag of pixie
dust Contraband let's see here's the
thing the kids know that the only way to
fly wizard pepper unbelievable
get your ass out of my office I will
turn you into a spider
they're good kid Hogwarts and clothes
and Hogwarts go hand in hand the best
top two Wizarding schools there are
but you know uh out of these two schools
we each have a strike we do score a
little bit lower on our standardized
tests than Hogwarts but there is a
cultural bias we may not have a huge
endowment like they get over at Hogwarts
and yes some of the teachers have to buy
their own Newt size or bat wings one kid
got transformed into a cat they can't
even afford a changing back this young
man's name is Jamar normally you're not
allowed to touch the students like this
when they're in human form
but uh when they're capped we just have
at it
spots everybody loves sports it's not
everybody the hallways are a Bluster
with the conversation of our criticism
half the team is Mack here riding mops
we got two little [ __ ] on Swiffer
Leicester
when all is said and done uh the average
chlortho student uh said this mother
sometimes the kids think it's cute to
turn themselves into a rat sneak into my
office play a little joke on me who is
that Tyrone is that is that no that's an
actual rat show me out son
now you're gonna end up with a bullet in
your head for it
you can't play me [ __ ]
I'm the [ __ ] that plays
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
God
all right everybody let's get reset we
are going again
Nigel that's great oh great it's
smashing thank you so much yeah Tom well
it's been an absolute honor and and what
a great opportunity to be here and be
able to play an American tough wow I'm
just so glad that we got you out of that
BBC commitment so you can play with us
Cheers Cheers Antoine listen I'm just
not buying that you're someone that was
born and raised in the streets of
Brooklyn
that's weird because I actually was born
and raised on the streets of Brooklyn
I wasn't a gang and everything most of
this stuff actually happened to me wow
okay well that's that's great for us
because I want you to use it okay it's
good first take let's just uh let's get
going let's go let's get going thank you
chief
scene five take two
and action you sold me out son
now you're gonna end up with a bullet in
your head for me
you can't play me [ __ ]
I'm the [ __ ] that plays
motherfucker's mother [ __ ]
[Music]
cut cut
okay uh Nigel that was great oh
brilliant just the way you move
especially when you talk I just really
see this character coming to life before
my eyes cheers it's fabulous Antoine
your performance
um
it's just not quite there yet okay I
really need to see you make more of a
transformation okay like like Nigel here
that was British yeah Anton if I might
jump in with a bit of advice I don't
think I need that no no no no look
caramel
maybe you might want to try thinking of
something in the material that's similar
to something that's happened in your
real life
for me for instance I like to think of
when my mom wanted me to attend Prep
School in Leeds to become a barrister
but I wanted to study the theater at
Oxford oh God and so that was a
conundrum really for me I'm gonna stop
you right right there because it's just
confusing me right like I don't need
that because I am from the streets
I was in a gang
they told me to kill my cousin
they'd be a [ __ ] spots home no yeah
that's a good spot on do you have any
stories that involve your mom
what's a mum
yeah scene five take three
okay Antoine remember you're a gangster
okay betrayal the streets
okay Nigel your perfect Antoine
transform and action
sold me out son
now you're gonna get a blood up in your
head for it
you can't play me [ __ ]
I'm the [ __ ] that plays
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's boring
to watch
cut
oh that does not sound good
I do not feel like you have found the
emotional core of this character [ __ ]
this nobody is more real than me okay I
come from the streets and nobody's gonna
tell me what the streets is like nobody
you understand
that's a great speech I just wish that I
believed it you want to give it a shot
so I'll have a go man [ __ ] this I'm as
real as a guest yes this [ __ ] is freezes
for real imma be in there man you are
I'm [ __ ] from the from the [ __ ]
from the Earth from these streets
something to that defense no but I'm so
with you I'm with you when you say that
even when you're saying the wrong words
I just wish you could do that
[Music]
oh goodness
okay that hurts but I don't feel that it
comes from the right emotional place for
the character all right here give it a
shot give me watch watch
oh that's that's great I feel that in
here and in here in my heart try that
again
I just I don't
I don't believe you
so you've got to keep the toppings full
okay got it I'm on top of that you're
gonna fit in just fine here hey someday
that might be your picture on the wall
oh employee of the year when does she
work what
I was just wondering when she worked
girl it's me
oh
congrats now here's the best part about
working at a yoga shop is you get all
the free photos you want mm-hmm you
can't believe how delicious it is and
also fat free thank God because my
boyfriend he just got back from his tour
in Afghanistan and he's coming here to
pick me up he should be here in a minute
I haven't seen him in a year
a whole year you say
have some
I'm good
now if you need an extra shirt or
anything they're going to be in there
because these seem to shrink uh-huh okay
you know what girl I can't get enough of
this stuff I mean you should have some
it's free no I'm okay I'm I'll have some
later come on
hungry
hi hey just got back from Afghanistan
I'm here looking for my girlfriend latia
yeah
baby what what is me no it's not what
it's me
apparently she doesn't work anymore
thanks
what
oh my God
this is
disorder
hey they got the PTSD
my baby got
the team
wolf babies
[Music]
[Music]
it is so good to see you Keith yeah we
usually have to wait for a special
occasion well actually I have a little
surprise I got engaged oh
[Laughter]
son
[Music]
wow
congratulations little bro
engaged kind of a big deal more for me I
guess that's what that means
yes well um
she got a name Stephanie marriage is a
wonderful Journey 50 on the divorce
sorry bro them's just the facts
I will I will keep that in mind thank
you
you got a photo oh yeah AKA does she
exist there you go
oh she's beautiful don't let me get eyes
on this
everybody else already have
great lighting
airbrushed I know she kind of looks like
that one model uh on The Price is Right
uh yes
uh that's her the price Price is Right
Clive that's your show shut up mom no
it's not
oh yeah
Stephanie
people always under bid on their
showcases not the best presenter
where's the wedding oh
oh in Hawaii
awesome
she ever been married before uh no so
she says
ex-boyfriend she got one of course
sloppy seconds at least right Dad
Keith she sounds wonderful shut up shut
up
from you
okay you're cut off
from talking
you know what Clive
I really don't appreciate the way that
you're talking to Mom
yes yes
The Prodigal Son hath returned you know
what you want to go let's go cause I've
been here for the last 15 years taking
care of Mom and Dad well you've been
trollopsing all over the world and why
so you can come back here and criticize
me for how I treat them no
I actually came here
to ask you if you would do me the honor
of being my best man
I know that we have a
had our differences
but you're my older brother
we'll pay for your room
and we're also going to rent you a car
and and we'll pay to fly you out there
[Music]
first class
well we can't afford first class
oh you're dead to me
well that uh that went better than
expected
let's get this party started
ladies and gentlemen this is Paramount
Plus
Strokes of Genius beautiful games and
One Shining Moments this Defenders
investigators and seven strangers picked
to live in a house this is Young
SpongeBob young Sheldon and the younger
this is everything you've been looking
for that's gonna leave a mark live
sports breaking news and a mountain of
entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now streaming
[Music]
nobody likes you you girl well you're a
different color than me and that's bad
oh yeah well you dress like a now hold
on a second
whoa Mr T never make fun of a way a man
dresses way man dresses is his business
remember that whether it's overalls
chains or feather earrings however they
dress is not to be joked about I'll pity
the fool that judges another man's
clothing
I'm sorry I judge your clothing it's
okay
[Music]
hey Scout there's a man over there who
said he'll give us candy if we get in
his van I don't know if that's a good
idea Timmy
what are you afraid of is it because you
have a stupid name like Scout hey
whoa Mr T again never make fun of a
person's name your mama gave you that
name or you made it up for business
purposes on the way it's personal
I'll pity the fool to make fun of
another man's name Mr T's a cool name
it's a cool name Mr T
[Music]
hey Scout wanna do some drugs aren't
drugs bad
I don't know
if you're afraid of drugs we could drink
a bunch of alcohol
yum that sounds good
well guess what your hair is stupid
never make fun of another person's hair
hey Mr T a person's hair is the artwork
that they present to the heavens
it's just like I've been saying
[Music]
[Music]
and for your information it's not even a
haircut it's a rare form of male pattern
baldness
your fools
[Music]
teaching Center is brought to you by BMW
the ultimate driving machine
[Music]
foreign welcome to teaching Center I'm
Boyd Maxwell with today's top stories
from the exciting world of teaching and
I'm Perry Schmidt
well now we know the long-awaited
announcement by star English teacher
Ruby roof has sent teaching fans Across
the Nation into a friendship I've
enjoyed my time in Ohio very much but
I'm pleased to announce that I'm taking
my talents back to New York City
thank you very much apparently ps431 has
made Ruby an offer she couldn't refuse
80 million guaranteed over six years
with another 40 million in incentives
based on test scores his salary puts it
right up there with Rockridge
Elementary's Katie hope and William Wu
out of Colgate foreign
let's take a look at yesterday's high
school teacher draft from Radio City
Music Hall where central Rapids High
recipient of the worst test scores last
semester made the first pick that was no
surprise to anyone
with the first pick Central Rapids High
takes
calculus teacher Mike Yost from Tulsa
Teachers College
and just like that you're a millionaire
Mike Yost is an unbelievable story his
father living from paycheck to paycheck
is a humble pro football player kid was
a natural mathlete you know he's gonna
buy his mama house oh you know this oh
there's no way around no you owe your
mom
today's highlight of the day is brought
to you by the 100 Black Angus beef thick
Burger on a fresh baked bun from Carl's
Jr and Hardee's
now it's time for the highlight of the
day
star history teacher Ashley Ferguson has
been one of them test scores over at
Vince Clark oh hi okay
Confederate forces fired first
can anyone tell me where this battle
took place now look at this she looks
left then right looks past the students
with their arms up in the air spots Max
near the back sees that even though his
hand isn't up he's engaged Max it was uh
Fort Sumter
that's right oh come on see what she did
there she's bringing an introvert into
the discussion y'all that's a teacher of
the year play right there that's right
Boyd you know The Confidence Game by Max
by answering that question correctly
will enhance his performance throughout
the rest of the year No Doubt coming up
after the break Mayfield prep trades
French teacher Janine low to Skyline
High for a head librarian and two Lunch
Ladies to be named later and we'll get
the inside scoop on the impending
teachers strike that code crippled the
season next up on teaching set
strength courses through me
I am velocity
I am power
[Music]
I am a leader
a Believer
I am the force that guides
I am the gateway to what is possible the
path to the future
I am the future
the all-new 2015 six series is here meet
the new teacher's pet
okay all right good morning Tom
Jason
how you doing there Dave Crystal Tommy
good morning Jake how are ya
pretty good Kenny yeah yeah I you know
so early in the morning I'm sorry to be
very bad news but uh you know how I was
supposed to work late tonight well I
gotta run this errand for Mr mahina and
he says that you're gonna have to cover
for me so there it is I don't need I'm
sorry drop the ax
hmm
again yeah
oh you know what just remembered Mr
mahina also almost slipped my mind wants
us to change parking spaces what yeah me
personally I enjoy the nine minute walk
but uh he said that we have to do it
believe it I hate it as much as you do
what are you gonna do nothing you can do
Mr mahina said it mahina this whole
situation has been meaning it just seems
a little confusing to me as to why Mr
mahina would give a [ __ ] where we park
how's that I mean why would he care
where we are I I don't know the answer
to that question I mean that's it's just
what he said hey the mahina works in
mysterious ways you know what I'm gonna
ask him myself because no that's okay
I'll do it
I'm Mr magina sir I know you're busy but
can I speak to you about the parking
switch what is there so talk about Kenny
I told you and Jake to switch parking
spaces don't even know who I am I am Mr
mojito and I'm a real real person in
here no you go to my office
wow I'm sure that it was crazy in there
I mean that was
tense yeah
you know what's really crazy though you
know I've been working here for about a
year and I've never even seen Mr mahina
well see now that's that's an easy one
to answer that's because he comes in
before you come into work and he's still
working when you leave that's what makes
it Mr mahina you know come on we're
talking about Mr Vegeta here right it
makes perfect sense you know I bet the
hard-working boss would love to meet a
hard-working employee you know shares
the same values so I'm gonna go ahead
and just introduce myself no no uh you
can't go into Mr beanie's room are you
crazy no one except me is allowed to go
in there Mr mahina is busy
okay fine you made your point clear man
thank you very much
come on man
what
question
question
I'll have that end of the year report to
you by 10.
saving Earth from space
[Music]
yellow Falcon what do your senses tell
you stroke 2 is a killing machine
his armor is impervious to our blusters
you got any ideas red Falcon sure do
yellow Falcon Blue Falcon you remember
our battle at Dango Bluff I'll take the
legs you take the blasters it was Beaver
Creek and I took the legs make sure you
show up that flank Black Falcon
um
are you talking to me because
I'm the green falcon no time for that
black falcon purple Falcon fire missiles
Roger that farming the food now
uh battle formations we're going in hey
Roger hold up copy that crunchy my
Falcon is green hey hey hey we can talk
about our Falcon colors when we get back
to base Black Falcon right now we got a
mission to do fall into Falcon formation
well here's the issue is that you're
gonna give me an order I'm not gonna
know you're talking to me
I'm not in the Black Falcon come on
chill it out black falcon yeah Black
Falcon relax first of all I don't like
the way you guys are saying Black second
of all there is no Black Falcon I'm
green falcon black falcon homie no one's
trying to get up in your grill here
don't talk to me like that no don't say
Grill like that I'm the green falcon
oh stopping some Black Falcon about it
what the [ __ ] do you mean by that
I understand what you're going through
do you no I don't think you do how would
you feel if I called you red Falcon huh
whoa and purple Falcon how would you
feel if I called you yellow Falcon huh
that's a racist that was racist yeah
that's racist oh that is racist that's
racist
oh see okay no forget it Black Falcon
out green falcon green falcon damn it
hey why'd that green falcon fall out of
Falcon formation Black Falcon get on
that and report back
falcon
blacktalk can come in
okay Carter
I can stay here all night
so why don't you and I cut the crap and
you tell me what happened on March 15th
and what's in it for Carter Finley
what's in it for you is I don't send you
back to jail
the guy's name is cat branchman I met
him downtown at a club called the clutch
and kitten you may have heard of it it's
down on the corner of hang and Fur
Street cat branchman
so what's a guy like you and a guy named
cat
okay I know what you're doing Finley
you're just using what you see in my
poster I'm not detective I'm telling the
truth we'll see how much truth you tell
after a few weeks in solitary fine
detective you've twisted my arm that's
better
the guy's name wasn't cat branchman
it was a Chinese guy named Mr meow
he's the real gang boss
story went he hung guys from trees and
took pictures of them Finley used to run
a club downtown a front of course called
it the Paw and poster Finley ran it with
a guy named Hong in Dar okay
let's try this one more time
[Music]
Finley
who do you work for
coffee Mr Coffee
coop
coffee Coop his name was baldy tall man
coffee Coop now you're just talking
about me Finley I'm gonna give you one
more chance
who is in charge his name was angry man
the warehouse is located in the diploma
for being a detective I want a name
Justin thank you
don't say hang God damn it do not say
hang
nope hangman Justin cap Finley
's poster do not say poster or cat
or cat cat poster okay that's it I'm
losing my patience Winslow get this
[ __ ] out of here
all right
[Music]
I'm losing my patience
let's try this one more time
getting too old for it
well played Detective
well played indeed
hey Carter
you hang in there
[Music]
hey player how you doing man hey can I
make a request sure man what are you
looking for hey man
hook a brother up with someone oh cool
oh yeah oh my word okay what you looking
for a Biggie Tupac Biggie Tupac come on
man that's too new I'm talking about
that old school man you know what I'm
talking about oh I thought I did
remember like a Wu-Tang Clan
Wu-Tang Clan come on man those fools
just came out hook a brother up with
some of that old school oh okay wait uh
I don't know what you looking for a man
with NWA and
wa come on man what do I look like a kid
out there talking about the NWA foe
shizzle my [ __ ] crisscross applesauce
who's the boss Tony Danza at a loss I
don't know it all right I'm talking
about that old school okay you know what
that's my bad old man all right we gonna
take it back all right I'm gonna bust
out some Run DMC for you right now run
DMV
foreign
come on man I don't know about none of
this run DM Theo wouldn't want to be a
onomatopoeia grab a donkey by the toe
give him gonorrhea I don't know it all
right all I know is some old school if
you can't give it to me you can't give
it to me come on man Run DMC is old
school
can you name a group you the DJ man I
ain't trying to tell you how to do your
job Grandmaster Flash
man Grand Master flap you look you
sounded like a kid yourself talking
about Grand Master Flash to the um
don't stop the booger to the bang bang
boogie the up Chuck why people talking
about upchar Sugar Hill Gang brother how
we end up in Candy Land what man
if you want some old school then you
come back here and find it yourself I'm
going on break
get myself back here right here see
what's going on back here
back here no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
now we talking
all right
[Applause]
yeah
what the [ __ ] is happening
let's get this party started
ladies and gentlemen this is Paramount
Plus
Strokes of Genius beautiful games and
One Shining Moments this is Defenders
investigators and seven strangers this
is Young SpongeBob young Sheldon and the
younger this is
let's leave a mark live
Paramount plus now streaming
what up to my left we got the champion
yo introduced son yeah what's happening
this your boy Rhino D and I'm about to
front hand
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you don't even know man Hey listen man
you can't even win this 100 yard dash
but let me ask you a question what do
they call that a mustache
[Applause]
can you take it down a little bit man
what are you a horse
that's one
yo what's up dog you know my son is Rich
I'm swimming in simoleons I mean what am
I supposed to do with this miniature
black Napoleon
[Applause]
Timberlands
[Music]
[Music]
why are you doing me why would you no
listen
[Applause]
you're all done
that's right man yo we got a champion
still we got a champion
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right listen listen man yeah I want
you to look out on the on the lake man I
just want you to look out and imagine a
place man where you can do your thing
man when you and I can go and do our
thing but never have to Forfeit yeah you
can scream and shout and shove people
back and forth but we don't never have
to quit Okay but look out on the lake
man look out on the lake no matter what
happens man I start rapping I'm a rhyme
States off the floor and I'm turning the
time and no matter what you do you can
push and shove and scream but we'll
never get disqualified
man for good measure while you're
looking at the lake just give me one
more good
ah
[Music]
could be worse not that bad for me it's
all about perspective it's what you make
of it can I tell you something All
Things Considered
actually kind of comfortable right now
thank God for shock I can be the kind of
prisoner I want to be still alive thank
you right just two injured buddies yes
no having a friendly convo while we're
waiting to get tortured again and you
know there's a kind of a positive in
having no options yeah because you know
we're not even going to try to escape
because we know we'd fail yes I'll tell
you another thing don't miss the arm
really first of all Lefty okay so this
thing pretty much got in the way keep it
buddy
you fools slathering away
your suffering has only just begun wow
that is a perfect summation of The Human
Condition once you've embraced that you
can do anything Bingo
no one I've done nothing as you win
you love your work and that kind of a
positive attitude quite frankly is
contagious it is
we'll see how positive you're feeling
after I cover your body and gasoline and
set you on fire
you know what it's amazing that you
would say that because I was just
thinking it's getting a little chilly in
here thanks so much man
get it oh
what a dramatic and fascinating man I
think we owe him big time as do I really
I mean all this time away from my
computer my phone my work it's just I
feel unplugged yes yes oh
circle of life
you know I can't really feel anything
anyway so you help yourself buddy
oh what do you got there did you see
this this is what I'm gonna use to cut
off your legs
finally that's a great saw I'm a home
improvement guy and I know my sauce and
I gotta tell you if you're cutting off
legs that is the way to go that's the
one that is definitely the one good on
you why are you doing this to me
you're making me crazy whoa whoa whoa
whoa somebody needs a day off we of all
people should know how hard he works
[Music]
good stuff this is torture
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
wait wait
oh wait I'm sorry sorry buddy I can't
believe it thank you so much for coming
I haven't seen you in years
oh
yeah
yeah ah
yeah hey
Steward man oh I haven't seen you since
eighth grade eighth grade Miss Lacy's
class yes
oh you brought me flowers
that's awesome
that's awesome I bought these in a store
for you you have to bring me flowers man
there you go
crazy the way I went out like that huh
yeah what was that I was like when I
heard I was like yeah
thoughts Boulder right I mean it's like
who gets killed by a boulder these days
well I mean I mean not me I mean you
remember I was in Boulder Colorado I was
hiking and then I fell off that mountain
remember
you remember right Boulder Colorado yeah
I was hiking and then I no I dehydrated
they couldn't find me no I was I was
saying like
if you think about it Boulder killed you
well not really Boulder I mean I
wouldn't say the city per se was that it
was the cougar that got me and then
that's what everyone was talking about I
mean I got I was out there for like
three weeks yeah geez but that's neither
here nor there so hey did you get that
LinkedIn invitation I sent you before I
died ah you know um I I mean I don't
when I see LinkedIn I just delete it
without even checking no no it's totally
totally totally yeah I get it I get it
so Hey so uh what what did you want to
say to me
um what do you mean you know that's like
why people come to graveyards right so
you can say the stuff that you wish you
had said when someone was alive right oh
my God there's so much stuff oh okay
where do I start
um take your time man you can lay a
couple on me today and then come back
yeah I mean uh oh yeah I can get it done
here because that's the whole reason I
came down here and you know yeah yeah
that's my grandfather's like two rows
down there
um I was gonna come to you say some
things to you
go to him and
sort of finish up
oh
but but you were coming to see me too
totally totally totally well by the way
man you're the only good friend I have
who's come to visit yeah
really yeah uh-huh
I just wanted to uh say that oh if you
see my grandfather
maybe you could just tell them that like
I said you didn't come here to visit me
you came here to see your grandfather I
get it
what do you mean what are you talking
about
looks
please I'm here to see you why right
okay that's it's cool you know I I'm
just gonna you know go back to the
afterlife I'm sorry I'm being hostile
it's just I'm a little embarrassed right
now and I'm taking it off guard I'm just
gonna
now go ahead take them get him no go
ahead get them get them
[Music]
oh uh just a heads up though Lee um I'm
I'm probably gonna haunt you for the
rest of your life and if you have a
daughter I'm gonna possess the creepiest
doll in her bedroom no just so you know
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
it's mostly about the dancers
[Music]
besides
I'm kind of the guy that says noise
what happened nothing happened I just
voiced you because of you standing up
yourself and your place in this damn
Circle no no no noise okay noise is my
thing
no more noise from you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
noise
noise
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
excuse me big man big man big man excuse
me big man no but big man okay God bless
you I catch you on the upflip thank you
big man thank you big man hey brother
hey can I ask you a question real quick
though by the mail see that's good cause
I was about to ask you a question okay
so here's the deal man crazy thing my
car went out again out of gas about a
mile up the road that's the way I just
want to get a little bit of money you
know just get a couple of gallons okay
that's crazy because you know what this
my car had also broke down right up the
road yeah I got my daughter here she's
fine she's sleeping in the car I gotta
get back to her real quick so if you
could help me out so I was gonna ask you
if you could help me let me just give
you my wallet out here I'll show you my
ID to let you know that I am straight up
the Jets real that ain't trying to
trying to do nothing to nobody okay uh
issue of legitimacy I too have an
identification that's an employee ID
from Borders bookstore right here I got
my Bally's Total Fitness ID right shows
you that I stay fit and conscientious
and whatnot you also notice of these
other IDs I have in my hand have the
same name on it which makes you know
that it is indeed me okay I got to have
multiple IDs Crescendo Wing in this
Yogurtland punch card okay yeah I see
that right there that is my ninth
purchase apparently and you can't wait
for that yeah all right so normally I
would not ask another person for an
assistance but uh our family is in a
fiduciary crisis right now my wife is
languishing in the hospital she had
construct action worker and what
happened is she got struck in the face
by a power line fried her whole head up
burnt both her eyeballs out she's
getting an eyeball replacement surgery
as we speak I also have a spousal injury
crisis on my midst as well my wife was
in the astronaut program making her a
full-fledged astronaut okay and she had
gotten Moon dust in her lungs inhaled
that's never good it's never good
let's find an ATM
oh look there's one over there guys
what's the chances of it we should
probably check that out yeah let's just
take a look right there here we are well
here we are ATM machines that I did not
know previously were here all right two
of them no less I'll tell you what we
should do though man you give me the 20
okay I'll give you the three that's on
my person then I will give you the 17
after then you give me that 17. I'll cut
you a check for a hundred just to cover
that you give me the change in cash okay
okay I feel that why am I playing I'm
just going to give you my ATM card so
you know I'm Legit
I'm gonna give you my ATM cards we both
have something of value from the other
person all right
and your code is it is one two three
four and yours sir one two three five
thank you
okay that that is a Ralph's Rewards Card
okay that is a credit card placeholder
you would find in a translucent sleeve
and a brand new wallet
youngster yeah I'm uh headed to the Kobo
building on Jefferson all right yeah
Cobo Hall Jefferson Avenue
so uh what you in Detroit for I gotta do
a presentation all right okay yeah
presentation okay
what do you present
uh actually it's about how market
research can be interpreted with out of
the box Solutions oh all right so you
won't get this all outside the box all
right
most people think that all customers are
a single demographic oh okay you trying
to get all them demographics up in here
all right all right yeah
online Trends are less linear oh okay
online trans Linea
[Music]
um
also thinking about doing the
presentation naked there's no no clothes
on oh yeah yeah naked presentation no
clothes on that's good
afterward I might just piss on the floor
in front of everyone oh yeah okay all
right piss him right there up in front
of everybody
all right sounds good then I might just
shoot everybody in the place you know
with the gun I'm hiding in my ass yeah
yeah gone way up in that ass that's the
way to do it I'll cut my victims faces
off wear them as masks yeah masks go on
the face yeah okay
YouTube
all right here we are
oh and by the way when you kill those
people with your ass gun make sure to
use a serrated blade to cut the faces
off
our feet is a
very good
this place is so nice
I'm supposed to be one of the best uh
French places in town
I did not realize that you were so
cultured
sweet
my French is pretty good so I can order
for both of us wow
I am your wife my name is
too if you have any questions about
anything at all I'm more than happy to
assist you
[Music]
I got it
merci beaucoup
well our first special two nights is
served with a Premiere verdecution
that is served on a bed
and also illuminate Rouge and souffle
petite fiato DuPont greniere
foreign
soup yeah our other Seafood today we
have a very nice
from the good solution Valley and
visitor it is served with the side of
Colombo Fontane
do God sauce
I'm so glad you said that I was about to
say the same thing you would recommend
getting
with the um
oh what do you think I'm I'm gonna defer
to him on this one because he knows his
stuff way better than I do miss you
um yeah we're uh we'll have the
song
um
we'll try the food
it's been nice knowing you have a lovely
dinner
not just another streaming app this is
so much comedy it's not even funny are
you choking me bro this is daily late
and lately this is real roasted and raw
give it to me now this is great stand up
great movies and the great cornholio are
you threatening me no this is one pump
two pumps and three pumps this is live
sports breaking news and a mountain of
Comedy entertainment Paramount plus now
streaming
foreign
gotta be careful here
this place is crawling with them
what was that
what cover me
guys hey guys
hey guys oh thank God
and we started a community of survivors
y'all come live with us
[Music]
wait how did you know
redneck wants us to move into his
community
us let's go
guys over here
thank God there are others
would you let me date your daughter of
course
please don't hurt me uh my best friend's
black and I love Jay-Z and uh my
favorite movie is Think Like a Man
she's good come with us stay close okay
what's your name Emily of course it is
foreign
what do you think about the police
well I love the third album
I I I don't have any money I'm no money
oh my God oh my God thank God you guys
showed up I gotta get out of here
silver Lexus
pull it right up front and don't scuff
the paint all right I just had it buffed
was hand alien too yep
good morning
uh Clive Double Down ruggins I'm Daniel
Tate I am your parole officer
and I just want to help you how the hell
are you supposed to help me man what the
[ __ ] you know about the streets what
would your diplomas on the wall
settle down
I know that
you might not be able to relate to me
but
I think
I know somebody who you can relate to
little homie what
it's my favorite Club what up dude no
dog listen hey man I ain't trying to
talk to no Puppet Man
not a puppet it's a little homey and I
would like for you to talk to him Clive
see I used to work in the juvenile
correction systems and I found this
method very effective I ain't no
juvenile man okay he's right because he
look like a kid to you come on he's a
grown ass man see what look it's very
important for your parole
that you talked a little homie
what's up little homie
that's better my [ __ ] Grumps what you
getting into these days man what it is
what it is you got a job yet
I'm trying man but no one will hire me
yeah hey
[ __ ] all that noise man
between you and me man ain't nobody
trying to hide with a record but hey man
what you need to be doing is get back
into some crimes man
what's going on man are you talking to
me
yeah well you should be talking to
little homie right yeah [ __ ]
to me look at me when I'm talking to you
okay okay fine
damn
so you smoking weed
no man no no little homie uh I'm I'm
done with drugs
I got something
look at this Grumps
smoke this week no no no no no no man
I'm done man you hear me I'm done with
drugs I ain't doing all that
I don't know
homie seems pretty serious about that
here
look I'm confused man what do you want
me to do here well I want you to clean
up your act but you're not talking to me
right now you're talking to little homie
no smoked it or I smoke this [ __ ] right
here
oh yeah
foreign
wait wait no no no no no no no no no you
can't fool me
are you trying to trick me man
no no I'm done with the weed
get
dumbass now your fingerprints is on the
weapon you in this with me now right
okay little homie yeah
well oh
you failed the test
I have no choice but to revoke your
parole
what
what oh man
on your feet baby boy get him out of
here come on
I can't believe that negrams actually
thought I killed you
[Music]
oh wait
Miss Clarissa I'm gonna tell your girl
in that dress you looking about as sweet
as a field full of honeysuckle after a
spring rain shower
how do you do it girl
badass though
what was that what was what what you
just said to her oh well I was just
following yo Lee no you wasn't he was
being all heavy-handed with it man you
got to be subtle
subtle exactly you gotta be subtle you
want to talk to them later I can do that
Mr Nice
girl the way that dress is Flowing you
look like a mountain creek after the
spring thaw simply refreshing what is
Young
secret way that dress fitting on you got
them titties popping out
what amazing what here yo
secret what are you doing what are you
doing
I was just doing what you was doing no
you wouldn't I even said what if your
secret that's with verbatim that part
was did you hear me say anything about
anybody's titties
no you know what how about we just say
no words all together no words all
together question yeah how will I talk
you're not gonna talk okay all right
oh wait
ladies I'm sorry y'all hurt my eyes
y'all just like smoldering like the sun
and just as bright in them beautiful
dressing vagina
[Music]
what the hell was that oh I did say a
word at the end there didn't I did you
see the point oh this was going on and
shaking your tail feathers and whatnot I
didn't see it I got the worst view in
the house
that's what chase them away man all
right you know what stay away from me
all right
oh hey
Miss Laverne
you like a long-stemmed Rose the way you
looking and smelling
what is your recipe
damn boy I bet you got a big old dick
and ball
I love you
[Music]
this is all about Susie Diaz Susie
Diaz's party Susie Diaz is running the
show I'm just going to show up if she
needs me to bring beer or something I'm
more than happy to
oh dude oh my god a woman just fainted
I'm gonna have to call you back
ma'am man oh
um
[Music]
Metropolitan and I just came across this
woman and she just she just passed out
on the sidewalk here okay and then she
responds this sir
um
[Music]
okay sir is she responsive
sir
sir
um no sir if you can hear me he's not
responsible it's just
beautiful
[Music]
that is not relevant to this emergency
sir an ambulance is on its way in the
meantime I need you to check her pulse
up to check her pulse right check her
pulse okay
does she have a pulsar or she does but
skin is so soft so she isn't having a
ton of makeup but she's the kind of girl
that just doesn't need it so you can see
that she put a lot of thought into her
outfit but that was just trying too hard
perfect
for me I remind you that you have not
spoken a word to this woman I need you
to see if she's breathing yeah okay hold
on
[Music]
sir I need you to stay on track
do you know how to give mouth to mouth
resuscitation yes I do okay I need you
to administer that now okay okay
[Music]
this is the only time it's okay to put
your mouth on an unconscious woman do it
I just didn't picture it happening this
way there's butterflies in my stomach
and I'm just I don't want to mess this
up it's so rare but to find her if you
can hear me an ambulance is on its way
I'm sorry I'm sorry oh gosh my head
sorry stay with me this is what it feels
like to be in love but it must be like
when you when you find the wolves
foreign
[Music]
okay ma'am listen very carefully I'm
going to need you to marry him
oh okay
should I give him like not to mouth
first
yeah girl get you some
best comic book adaptation to film hands
down no argument see you later girls all
right oh yeah
um I know I'm in the minority here but I
don't really like the Christopher Nolan
Batman movies I don't I really just feel
like they're
overrated
okay
well that's um that that's just an
opinion you see that's why I prefaced it
by saying I know I'm in the minority
or you know what no no
not really it's not awkward at least not
until you said awkward now it's awkward
because of what you said
anyway anyway what anyway what really
because when you say anyway then you
have to follow it up with an actual
contribution to the conversation we're
having
no look at me look at me look at me look
at me look at me there's no yikes and
the reason why there's no yikes is
there's nothing scary about this
situation okay it's a very low stake
situation all right no not all right
come here no don't look at him don't
look at either of those guys look at me
all right all right what because after
you say all right you have to follow
that up with something
don't do it
don't look at them
do not look at them
no no do not look at them do not look at
them don't tell us how you really feel
you know what I'll tell you how I really
feel listen I really feel like you're an
[ __ ] who has nothing interesting to
say so what ow no don't no no don't look
it up come here turn it right here tell
me an opinion that you have about
something just one opinion that you have
about anything at all just share an
opinion anything share an opinion share
an opinion share an opinion share an
opinion right now just on the top of
your head share an opinion anything just
one opinion that's all I'm asking share
one opinion right now
I don't have an opinion and that's why I
just like everything that everyone else
likes in pop culture oh
hahaha
[Music]
don't look at me
[Music]
don't look at me
don't look at this
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
rather than sisters
okay
tonight
the newest member of our family will
Feast for the first time
Ophelia
bring the new blood
ah
rubber Tyrell
welcome
first night of your new and what are we
wearing here
I'm just wearing what I got bit in
mm-hmm
okay do you have anything black
or like pants with laces up the side of
the leg
just so you can still see the skin
oh no that's not my style so I ain't got
none of that in my closet or nothing
like that
okay
anyway we will tonight
oh feast
hahaha
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come on man
excuse me
I'm just saying y'all were here looking
and hissing and whatnot if we gonna eat
then let's eat damn
yes of course we will all feed
[Music]
spread the meat
[Music]
the enemy that actually get in your
mouth because I mean now Sue no wonder
y'all is hungry all the time
[Applause]
no no no no see look why y'all got a
hiss when you're flashing your fangs you
know you can make your teeth come out
without doing all that nonsense see
and can you two get a room
it's a damn mention they got
that guy could do that [ __ ] I mean are
you two even lesbians
I just don't understand why everything
got to be all sexual and licky girl
seriously man you got to get your hands
up off before I [ __ ] you up [ __ ] is
nasty creepy as [ __ ] and touching my
nipple for 15 minutes did all this [ __ ]
y'all is doing up here this is just like
straight up gratuitous I got bit on
purpose so I could live forever and see
future cars
against Cyrus these pants are
uncomfortable and I actually have a
boyfriend and this song has been playing
for like two years and
it
seems
desperate okay desperate really Tristan
it's Christian
really his name ain't even Tristan so do
you all feel this way
yeah yeah kinda yeah
wow
it's like you can't even get good
friends no you're not even okay and
you're leaving now that's I mean you
know what though seriously like you
could fix this place up it'd be dope
dope for real our car is going to be
able to fly or is everything going to be
on a magnetic track I mean that's what I
want to know that's no big deal this O
Negative tastes like pennies also but
hey come on now nipple player for
private time we talked about like 211.
it's just a dream
you guys
foreign
[Music]
she was drunk on barley wine I'd been to
Sea for months or three I knew I could
make her mine but the last was past
consent so it was off with her we went
and we threw her in bed and rested her
head and we laughed cause that's what
gentlemen do
a woman
[Music]
there once was a cow from Leeds who I
heard was good on her knees so I docked
my ship for an overnight trip to take
care of all my needs just fine with
Tales to tell and my mask we're going to
swell so I landed
up on a Lingus for an hour or so
[Applause]
attention down there we say
[Music]
I once had a woman so fair whose wound
contained my air with a Sun by my side
the Seas we'd ride the child she would
bear but my girl she was no fool she was
working her way through school so I did
support when she chose to abort because
it's her body in there for her choice
foreign
[Music]
there was a lady with a golden eye and
the doctor said she would die so she
emptied her purse to lift the curse and
prayed to stay alive she awoke the very
next day and in her grave she lay but
the scariest part of the story from the
start is I bet you assumed the doctor
was a man
I am so
doctors to move a foreign
[Music]
okay straight back oh yeah
there was a slot with tits to here and a
nice
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right how's everybody how's
everybody doing
all right and you guys can all hear me
okay yeah all right I know this guy can
right here boy this guy's ears are so
big he's laughing at jokes from the yuck
yuck Club all the way on the other side
of town
all right and you sir you're doing okay
right and you're getting enough to eat
is that even possible
thank you sir folks I'm sorry I'm gonna
get everybody tonight I'm gonna nobody
is safe I'm getting everybody except for
you sir I'm Gonna Leave You Alone just
like your date did tonight hello
all right okay who is next who is next
hey ma'am I get it you have breasts okay
geez man look at this chick over here
her cleavage is giving the Grand Canyon
an inferiority complex
[Laughter]
who's who's talking right now
[Music]
yeah hey man look at that look at that
pink shirt you got on there wow where'd
you get that queertyshirts.com
I am gay though
okay go for it I can take it hmm
oh yeah yeah no hey yeah don't you worry
about that man
gloves are coming off
right there right there what's with the
three drinks man with alcoholic much
this is my pain medication [ __ ]
course it is it's your pain medication
because uh he is in pain
right now
make fun of the what did you say because
here's the problem sir is it's really
dark in here and sorry are you burned
because I can't make it out thanks so
much ma'am for Illuminating him thank
you that's uh I appreciate that
oh
those Burns make fun of the robot voice
sir I don't know
okay well no you know what I feel like a
wheelchair look sir there is nothing
funny about you being in a wheelchair
and we can all but there is something
funny about me being fat
all right all right fine fine I've got
it I've got it I'm doing it I'm doing it
I just didn't want to go after this guy
because I didn't want him to kill me in
my dreams
like like Freddy Krueger oh
come on because no
condition how Freddy Krueger's face is
burned off
that's not
[Music]
you [ __ ]
he said he could take it that's what he
said
but I can't how is this on me how do we
even know if he's crying right now
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey I I just got a text from Charles
y'all he got on the wrong bus he's on
the other side of town other side of
town but our concert is in an hour yeah
I know but but he wants us to warm up
and rehearse praise to the Lord said
that in Texas okay okay well if that's
what Charles said yeah that's okay we
got this we can do what we can do to do
this
[Music]
five six seven eight we lived up to the
Lord we give praise up to the Lord we
sing merely up to the Lord give thanks
up to the Lord we lived up to the Lord
we sing merrily up to the Lord give
thanks
you're going higher than your notes
pretty sure this is my note in fact I'm
positive this is my note because this is
my note pretty sure this is my note
could have swore this was your Lord that
has never been my note where we can't
have the same note so one of us is wrong
why don't you worry about your note I'll
take care of my own nose but it's a
really really really bad note
you are not Charles I never said that I
was Charles well you acting like
[Music]
and it's messing with the rest of our
notes speak for yourself Naima I'm
holding my nose I wasn't trying to
single you out you said everyone was off
there no now everything is about you
Gina kiss my black ass
oh dear lord
where is songs
[Music]
[Music]
Vince I uh I have that quarterly
analysis that you asked for
I had a quarter of Deez Nuts on your
chin
right
it's just that I wanted to review some
of these numbers with you it seems like
our earnings are low against our
original projections
these nuts were low against your chin
you know Vince
if you ever need to talk to me about
something I'm more than happy to listen
nuts will be more than happy to rest
against
you hey look you've been doing this for
about a week now and it was kinda funny
at first these nuts were kind of funny
against your chin
I've been so worried about you
I was worried about these nuts on your
chin
man seriously
these nuts were seriously on your chin
Mr Graham I just got a call from St
Mary's Hospital and your parents were in
a serious car accident
I'm so sorry but your mother is dead
and your father is on life support
[Music]
these nuts are supporting life on your
chin
sorry Amber
you gotta stop it
[Music]
he's not passed away on your [ __ ] no no
he didn't
they didn't Vince
I said you gotta leave here right now
and go be with your dad this could be
the last time that you get to see him
it's gonna be the last time I get to see
my knots on your goddammit Vincent your
father might be dying
these nuts might be dying on your chin
God damn it Vince snap the [ __ ] out of
it
your mother is dead
[Music]
all right
you okay okay you're all right you're
back
it was so good
it worked in every situation I know I
know and it's always it's just so funny
well it wasn't it wasn't that funny
really wasn't that funny Vince
it was really funny
I would not go so far as to say it was
really funny Vince was funny
but it wasn't though
it was
I really disagree it's funny okay
one more time it's kind of one record of
saying it wasn't really that funny
I'll go see my dad that was funny wasn't
that funny
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Stay With Me
that I love you
and I love
these nuts on your chin
foreign
[Music]
check out Leos
I wonder what he's dreaming about he is
probably dreaming about what we is going
to do to the team from the West
I wonder
[Music]
Tavarius Smith's T King for short I'm a
bad mama jama and an awful sport Smoochy
Wallace you could call me Ty Royal
rapping up Russians like aluminum foil
the queen Goldberg I'm very scary if I
got the the ball you best be wary the
carpetron Duke Marriott I love the ball
so much I wanna marry
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
you are the best
I'm Ibrahim Zeus and my Rhymes are clean
like my name was Dr Seuss Papa cut the
third they call me the probe I can
intercept ball with my yellow shower
handle that's my name power candle
sounds the same with Jack Mary the
sweater
wax and play Saxon Demarcus plays guitar
[Music]
okay don't you know
[Music]
indeed we are the best
it must have been all a dream
or was it
[Music]
oh it's on
[Music]
what's up y'all if Jefferson I'm the big
left Knack we're gonna help us win X win
at Alicia's nurse I'll use my Force to
give the East distress
[Music]
y'all know me I'm washing beard catch so
many balls it's a little weird cause you
know we're gonna win against
[Music]
AJ
[Music]
Formerly Known
[Music]
but y'all ain't ready for my man Dan
Smith
comma Daniel other kick it's in the lead
don't hold that candle cheerleaders
goddamn baby cocker spaniel BYU y-u-b
man cause the [ __ ] wanna get with me
got Swisher Sweets and clutches
blinded been drunk when I punted been
like a hundred times that I already done
it oh see these haters thought I was
playing staying away from my faces with
all
Smith and the West is getting rowdy like
Monsters
[Music]
what if we told y'all
that once a month half the human racism
pain and
the other half
don't want to hear [ __ ] about it
Tombstone welcome to menstruation
orientation
oh no you don't now we know you don't
want to hear about it but they don't
want to have it so sit your ass down and
listen for once in your life today we're
going to talk to all you men about what
happens to your women when they're on
their periods and why it's important to
be sensitive to that [ __ ] don't say
chillax relax calm down and how come
don't say ass fat grumpy or cranky and
cranky they got blood coming out of
their vaginas that's some biblical
plague [ __ ] y'all that would be like
once a month if you had locusts flying
out of your dick for a week your ass
wouldn't be cranky your ass would be
like oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
so be nice to your [ __ ] when they
bleeding if you ain't getting them [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out their way cramps they
got headaches they got winkies and every
time they pee it's like the shining in
the toilet we support the empathetic but
whatever you do do not try to solve it
don't even bring that [ __ ] up when women
be hanging out together their periods
will sink uh vaginas be communicating
they got their own vagina language
[Music]
if you find yourself around a group of
women and they all have a backache back
away slowly what's that in your pocket
there's some boots recognize this
[ __ ] that ain't space starting
tonight here's the tear upon learn what
your [ __ ] has to go through first you
put this piece in your vagina then you
push this part into the face of the
first piece sweet then you throw this
part away do that several times a day
for a week every goddamn month it's the
worst thing ever all the time it's much
worse for them than it is for you to
hear about it and periods is important
that's how the body gets rid of the old
eggs so we can cook up them new ones so
listen to what's going on with your
female emotionally and get your [ __ ]
some chocolate don't call her a [ __ ]
but get your [ __ ]
[Applause]
come on
let's get this party started
ladies and gentlemen this is Paramount
Plus
[Applause]
fenders investigators and seven
strangers picked to live in a house this
is Young SpongeBob young Sheldon and the
younger this is everything you've been
looking for it's gonna leave a mark live
sports breaking news and a mountain of
entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now streaming
these allegations that I have sent
inappropriate pictures over the internet
are completely ridiculous they are
levied by my political Rivals who are
trying to embarrass me
and Advance their own agenda so let me
be
perfectly clear
these allegations are false and I will
be Vindicated
Philip
TMZ has obtained an actual photo of your
genitalia they're posting it to their
website as we speak they're saying you
took it how do you respond
okay I may have sent one photo of my
genitalia okay
it was a one-time thing
Senator what about the new report there
are three new pictures having been sent
to three different women
what second-rate news or this
organization is trying to New York Times
it was it was four total no more that
was it it was
yes you are sure that there were only
four photos sent that's it four that's
all there's no more than four then how
do you explain the one you sent me
please please I'm begging you
I'm begging you
to forgive me
for the the foibles and transgressions
it was The Reckless Act of a younger man
a younger man you sent it two seconds
before you stepped on stage Senator
Senator that's very innocent Amy last
time I checked time is still real okay
so technically speaking I am much older
now than I was all of those seconds ago
oh my God
what's happening right now I just got
one what's going on I don't understand
what's happening
Senator how are you even doing this you
have no proof that I'm doing anything
wait a second you can do it but I can't
do it
first things first I do not care that
you're a multi-platinum selling rapper
gun rack
what I care about is that I 100 know
that you murdered Darnell Simmons so you
better start talking
yeah but you ain't got Mom
okay you know I'm actually I'm very glad
that you said that
because I respectfully
I beg to differ
[Music]
now yeah I shot him with my knot I shot
him nine times nine pm on the dime and
by the way it was November 9th
thank you
I got a vivid imagination
I couldn't have sat down now
I was at my cousin's birthday party
Red Lobster November 9th
at Red Lobster geez I gotta tell you gun
right I find that really hard to believe
it's a lot anyone could tell this if you
know about my allergy to all shelving
just confess conrack
fish is the only thing
that
first
nouns adjectives
they just happen to be an adult order
but
man I ain't got no pearl
shut up
now I have no idea what that object is
if I had to identify it I would call it
a gun
of the long ass variety some seaweed in
there too look I'm gonna try to do I
have to break it to you I ain't killing
it
struck my chin real slow when I'm lying
and I was laughing super hard and gone
that was dying the name of the album is
I killed Darnell Simmons
that's a picture of you a picture of you
and behind you
you said that you're going away for a
long time you understand you're gonna
confess if it's the last thing you'll
ever do when you hear me come back I'll
beat your body I'll be nice
oh he's free to go what no no no no we
have everything we need no I was Simon's
girlfriend she just confessed to the
whole thing infidelity crime of passion
let's go Mr rack
[Music]
Ed on his track I got a ride or die
[ __ ] I think you get the gist and when
you let me out I'm gonna blow a little
kiss this is my confession admissible in
court I killed Darnell Simmons for sport
that's right I'm a murderer come get me
come down the hall you can get me okay
okay okay you got me you got me hey
Google
foreign
[Music]
Decker
hey Jim Jackson I'll be working with him
on this mission
he's in his exit
let's get one thing straight I don't
like orders I don't play by the rules
I trust you heard of me actually no I
haven't oh
[Music]
we don't have much time the arachnid
agents have taken over the consulate we
need to get you in and resolve this from
the inside
we've taken the latest sit rep of the
hostile's position and we've
reconstructed a holographic blueprint of
the consulate save the mouth Square for
the newer occurs General
not going to be impressed by anything
technology
it's just a 3D representation
entered these days
agent Jackson you will enter through
this AC duct on the south side of the
building yes sir Decker you will be
dropped on top and then you will gain
access through this Elevator Shaft we
want you to go down to the fourth floor
mate
Decker
you okay I heard everything he said
Elevator Shaft
it's bright yeah it's bright
the terrorists are located on the third
and fifth floor of the building each
floor has six groups of six men what
we're going to want you to do is stop in
the middle at the fourth and pry open
the elevator door and go
I just want you to move through that
elevator door and then go down
pry open
[Music]
elevator door go down to the third floor
[Music]
okay maybe this isn't going to work out
why what's the matter General
everybody's putting their hand in the
laser
it's not a laser
it's a hologram
tomato tomato look what's with all the
babies sitting and hand holding
I was a big boy
let's zoom into the interior
[Music]
let's cut to the chase why am I here
your primary target is your old rival
from the Cold War
Nikolai andrakovich now Andrew kovich
has been leading him
Jackson Jackson damn
good job Decker
Jackson was an undercover agent for
arachnid
how in the world did you know
[Music]
ah
in my day we made coffee hot
[Music]
forget this fool man he's fronting ain't
no one here scared of you you fake ass
gangster
it's your fake ass up out of here
you were scared for like a minute though
this [ __ ] eating his gun
[Music]
you look at that
foreign
oh
thought you had an idea I do
we need to make an app like for a
smartphone an app that all other people
could download and then we make millions
it's just hard to come up with man it's
like catching lightning in a bottle I
already got that you got what
lightning in a bottle really what's the
idea no no idea I got actual lightning
in a bottle no Levi that's just a phrase
I got that dog
lightning in a bottle blip that's crazy
son would you get that some old Chinese
man sold it to me years ago
I mean that's some Supernatural
man
all it does is this
I got it
but seriously man
would it be like an app that reminds you
when your favorite television shows are
on no
we gotta
which model that you got
a bottle
what bottle
the bottle with the lightning in it
you still on that yes
how does it work Cedric I don't know
it's the classic lightning in the bottle
guys
you just opened it up
okay you know what you shouldn't have
this this belongs to the military or
something
but that app though no we don't need the
app you've got the goose
how do you know about Honkers
what this [ __ ]
August get in on this app idea
you like it he likes it
yeah he got a goddamn golden egg
Honkers here is the cat's pajamas
no please don't don't I want to show you
something whatever it is I don't want to
see it it's relevant I already know what
it is it ain't what you think
well what I think it is it's a pair of
cat's pajamas
these are for Honkers to wear the what
the Little Neck in there the neck How
You Gonna fit his head
through this thing with the orange
[Music]
I'm gonna have to ask you to leave my
house
why because you disrespected my roommate
okay okay
it's clear that this is a crazy house so
I gotta go you over here talking about
geese golden eggs and Feline sleepwear
Matt Cedric you need to get off your
high horse man
I just thought of a name for you
high horse
[Music]
hello this is Gavin
Evan my name is Colin Valenti I'm
calling
Travel Incorporated tell you about an
exciting limited time off for exclusive
Las Vegas getaway I have a few minutes
your time to tell you about this new
package you know what I would love to
but I just don't have the time
hello
hello
father
this is Colin valenci Master Travel
Incorporated I'm every Service uh hi
Carmen Valenti my name is Gavin I think
we just talked did we get disconnected
yeah no I mean yeah I hung up on you
uh why would you do that
I mean are you even
are you even allowed to do that
were you going to buy the Las Vegas
package well I mean probably not but
that's not the point the point is
this is Colin yeah Valenti listen um I
don't know what crawled up your ass and
set up shop there but you don't get to
hang up
oh my God
what the [ __ ] do you want what is your
deal huh
um you don't want the biggest package so
I don't want to talk it's just a favor
wasting our time stop stop
why shouldn't I realistic what if I
wanted the Vegas package you know what I
want the Vegas package
sure you do
[Music]
oh my God you son of a [ __ ]
come on man Let It Go new man you I want
five
packages right now you know what you
know what my wallet this is my credit
card number right here okay this
my credit card number is zero zero seven
four five four zero three zero zero nine
eight decoration date is 12 20 and then
and then uh oh yeah the security number
is zero eight four so run the damn card
right now right now you run it right now
[ __ ]
thank you for your business
well I hope you learned
these new call scripts are really great
yeah I know right
do you want Kathy
[Music]
happy Sunday Esther happy Sunday
Georgina
how was your week oh the Lord is with me
but the devil he got his hands on my
grand niece Grace oh no they're smoking
the reefer doing the Hank and pancake
with boys
or Esther you know
that I love all things that are good and
holy but if he doesn't let go of my
grand niece Grace I'm gonna cut the
devil's off and shove it in his ass
with my prayers I know you're well
Georgina I know you will
how was your week girl oh you know me
I'm blessed and thankful for everything
all right but you know my grandson Jason
got his self wrapped up in the leather
closet not Jesus he got himself arrested
for the spray painting
numbers oh Lord and I tell you I never
raise my hand in anger but if he don't
let Jason go I'm gonna punch that Satan
in the nuts so hard and wipe the licking
smirk off his horned ass face
with my prayers amen I know you will
Esther I know you will but Esther I
gotta tell you some announcement let it
out you know Esther I have found
Serenity in the glory of Heaven yes but
my daughter's husband Bernard has got
himself wedged between the cleft Hooves
the Lucifer himself she opened up his
laptop computer and found the
pornography it went on to pornography
absolutely the pornography of women not
on a laptop computer
[Music]
I am a pacifist under God's request but
if he don't let go of Bernard I'm gonna
sneak
on that [ __ ] ass Lucifer right in the
midst of his sleep time and then I'm
gonna sit on that mother head and almost
spread my booty cheeks on that Pig's
face and I'm on just pucker up my stank
hole and just tubes tubes tubes scoops
[Music]
I got a brown dot on his nose that I
could use for talking
with my prayers with your prayers of
course of course oh oh Georgina Georgina
Georgina oh I got nothing but faith and
God in heaven above but I tell you my
son's wife Crystal she got herself
wrapped up in the fiery wings of
mephistocrates yourself here we go you
know she got caught using personality
with her own children what at the dinner
table oh Lord
oh I have nothing but lovely every
creature on this planet but if he don't
let my darling Crystal go I'm gonna
flirt with the devil oh oh show him a
little bit of shoulder how you doing he
gonna start looking away I'm gonna start
twerking Stop Twerking he ain't gonna be
like he's gonna be he's gonna be drawn
in seduce that little [ __ ] give
me one leads back my eyelashes at them
then when it least expects it and I got
his trust that's when I'm gonna ride
I'm gonna give him the night of his life
and not you ain't never gonna forget I'm
gonna give him this way yeah I'm gonna
give him that way and then right when he
about to climax that's when I'm gonna
clean
on that [ __ ] and I'm gonna snap
off with a Divine Kegel well you gotta
snap it
with your prayers of course with the
prayers yeah but that's right girl yeah
you go get them
MD
[Music]
what what's happening
Georgine isn't here anymore
Satan
[Music]
oh
help me somebody help me I've got to get
out of this [ __ ]
stupid
urethra
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh give me some of that I want a piece
of him
[Music]
who is this crazy [ __ ] now
[Laughter]
what's going on this feels good why
would you do this to me
here you go
I'll do anything I'll do anything
[Music]
on his ass
please please get these crazy [ __ ]
off of me
Jesus Christ is my personal Lord and
Savior I swear
feel like crap it just came from a
trashy Indian restaurant in a strip mall
not bad food though got pretty lucky got
the hottest baddest Curry ever ate in my
life a place called nonsense Indian
joints
it's like I'm going to my brother's
wedding on Sunday and it's like I even
want to go I don't even like my brother
my brother brothers like a jerk but like
his wife she's like a [ __ ] I stayed
with him for like three weeks she's a
[ __ ] to me man I put my feet on her
coffee table she was like don't get your
feet on my cup I'm like who are you
a ginger broad man like those are the
worst people on the planet so I said
that too I said that to him in the
parking lot I cornered him a little bit
sure but he swung on me man he swung on
me can you believe that it's like who
swings and their own brother Matt yeah I
swung back
but that's cool you know it's like I
haven't seen him for a while but now got
this expensive wedding I have to go to
sounds crazy I gotta get my uh tickets
and that's the whole situation I hate
doing that and hold on a second hey hey
pow pow
der start on the downstairs bits a
middle of a conversation up here
I've got it
thank you
about that
is
from the Eternal from within
there is a guy in there
yes and hopefully I you know I can get
like two down in one evening you know
and speaking of 2001 anything if they've
got popcorn shrimp and little lobster
rolls
stop
who goes there
[Music]
last night my name is
everything is changing what do you mean
the end is near South no I don't I don't
know what you mean what do you mean I
don't want to die there's nothing you
can do the end is near everything is
changing from the eternity
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
championships
representing the body shop from
Hollywood California
and from the skin Shop Detroit Michigan
lightning
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's get this party started
ladies and gentlemen this is Paramount
Plus
Strokes of Genius beautiful games and
One Shining Moments this is this is
fenders investigators and seven
strangers picked them in a house this is
Young SpongeBob young Sheldon and the
younger this is everything you've been
you've been for that's gonna leave a
mark live sports breaking news and a
mountain of entertainment all right this
is Paramount plus now streaming
oh thank you I wish I could just stay at
my old place but I can't afford the new
rent yeah moving sucks you know
strangers handling your belongings the
movers always bring something oh no I
can't afford professional movers I'm
moving myself this Saturday
foreign
you can help me with some of the big
stuff
um
yeah
you know what I've been thinking a lot
lately and I think we need to spend some
time apart
not not to break up no I just I just
just some time
apart to figure ourselves out and and
then and then we come back together
stronger you know this is coming out of
nowhere no it's not I've
I have I've tried to tell you like I'm
like a million different ways but you
don't listen see you that's the thing is
that you you never listen I don't need
this time apart for me I need this time
apart for us how long do you think it's
gonna take you to move okay this is
about the move you don't want to help me
move what
what
I'm gonna help you move that's what
boyfriends do
I just think that it's a weird
coincidence that you need space right
when I'm about to move oh my God
oh my God I am so sorry that I didn't
plan my emotional turmoil around your
move look at your face see and now
you've assumed the worst of me because
you do that and that's why we need to
spend time apart from each other that is
not fair not fair
babe all I'm asking for is 12 lousy
hours this Saturday okay fine okay fine
we'll move on Sunday 48 hours I don't
know what I was thinking 12 hours
is nowhere near enough time
to do what I need to do to make our
relationship stronger see you got me all
confused and you know what I love you
but I gotta get out of here I can't I
just can't I don't I'm so confused right
now I feel like I can't think and the
walls are closing in on me and I just
don't know what to do I was my landlord
he says he doesn't want to lose me as a
tenant so he is not going to raise my
rent
now I don't have to leave my place
and I don't need time apart because
we're perfect together
[Music]
will you marry me
you paint my apartment
of course I'm painting your apartment
that's what boyfriends do when exactly
do you think that's going to happen
no matter what though don't snitch I
ain't saying nothing dude
you know me I die before I turn snitch
we tell them nothing they got nothing
you think Jay Rock talking hell no dog
hey rock is my cousin that man would
never snitch all right so just chill out
here oh hey bring that ice when you get
that chance do I all right man you're
the man Knight
jazz
what up J Rock they hurt you up a
natural me hurt you look like he just
got back from the [ __ ] snack shop
what you say to them man
[Music]
right here all right my brother
this man ain't never snitch on nobody
never
look
we in this together huh
say nothing right
right right
nobody gonna say nothing about how big
girls shot up that liquor store
no I don't know it wasn't big girl what
the hell are you talking about
the one hell no bug shot's the one that
held up that liquor store
buckshot
Now where's he going
I don't know maybe he's going to the
bathroom or some [ __ ] man he's going in
there to snitch on US ah no listen let
me tell you something that's my boy
right there we grew up together that is
a stand-up G that man would never
snitch's time
below picture time wake up in the
morning
Pizza Pizza Time mother onion Pig ass
cop man hey
hold on now J-Rock um
where'd you get the pizza
back there
bought it can't you know what muscle you
made it this ain't no [ __ ] game okay
if I find out you touch this on us I'm
gonna bust a cap in your tiny piece of
breath ass and then I'm gonna bury you
in my mother's basement with the rest of
the snitches
what
we said we said where you going where
you going where you going man we go
see look look he's selling me out right
now no no no he's saying that I would
never sell out that man up
I'm telling you all right all right
let's go let's go come on yo man see
what I tell you Rockwell huh what I tell
you you snitch ass [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up y'all
hey what you guys playing Oh no just a
little DVD right uh what's DVD uh it
came for you in the mail it says to my
fresh dope son from MC mom
come on
come on man oh yeah
oh yeah oh God please man did you
produce this track
I'm the m to the C to the m-o-m and when
it comes to Mom rappers I'm the biggity
best of them wow
I'm to my homie number one his name's
Carl Stewart but to me he's just son
[Music]
you left some stuff behind that I can
send you if you need Like Your Best
Friend Bear and your magazines going
through all this stuff but it looks
pretty risky you use so much lotion but
your socks sure are crispy
I've been cleaning with the broom and
the vacuum and found Victoria's Secret
is she's hiding in your room every nook
and cranny there are lots of tissue I
can't even open this swimsuit issue
what is wrong with you bro I spilled a
soda on that magazine I'm getting your
sheets so nice and clean like when you
wet your bed till you were 16. I
overreacted sorry I spanked you look
another crispy sock no thank you
how many crispy socks she gonna find
though crispy here crispy socks there
crispy socks with some mystery hair
we're gonna turn it off right now come
on you guys we started it we gonna
finish
oh oh the beat changed out
I got the kitchen and the basement and
the living room and since your dad met
that [ __ ] I got his office too got my
juices going my Rhymes flowing my breath
flowing showing the signs are slowing I
can feel my skills growing took a little
practice to practice these lyrical
gymnastics but now the fact is Queen Bee
imma be throwing out your [ __ ]
mattress hell yeah baddest [ __ ] in the
biz taking the show on the road you can
clean up your own cheers [ __ ] peace way
s
here is your white wine thank you you
are welcome hey Pete a little uh a
little thirsty tonight
yeah super thirsty Pete this is a racer
all right so this is uh Pete Harissa
just got back from Africa oh Africa
uh anyways uh where was I oh the AUC oh
right so this conflict is exactly the
reason that the African Union commission
was put in place to address the
organization of African Unity certainly
wasn't going to do anything exactly and
in Costa Zana Zuma wants to do anything
about bangui she's certainly been quiet
about it the worst part about Bungie is
that no one knows what's going on we
look at right next door the South Sudan
here's the thing everybody just thinks
that it's like it's the damn Lion King
over there you know Lion King
excuse me
it's not the Lion King
exactly
I mean what do people think hey
hey baboon is gonna hold a lion cub
over a rock up to the sun while all the
little animals sing
anyway
um something else I wanted to mention is
they have the Manpower because Amazon
has 25 000 troops just sitting there in
Somalia it's not a three animated hyena
situation that doesn't make any sense
the bad guy isn't scar
over there
um yeah yeah that's right it's not like
Scar's the bad guy huh well I mean you
know the truth is no
who to blame
in reality Amazon doesn't have that much
control I don't like Simba
oh like Simba he had no control over
well he was plucked out from his home
and went on a whole journey before he
came back and was just in the middle of
a war really had nothing to do with him
you know Pete I'd be really interested
in hearing your thoughts on the un's
policies in East Africa
Hakuna Matata
unbelievable
yes
there's so much work still to be done
yes that's what I was saying listening
going to many years so many years circle
of life
exactly that's really
that's really brilliant let's dial it
back I'm just a man okay uh I'm gonna
I'm gonna go get some uh some hors
d'oeuvres okay no need to announce it
what are your thoughts on the Middle
East
Aladdin
and what universe is the Family Circus
better than Dilbert for instance oh yo
what's up man how you
then oh you know cuz
keeping it straight
no
all right cool well I guess I'll check
you later all right dog
you should see these rain people with
James Khan
and Shirley Knight that's uh
[Music]
uh what's up man
[Music]
you guys want to say
yeah man um
how's Denise oh yeah Denise
anyway I guess I'll catch you on the
flip yeah don't yeah ain't no time
no I'm in the dog I'm in there okay
I'm in there tuck it I'm talking Indian
dog I'm in your dog I'm in your dog
all right
foreign
as you all can see here we have a new
traveler in our ranks uh this is my
cousin Tyrell and he will be controlling
the player character
his name is Kanye he's a giant yo
uh dear cousin traditionally a giant is
not assumed by a player it is a chaotic
evil but I want to be a giant yo
are big
okay fine well Travelers you are enjoyed
on your adventure today by a giant named
Kanye now when last we left you you were
at the Inn of the North Star in the town
of isildor how do you begin your
adventure I want to get some [ __ ]
where the club at esled door yeah Tyrell
This is highly unusual I think the guys
probably just want to go on the quest
yes
I'd like to join Kanye the giant of this
Quest
seriously
all right the two of you enter it's
Heaven what do you say Kanye the giant
orders Alize hmm does the barkeep I know
not of this foreign beverage of which
you speak perhaps you would enjoy an
elded ale no we both
does not exist in this world Connie the
giant slaps that [ __ ] oh Cuddy the
giant attempts to slap the bartender
here the bartender is half Hobbit and
very Nimble so you're going to have to
roll it 18 or above to hit 20. flip slap
that Hobbit off yo okay
call the cleric would you care to
restrain Katya the giant before the town
guard is called I grab money out of the
register God the cleric is lawful good
this act of thievery would dishonor his
Gods amen the only guys is money and
[ __ ] dude
except Kanye the Giants God and uh
I steal some of the money too
okay would you now like to continue your
quest for the lads of caldahar fellas we
came here for [ __ ] where the [ __ ]
at
all right you see a bevy of well-endowed
wedges great
I grabbed them [ __ ] and we all go on
my SUV five Kylie the giant udar the
dwarf and Gollum the cleric climb into
his SUV with their [ __ ] and their
ill-gotten gains
plus Kanye the giant puts his demo CD in
the season no he doesn't there are those
do whatever you want
all right I guess I'm the dungeon master
now
the eye of Odin opens up
[Applause]
16 titties fall out yeah
hey man I just have to say I am a huge
fan Outcast like changed my life yeah
thanks man so you're gonna collaborate
with Andre 3000 again
no
how come
people grow apart
a greetings may I have a half calf decaf
mint mocha latte foam on the bottom
served in a flower vase and if you all
got some green food coloring back there
throw it in oh
I don't know in the flash is right over
there
[ __ ] I'm trying to read a book
my brother from another mother man and
when I say mother you know I'm talking
about art right cause we got cut out of
her womb what's up man what's up Andre
Andre who
I ain't gonna say it man it's not 2 999.
it's not 3001. hey man what happened to
you after the show yeah um
I just I must just like snuck out or
something my fault patrols you went
missing
all those voices man do what voice
is man why are you doing the voice why
are you doing that man one green half
decaf mint mocha latte foam on the
bottom of the vase I got a new idea for
an album man it's going to be just the
sound a screech of metal and then only
one spoken word per Track cool cool
don't do that that's one of them
screeching metal sounds I'm talking
about earlier man
mocha latte foam on the bottom and a
vase
or boss you ain't here that that's your
that's you the only [ __ ] that ever
ordered that drink yeah okay so what is
going on with me what is happening with
what the [ __ ] happened man
what are you talking about we used to be
somebody man we used to be a team we was
on top
then you went and lost your [ __ ] mind
can we just lose this man can we just
lose the 3 000 and just have you talk as
Andre tell me tell me straight up man
what happened
you know what being better domain
so if you look into the pinwheel with
your third eye I thought she was gonna
say some stupid [ __ ] like that and
everything will be all right man it's
been good man thank you thanks for
seeing us okay matter of fact I got an
appointment right now to go get 54
October you got it
you leaving me that's a
[Music]
don't do it do it euros
Artemis
and Apollo
guide you through your musical Journey
[ __ ] what
why does your breath smell like burnt
seed
thank you cafe Craftsman you're welcome
sweet
ie
sorry he didn't actually pay for that I
got it
which one you want
give me both of them man okay
I decide which one I want when I want to
eat it
you uh you want some of these vegetables
too no no
I'm just saying man
the nutrients is good
for maintaining energy levels so
I know what the [ __ ] a vegetable is man
don't don't tell me what a vegetable is
man I'm hey
I'm a grown ass man
all right
yeah I'm sorry
there's three bean salad is the bomb now
oh snap they got three bean salad up
enough I ain't even see that
you want some of mine
yeah okay
open the hanger
what you doing
no uh you don't do that you don't feed
me like a kid man
I'm a grown ass man okay yeah you got
some Schmutz right here hey hey
out of my face milk
you never touch a grown man's face yeah
that's right I'm sorry okay you all are
grown ass hey hey I don't need you to
Pat my back I'm a grown ass man what you
doing I know you're going I don't want
to hear it anymore about grown ass man
uh that's what I am I don't want to hear
what happened
don't start acting up here cause you're
making me angry um okay then I need you
to breathe a little bit can you breathe
[Music]
[ __ ] I want a [ __ ] inside
voice up in this [ __ ] don't be getting
loud up around these white people
[Music]
I do not a baby
[Music]
um
how we behave stupid [ __ ]
oh oh I'm sorry I'm sorry you're a grown
ass man
who's a grown ass man you're a grown ass
man
yeah grown ass man right you know what
grown ass man do you go to the bathroom
and change your password right yeah yeah
okay let's go
all right excuse me everybody
um
I'm sorry but my son got that Benjamin
buttons disease oh
recorded
um
Noah Sanders here for the job interview
please take a seat
[Music]
Mr
job interviews huh
never fun
okay
I get it stay focused
okay
that's a big laugh
oh no I did it no you didn't
[Laughter]
exclusive job interviewer The Carol
Burnett Show you know what I mean
thanks so much for coming in Adam of
course and you better stay away from
that Chinese oh my God you got that
right
no stomach time
oh my gosh what an absolute Delight it's
been great and can I tell you something
yeah
I don't even care if I get this job
because I know I've made a friend for
life
what a terrific attitude
what a great goddamn attitude yeah you
son of a gun you know what
right quick before you leave I want to
give you something no sir I can't take
any more gifts this whole thing has been
a gift
my brother passed away
21 years ago
we were estranged
then he became ill
and he gave this to me as a peace
offering
and then one day when we were on the
ocean he fell overboard on about very
much like this one and died
I saw him struggling all the way as a
Riptide just
[ __ ]
as a token of my gratitude for you
bringing Joy back into my life
under any other circumstance I would
refuse
except this gift today
thank you
oh hey matey
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
how do you keep a straight face all day
and she's sweet it's weird oh my God God
damn it I love your [ __ ] energy well
what can I say sir I am solar powered
God
[Music]
really you like you like that one huh
interview I've ever been a part of in my
entire life
okay who's next
you ready let's go chop chop here we go
come on let's go
okay
requesting permission to come on board
sir hi Noah Sanders name uh sorry to
hear about your brother maybe we can get
some Chinese food after this all right
all right okay take it easy
she's settle down turbo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh
my God
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
wow
ah
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
uh
ah
crap
[Applause]
ah
oh
I'm telling you Vinnie no disrespect to
your daily departed grandmother but my
aunt makes a pasta forget about it
your aunt lives in this neighborhood
seems kind of dangerous
what are you McGruff the crime dog come
on we're late already
yeah you you say she lives in this house
here
that's the matter with you Vinnie you're
being rude let's go
not trying to be rude
the lights are off maybe we let's come
back later okay she's probably just
taking a nap after the huge meal she
just made for us go in
I don't have the key you should go in
first she said she'd leave it open
Vinnie stop being such a strong and get
in there
all right all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hurry
please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
surprise
welcome welcome
that's a good lady yes all right there
you go first timer
first time for you first time yes
yeah
so what's good okay
you have to have to keep happy is what
you're going to have okay oh don't they
serve that in the cafe across the street
you cannot get the get puppy at the cafe
across the street
what did I say across the street is that
a baby this Cafe
Macedonia
my friends
I like to apologize for the behavior of
my passion I just feel bad in my brain
for people to think that your mouths
will have been raped
but the food that is serving at this
cell paining and mother of [ __ ] this
mother [ __ ] sons of my [ __ ] across
the street what they be serving is
and and what do you serve here
okay
okay
look at mouth
okay okay okay
what is the difference between kebapi
and
chebappi
but they don't know
no I have to forgive them right
for the bastard mother beaches over
there that are serving the chavapi
pulled in the grilled meat salt chopped
red pepper diced onion cream kashmock
iceberg
then the cottage cheese
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
we are here
now it is time for you to try the real
good food not what this son oh my
[ __ ] serve across the street
on you
have you ever found yourself in High
Point North Carolina and not feeling
safe come on down to Doug Duggars
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
you will learn to tacklemore Grapple
like an ultimate fighting Pro
in my studio you get Hands-On training
and individual attention
[Music]
attack on grapple take on multiple
enemies this is a tackle that's a
grapple right there this is a tap
that's a grapple there we are
backwards all ages learn to protect
yourself and your loved ones
there are many different levels there's
the beginner level and if you pass my
private one-on-one Sensei trial
you may make it into the advanced class
Doug Duggar's Brazilian Jiu Jitsu at the
High Point many more just east of a
piece of bomb two doors down from Kyle's
discount ribs and Furniture it's a quick
Taco get there uh trip them up
no steak stay away
special discounts for college students
move it get your leg back
[Music]
this is not just another streaming app
what this is so much comedy it's not
even funny are you choking me bro this
is daily late and lately this is real
roasted and raw this is great stand up
great movies and the great cornholio are
you threatening me no this is one pump
two pumps
and three pumps this is live sports
breaking news and a mountain of Comedy
entertainment Paramount plus now
streaming
oh hold on a second
oh hell no he did not just text me he
working late that [ __ ] is weak you know
what working late my ass if you don't
walk through that door in the next half
an hour he means when I can come home
tonight because I'm not gonna be there
waiting for his cheating ass okay
you know what I'm saying I will be there
waiting because
but he gonna have to put up with a lot
of [ __ ] for me okay and if he think he
gonna do this [ __ ] again he is sorely
mistaken oh God because my man gets one
chance one okay and then after that he
get one more okay and then after that he
gonna get three strikes
he better get as far away from me as he
possibly can because he do not want to
get what I'm gonna give to him okay I
got my [ __ ] real estate license
okay but if and when he does come home
that's fine okay because he can go out
and get all turned up with these low
side hoes and whatnot cause you know
what [ __ ] he always gonna come home all
right okay I'm the queen beat and he
always gonna come home
okay but I'll tell you what happened if
you do come home okay you ain't gonna be
pulling any of that [ __ ] in my house
okay yeah he can come to the house if he
wants to but he ain't never gonna do
that when I'm home all right you know
what even if I'm home
it's fine
you know what I'm talking about
okay because I don't give a good guy
damn okay that's what I'm talking about
but he ain't gonna bring that [ __ ] into
my bedroom I'll tell you that much right
now okay because ain't no trip Finance
[ __ ] gonna wake me up while he's
cheating on me in my bed again okay and
I told him I looked it right in the face
I said this is the fifth and last time
okay
I couldn't say it better myself yo
you're right okay
you just been spouting words of wisdom
all evening I ain't listening to her
then you say
I don't even know what the hell I was
thinking girl you right
that man walks through that door I'm
gonna dump his ass oh
okay okay okay oh my gosh speak of the
devil
[Music]
oh okay
okay
today on Judge Jesse judge Jesse turns
up the heat you signed a piece of paper
he gave you the snake then you bring the
snake into the home with
with Chihuahuas I had not been made
aware that the snake would get rid of
his skin and then the sprinklers came
down with the snakeskin room my carpet
what what's it off the sprinklers
unrelated popcorn fire your honor
judge Jesse as a police officer he
defended the streets as a trial lawyer
objection he fought for the truth as a
black belt
he mastered discipline
as a carpenter he learned the value of
craftsmanship as a surgeon he mastered a
cool head
as a crack hoe he learned to go days
without sleep
and as an announcer he does the voice
over on this show
coming up on Judge Jesse Mr Simmons
before you speak I know from experience
the police have completely mishandled
your case and there's legal precedent
for you to win and any good defense
attorney would have told you that I also
know that obviously the place where you
hurt your back wasn't structurally up to
code Mr oyama and furthermore as a
Sensei you should know a man of his
skill set cannot do a mikeyaki you
should know that obviously I can tell by
looking at your alignment that you've
herniated a disc someplace in your L4
your L5 I'm fighting for the plaintiff
not twenty five hundred dollars twenty
seven hundred dollars thank you your
honor you're quite welcome
judge yes
Dusty can I suck your neck
you ready homie hell's yeah
hold up
no
what
we gotta go back home man
why
I pooped my pants
what just now I just pooped my pants
you got diarrhea I don't know man I
ain't gay
we gotta go home right now man let me
change my drawers some of the dudes be
trying to smoke is right there man how
you want me to smoke somebody and I got
poop in my pants
are you sure you pooped him am I sure am
I short yeah
yes that is poop in my pants nasty man
it's natural man for three-year-olds not
for hardcore gangster see this is my
real friend though you will make such a
big deal out of it what makes such a big
deal out of it
you a grown ass man who just in his
drawers oh snap
no you did it get your pants again don't
judge you need to get out of my car and
go to the hospital
okay I see how it see I wouldn't do that
to you though you never would have to do
that to me because under no
circumstances would I ever get my pants
oh God
I'm sorry I judged you apology accepted
tonight here at the opulent tostino
Center 50 000 fans are ready to binge
drink for a couple of hours I tell you
what I can't wait hi I'm grown
Manchester rinka and I'm grown man Bob
desantio that's right Bob and we have
both made careers watching adult men
play a simple child's game all while
being paid more than the president okay
chick and it seems as though the
millionaires are ready to play their
game so we can stop stalling with the
Mindless chat and the Rhino's been the
ball into play and the alleged rapist
passes the Big Orange ball to the sweaty
legal giant yeah
and easily puts the ball into the basket
making it look easy which if you're
seven feet tall it is he made about
eight thousand dollars while he was
doing it now the power Falcons are
bringing the ball into play the high
school dropout inbounds of the convicted
spousal abuser he slashes through all of
the drug addicts dumps the ball after
the genetic freak and boom quackalacka
two points downtown Oscar placas Bingo
time storm scams
[Music]
I'm just saying words that start with
this I'm going pure nonsense
[Applause]
are you okay I'm great Bob
I'll tell you we still got it on it oh
yeah yeah we do true that Walden we here
around we oh yeah hey we hitting it and
written it right now
[Applause]
we out here straight hitting the bricks
as it were hey I'm gonna tell you right
now I got a pocket full of niggles and
I'm ready to get loose all right
okay uh get another round please
you guys like Drake
drink a drink drink we got drinks I'll
sort it out we got them young buck drink
front there Tiny Town Drake
like Drake the rapper he's a musician
like started from the bottom now we're
here Drake
you didn't drink you know a musician
called drink okay you know never never
mind
um you guys are awesome
foreign
sperm my testicles do not make I woke up
this morning into my booty hole late
great great great great
[Music]
oh now look at it look at these two Old
Timers over here
now I take it easy on them
I will though because I will but I will
hey
hello gentlemen
y'all like great
drink
hell yes
started from the bottom now the whole
team [ __ ] here yo like Tyler the
Creator
Who you gonna call
hi I'm Ray Parker Jr writer and
performer of the Academy Award nominated
hit single Ghostbusters from the major
Motion Picture Ghostbusters but that's
just one song I've written so many other
major Motion Picture theme songs and
submitted them throughout the year now
they're available and together for one
especially priced compilation songs like
you tried to play the game but it's
driving you insane
Jumanji danger in the jungle
Jumanji this Lion in my house
come on Mr Computer throw me a bow I
said lawn mower man
[Music]
out of here
I ain't afraid to know Troy watch out
behind you they're trying to find you
pilot can't breathe it's getting legal
y'all these songs have only been heard
by the highest level of Industry
decision makers but now you can feel
like a Hollywood executive in your own
home
[Music]
[Music]
now there's a whole lot of kinky that
that room is stinky Fifty Shades of Gray
all right white people
oh
[Music]
12 years
[Music]
there's one thing I know is that
persistence makes Perfection sure
Hollywood missed out but that doesn't
mean you have to
down in the basement what's going on
it's uh
oh there's a kid in the Nazi down there
foreign
order now to receive your free copy of
Bobby sings the twos theme songs to
sequels that were never made
[Music]
warning
[Music]
Ron good morning Mr Shelby
how's the fam
oh I don't have one I'm single sir I'm
not married I mean I do have a
girlfriend that's great oh God
[Music]
hey I need you to do me a favor
make sure everybody knows that the
bagels are for sales associates only
no problem sir
all right let's get this sales
presentation started
all right who's hungover
I know Ron is that's not true you're an
alcoholic
I'm not sir I'm not
hey guys sales associates friends
today I want to talk about
the world's oldest profession
hold on hold on oh no I know what you're
thinking right sex and prostitutes
that's not what I'm talking about
okay talking about sales
if you look at our ancient history as
human beings the first caveman out there
sold a rock to the second gay man out
there
oh no I'm sorry those are for sales
associates only
fool not not for you I'm sorry the
bagels are just for sales associates
plus hey no it's free oh for free not
not for you though it's just for me no
the bagels are only for sales associate
Ron love the enthusiasm but it's a
little distracting I'm sorry I'm sorry
sir uh don't do it again please sorry
moving on for me maybe no not not maybe
I'm sorry I'm so sorry
it's just that they're for sales
associates only on Me Maybe
no okay forget that
just shut up all right
who's the first tongue twister you
remember hearing
sir
cream cheese is also only for sales
associates welcome it's not for me why
because the bagels are for sale on yes
time and place man I'm sorry this guy
just keeps trying to grab a baby do you
want to come up here and do the
presentation I'll go back there and be a
jackass you just asked me to make sure
that nobody but
my name is Rod I'd like to drink alcohol
and listen to science all day
he's really Relentless about having a
baby angel your bagels I'm trying
unbelievable everybody all right I'll
just I'll start cold cells make up our
bodies but selling makes our bodies come
alive
seriously
no no no no you can't have any Bagels
you can't have any cream cheese and you
can't have smells that's what the
[ __ ] sign said right yes you are
fired sir of course I am
all right
all right you know what
just give me a minute I'm gonna try to
forget Ron ruined my day
this presentation is great
hey
he's right Mom
there's no way that he can win no no so
anyway
um what'd you think of the season finale
Game of Thrones
no no no I'm reading the books oh sorry
sorry I saw the first book and he reads
slow
we could never talk about it
okay
hey has anybody seen that new Russell
Crowe Thriller because let me tell you
[Music]
sorry it's just we're going tomorrow and
I don't want to know a thing about it he
doesn't want to know a thing okay all
right sure yeah yeah yeah
who won the game
that I'm gonna watch it later
oh you're oh you have a DVR I got it
okay
yeah oh
so yeah
what's the weather gonna be like
sorry it sounds
we're having a barbecue this weekend and
I don't want to stress about the weather
no of course you don't we just yeah yeah
hmm
istry being cast with all this stuff
I'm so sorry babe I just I hadn't tasted
him yet
I'm sorry looking forward to you know
talk about the ingredients I know yeah
it's a surprise for your mouth yeah
yeah oh uh
if you got you know that commercial with
it
okay
[Laughter]
nevermind
it's probably best yeah
no
cheesecake
got cheesecake
oh yeah you know what yeah I love some
cheesecake let's do that yeah yeah yeah
cheesecake I mean I've been watching my
cholesterol intake but what the hell
right well I'm gonna die someday anyway
right
what honey wow are you kidding me really
you're just ruin it every time I'll see
you at home wait a second
would you not know that that was taken
yo what's up Game of Thrones though do I
yo you all caught up totally bus watched
that whole thing last night yo it's cold
blooded up in Westeros God they killed
my man it starts
[Music]
I mean my man was just dead right he got
down there on the thing I mean I was
like I ain't worried they gonna kill my
boy that start slip and then plop I was
like
yo I told you they cold blooded up in
there and then I was like but that's
okay because I still got my college logo
oh pig's name Navarro Big Dave Navarro
yeah that dude picked up some molten
gold
I wanna sleep a nice hairstyle and he
killed him right I mean he being like
Hercules and everything I'm like you
can't kill quadragos with a paper cut
and in fact they're scratching scratch
so he got straight killed but just yo
but you know what my favorite character
is
Khaleesi's place
you know I'll be liking some Khaleesi's
daughter but what about khaleesis
straight up with them dragons
as Khaleesi is all like this and then we
talk about it
this great roasting goats oh my God I
mean that's when they start killing
characters left and right doing after
waiting
monsters what his wife yo
no
killed Slowly by Omission yo but what
about my man Taiwan Lannisters Taiwan
Lannisters yo my man's talking about I'm
taking you yeah
by his own son what
the dinkles
the dinkles dinkles
dinkles Is My Jam ain't nobody tilt the
decks they think cause it's my jam my
jelly my peanut butter and my peanuts
Tinkles though
there it goes is
[Music]
it's a weird one nothing out of place no
murder weapon and no motive there's such
a couple lying dead in their bed
the proof is always out there detectives
you just have to know where to find the
pudding excuse me sir you can't bear
this is a crime scene
it's okay
he's the greatest sex crime investigator
in history
if it isn't detective Chuck Vaughn
detective Sally Ferguson we could use a
genius right now Tom Samwell
what have we got Samwell well uh long
we've got ourselves a hard case here all
we've got is two bodies both dead naked
one man one woman
in the bed two scented candles by the
nightstand how did you
no sign of forced entry
he loved the way they smelled
he wanted to cross the threshold the way
they had on their wedding day
Dirty Dog
he would have experienced that pleasure
right here
anniversary a couple was together for a
while wanted to spice things up
took the date on the photograph
foreign
's right today was their 15th wedding
anniversary this is huge and
what the [ __ ] was that you just pulled
your dick out and started jerking off at
the crime scene Samuel
he's the best there is by putting
himself in the perpetrator's mindset
he's able to solve crimes that involve
sex back this up
some call it a blessing
it's more like a curse is that what it
feels like
threesome
you wanted to see them didn't you you
wanted to watch
25 feet from the bedroom across from the
kitchen you
didn't want to see their flesh yet did
you
no he stood
right here
[Laughter]
laughs
[Music]
role play Gone Wrong check the logs
we've got a bloody fire poker we've got
our murder weapon
um why do your Revelations require
masturbation why do kittens require milk
no not the same thing hey hey
he's the most brilliant goddamn
detective I know put your ego aside and
give vonna's space my ego we've got
Captain PUD puller flinging his fluids
all over the crime scene wait
he knew them
they were closed so close too close he
he
I think he knew the house
why
what did you want you sick bastard
he wanted to see
what he saw every day
only Closer Closer
he was close to home
[Laughter]
there's a man
all right let's go get him go go
come on
that was amazing I'm sorry
that I doubted you your methods are
unorthodox but
I cannot argue with your results
no hard feelings uh no no not gonna
oh
no my little darling Oh man [ __ ] you
you suck my
Tao thing
[Music]
this is Whitaker I have been babysitting
for 20 years I've seen it all the thing
is uh Forest is a unique child
everything is going to be fine I want
you to have a good time tonight you
deserve it
okay um
okay good luck
hey is there a forest
I want
our milk
you want me to get your your bottle
buddy I want milk okay
[Music]
this is a baba
I want Mama's milk
why can't I have Mama's milk
and simple requests wait yeah well uh
you should you can't have Mama's milk
right now buddy um how about we play
okay I want
I want I want to play with my Legos okay
yeah
yeah okay buddy let's look it's your
Legos done
I wanna
I wanna put the smallest Lego in my
mouth that's what I'm gonna do it no no
you can't you can't do that what
first you tell me I can't have Mama's
milk
now you ham the smallest Lego in my
mouth
what a night
it's a bad start rip it before it's
dangerous
let me get this straight you're in
charge of me in my house all right first
it's time for bed I guess then
you gonna sing me a song
what mom always sing me a song before I
go to sleep
are you gonna do that for me
okay okay yeah yes I will
hush little baby don't say a word
keep keep singing mama's gonna buy you a
mockingbird put my name in it
I like I like it personal hush baby
Forest Whitaker don't say a word
mom is gonna buy you a mockingbird who
baby
and if that mockingbird don't sing have
a good cry
but I was gonna buy you retirement
[Music]
hey babe
um I made a really big decision without
consulting you
I I went by
um a puppy rescue stand on University
Avenue
I had to I had to you've got us a dog
yeah I did
so honey I've got to tell you something
okay these rescue dogs have had some
tough situations and a lot of them take
on the personality of their owners
and this dog was owned by rapper Ice Tea
all right little buddy come on out
hello my little darling Oh man [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you suck my
this house thing okay buddy take it easy
nothing ever been easy for me in my life
to hook me up with a treat you want a
treat buddy you want a treat is that
what you want here he goes
um yeah that's a tasty ass treat right
there now give me the whole bag okay one
treat is enough [ __ ] without talking to
you
give me the whole bag of treats because
I'm a treat killer and a [ __ ]
handful somebody's grumpy today grumpy
whoopy leave my ass right up on this
comfortable ass sofa I'ma sleep on this
[ __ ] too as a matter of fact you know
what [ __ ] and [ __ ] I'm a piston
up here too no oh no no no no raise your
hand at me okay
um I've got something for you little guy
huh huh you want to play fetch you want
to play fetch you like fetch get that
ball [ __ ] you both y'all can't defending
[ __ ] I Ain't Your Entertainment
[ __ ] so [ __ ] you
oh
hello who is this come on Coco don't
worry about these [ __ ] that's my
[ __ ] Coco well I forgot to tell y'all
she gonna be living here too wow okay
you got your little friend here yeah
yeah well you can uh she can play here
for a while sure puppy play date yeah
lady we gonna have a date that's we
gonna have [ __ ] come here [ __ ]
are you he's doing that oh no don't do
that yeah that's my [ __ ] suit okay oh
dear get the [ __ ] out of here it's about
to get graphic in this [ __ ] how come
you don't do that with me I mean I told
you he does it I just want to keep this
area clean ladies and gentlemen Darius
Rucker
foreign
[Music]
I'm not in hoodie in the Blowfish
anymore y'all doing my own thing what do
you mean in hoodie because you you are
Hootie man come on everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
now stop it stop it I'm not Hootie I'm
Darius Rucker all right I used to be the
front man for a band called Hootie and
the Blowfish
all right but I was never Hootie there
was never a hoodie just if I may if I
may ask where are the Blowfish at right
guys
[Applause]
no then there are no people known as The
Blowfish y'all okay the whole band was
just called Hootie and the Blowfish
that's it it was a nonsense name like
Hoobastank or told the Wet Sprocket oh
don't go out with my friends no more
don't wanna hold your hand no more oh
yeah I see I get it now I understand hey
we gotta pick y'all we gotta choose
between Hootie or the Blowfish so who
wants to see the Blowfish
there's no blowfish
hey who wants to see Hootie
hey
hey that that hurts my feelings y'all
but you said you weren't Hootie no I'm
not sir but in the question you just
asked the audience I was clearly Hootie
so you are Hootie I'm not though he is
Hootie
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
nobody likes you you girl well you're a
different color than me and that's bad
oh yeah well you dress like a now hold
on a second
whoa Mr T never make fun of a way a man
dresses way man dresses is his business
remember that whether it's overalls
chains or feather earrings however they
dress is not to be joked about I'll pity
the fool that judges another man's
clothing
I'm sorry I judge your clothing it's
okay
[Music]
hey Scout there's a man over there who
said he'll give us candy if we get in
his van I don't know if that's a good
idea Timmy what are you afraid of is it
because you have a stupid name like
Scout hey
whoa Mr T again never make fun of a
person's name your mama gave you that
name or you made it up for business
purposes either way it's personal
I Penny the fool to make fun of another
man's name Mr T's a cool name it's a
cool name Mr T
[Music]
hey Scout want to do some drugs aren't
drugs bad
I don't know
if you're afraid of drugs we could drink
a bunch of alcohol
yum that sounds good
well guess what your hair is stupid
never make fun of another person's hair
hey Mr T a person's hair is the artwork
that they present to the heavens
it's just like I've been saying
[Music]
my head and I cry about your mean jokes
in my bed A is for anxiety that fools
provoke when they looking at my hair and
they making jokes I is for I don't like
the way I feel when you're joking that
my hair cut does not appear R is for the
real mean jokes you make and the hurtful
little pocket shots that you take
and for your information it's not even a
haircut it's a rare form of male pattern
baldness
your fools
[Music]
288 I'm investigating the report of a
disturbance
[Music]
because I got a pop sticker
foreign
watch out that black guy's got a gun
he's gonna steal your banana what
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go
you're gonna have to leave the area it's
been a disturbance
go for your safety sir go now please
[Music]
go go go get going
[Music]
I mean it's like it was like you know a
holiday for people having gone God damn
it Mayors are wall pack who's
responsible for this mask I'm sorry
Chief it was me
God damn it coffee cup my bad
anyway the last seven came out of
nowhere let's get this party started
ladies and gentlemen this is Paramount
Plus
Strokes of Genius beautiful games and
One Shining Moments this Defenders
investigators and seven strangers have
to live in a house this is Young
SpongeBob young Sheldon and the younger
this is everything you've been looking
for that's gonna leave a mark live
sports breaking news and a mountain of
entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now streaming
give yourself up Carlo why would I do
that
when I have the other man
[Laughter]
give yourself up Carlo
I'm right here
or am I over here
[Laughter]
oh
my God
where the hell are you
shut up [ __ ] come out
soon
[Music]
[Laughter]
mirror mirror all on a wall
who is the fairest of them
you are under arrest
for the murder of Mary Deeley
Meg Foster
and one detective Mason Jimenez
Now where's the girl
oh detector
you assume it's the real me standing in
front of you
but maybe that's just what I want you to
see
when in reality the real me
is safe in a hiding spot
okay that's the real you all right
or maybe I'm over here no no you're not
over there
Carlo I'm only going to ask you one more
time where is the girl go ahead and
shoot Detective
I mean what do I care if you get seven
years bad local you know it's not safe
to keep a gun cocked like that even if
you are just pointing it to the mirror
turn around and put your hands on your
head
now for that you really are going to
have to find the real man are you
kidding me
what why would you shoot a mirror Carlo
it's you I'm holding your lapel now
you're done it's over
you're going to cut your hand on that
broken mirror where is she
say it dude say what
say you don't know whether or not this
is the real me or just a reflection in
the mirror
weekly
okay I don't know whether the you I'm
holding on to is really you for the
reflection or our reflection in the
mirror
um almost to it she's on the before
boards by the intross oh
oh I win detective
I told you but I mean the mirror told
you but what you know
oh [ __ ]
oh
oh hey good to see you thanks for having
us this is my girlfriend
we're so happy you could join us and
this is my wife
so this is the infamous and
has told me so much about you both all
good things I hope you can never trust
[Music]
and please please don't call me makes me
think my mother's around someplace oh
hey you know where is little oh
she said
it's for a slumber party oh
um
uh there was this is a couple from New
York that we wanted you guys to meet uh
this is and her husband
they're gonna be in New York for a few
weeks so we were hoping you could give
them some tips I'm sure that'd be great
so how do you know and
oh well and I went to
School of dramatic arts back when was
working in Midtown oh where did you work
I was at uh
and
oh the law firm hey
how are you it's so good to see you hey
everybody this is
I want you to meet one of my dearest
oldest friends this is his girlfriend
of course you know this is and this is
her husband
hi what a beautiful name you know I
knewa
in grad school oh well thank you but
it's actually pronounced
[Music]
wow I swear that sounds like what you
were saying
anyways it's lovely to meet you all
Robert
I'm so sorry Hi and Rick
show myself to the restroom
watch she's so rude
it up what'd you get up to this weekend
though ah you know me man
got a ball up in that bed box oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know who's good
though
Robert Downey's juniors
Robert Downey Jr still doing which one
which one Tony Stark
s damn it Tony Starks Iron Man I may be
building his own suit and everything and
getting no ready with Papa uh yeah yo yo
my man's got a glowing Hearts you give
that a statue for that alone that's
right there man
where he woke up in his neighbor's
daughter's bed and he was all on drugs
no no that was already squared in real
life it was it was that was real she was
good in that one though he was good that
was very realistic you know what else is
good though Valley kilmers oh we're
talking about Valley cameras right now
no which one which one which one oh you
know Valley killers and tombstones oh
what
what
okay that's my that's right there donkey
holidays
okay
[Music]
oh yeah what about Valley kilmers in
that Willows though
when he was mad Mart again and there was
in that medieval tobag game
and a little Leprechaun talking about
you are great and he was magically
delicious delicious
and the Saints
my man was like
and then he was like and then
I I didn't see that one the cover looked
interesting you know what I'm realizing
right now for the first time it's like
if there was a graph of Rd Square and
Valley Kilmer's careers yeah yeah
already Square would start down here
right and Valley kilos will be starting
right up here and Rd Square would get
this trajectory right and then Valley
Kilmer's Beyond this trajectory right
here
movies making movies get a little crazy
little drugs crazy make it still making
movies and then they meet at this point
in the same movie which is why
the best movie of all time is Kiss Kiss
Bang Bang is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
when I would come in here to find you
sitting in that chair
was it easy dragging you down Decker
wasn't supposed to be
I know you're retired but that's all
behind me now General
I'm not the man you knew during the Cold
War I understand
we're now facing a threat unlike any
we've ever faced before
man with your expertise I made a foul
for to kill another human being
sorry General
got to find someone else
oh
no we uh we weren't thinking you'd do it
we were just hoping you could recommend
someone for the job
I guess I could come out of retirement
no
No Need Just a recommendation will do
all right
I'll do it you know you're just not what
we're looking for
son of a [ __ ]
he always knew how to push my buttons
I'm in not you Decker sharp as I ever
was
even faster too grab my hand nope
wait till I count to three first
one
two
[Music]
three
okay
I want you to try and slap me in the
face I wasn't ready for that
try again okay you know what yeah what
didn't have my adrenaline up because
this is not actual high-stakes situation
all right
draw your weapon
and disarmed
[Music]
you're getting pretty quick and disarmed
okay
I don't need to take your weapon
[Music]
you know what
[Music]
I am not going to shoot you
Wing me in the shoulder this is
ridiculous try General
see what happens
okay I made a mistake coming here why me
in the other shoulder I'd rather not I
insist
that was because my other arm was
already injured okay I'm leaving
all right all or nothing got a shot no
gut shot come on if you can shoot me in
the gut I'll concede Decker you have two
wounded arms
got it
[Music]
you you caught the bullet
so you're telling me that the bullet is
in between your hands right now
is that all you got
come on headshot
headshot let's go I'm ready I was wait
one second though
Coolio man oh yeah certainly
oh hey I gotta go yeah Terry out Sarah
how you doing man hey pretty good Gabe
oh got something on your shirt
not today Terry
it's like Gabe's come out to play
you do have something on your shirt no I
don't yeah you kind of do I'm pretty
sure I don't got a clean shirt at my
desk if you want me to get it for you
don't see why that would be necessary
because the treats you have on right now
it's not clean except for that it is me
I have a clean shirt you you have some
Schmutz on your jams no there is no
Schmitz in my Jammy Jam
you know what why don't I just get it
for you yeah why don't you do that
[Music]
and and there we go
[Laughter]
they almost got you yeah
almost I mean I'm thinking damn he's
good
but you know what the funny thing is
what's that now I guess from when I
dabbed your shirt with the paper towel
and I'm not playing the game right now
but I actually I must have got some
paper towel fuzz on your shirt so
foreign
[Music]
how long has Cameron wearing her hair up
like that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey Terry what's going on
uh having a good morning
I'm having a terrific morning
great hope there's nothing on my shirt
because I can't look down
oh no dude we're not doing that right
now okay
it's nothing on your shirt no one cares
about your shirt everything's not about
you
I'm trying to have a conversation with
Karen right now so
you okay Terry just pisses me off
oops
[Music]
oh yeah yeah I do have Schmutz there's
Schmutz all over me now you can't deny
that Terry's not gonna know what hit him
I will win I win
[Music]
what what happened
Terry
died
[Music]
hey Terry
it's Gabe
I am
just wanted to let you know that um
that you didn't get me Terry
you didn't get me because on the day
that you died there was Schmutz on my
shirt so guess who wins the game Terry I
do I win
you lose
[Music]
[Applause]
oh Jerry
he flicked me
Mr Lewis
thank you for coming in
with your Associates
I know this is hard to hear but we need
to make some serious decisions about
your mother's health let's be honest she
is getting on the news oh
snap okay I see how it is I see how it
is well yo mama so old her last name is
osaurus
no Mr Lewis it wasn't an insult I I was
just saying that your mother's condition
is deteriorating because she's getting
older oh see that's cold though that's a
cold one okay okay I see how it is hey
yo yo mama so old in her history class
they just wrote down what they was doing
an insult contest not only is your
mother elderly but also her ability to
walk is currently being affected by her
weight oh see okay it just got real no
I'm not insulting her I'm trying to tell
you your mama is so fat
we should go to the movie theater [ __ ]
that's to everyone
[Music]
listen to me okay your mother needs to
manage her weight or there can be some
real problems
yo mama is so fat she need a latitude
and longitude number to fight her old
ass
[Applause]
who's the doctor I Am the Doctor Mr
Lewis I am and it is my job to make sure
that your mother is getting the care
that she needs we are talking about the
woman who took care of you your whole
life the least you can do is take care
of her in her old age and take this
seriously
I'm sorry I'm sorry that I lost my
temper
no really doctor
I guess I was just joking around because
I know her condition is really serious
and
I don't know I guess Huber is the only
way I could really deal with it uh
I just know that she says so many times
she doesn't want anything invasive died
really
I was not aware of that that's
interesting because she did not mention
that to me in our previous conversation
because
it was difficult to hear her with my
dick in her mouth
snap Mr Lewis
oh snap
now let's talk about the procedure
[Applause]
hey uh forgot to tell you
congratulations on getting the new job
oh thanks man appreciate it I appreciate
it yeah and thank you for inviting me
over here to the game today oh no
probably appreciate it you're my best
friend wow thanks man hey you know what
you're my best friend too cool yeah yeah
wrote a song about it
not gonna sing it or anything because
that would be gay that's pretty gay all
right I'll give it a shot
Wally you're my best friend
together we can change the world
I've been together through thick and
thin playing ball and talking to girls
Wally I'm so proud of you
you know you're taking all the my advice
wait stop stop stop stop stop what
advice oh um
it's it's just a song dude I mean like
can I finish and then we can oh okay
you've done everything I've asked of you
and you never ever questioned twice what
are you talking about thank you for
doing what I told you to
your achievements are all so mine
living your life living your life
living your life to my desire
that was the weirdest song I've ever
heard in my life you have listened to
your elders I'm older they never forget
the words I say I'm not don't like your
songs
no I'm not I have shown you the way
except for
except for the heavens
guys just curves Through The Plains of
the Caribou shut up
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the team Mr wise thank you
now being an Arizona assistant State's
Attorney is an important job one we take
very seriously in fact we are willing to
do anything to win it's my honor sir and
I look forward to serving the State of
Arizona are these marbles how's that
it's just admiring your container of
marbles
why yes
my wife got them for me as a gift
for my birthday
which brings me to a speech where I like
to give anyone on their first day here
at the state's attorney office of
Arizona
you see
Lady Justice is a committed woman she's
a slippery little scallop as you can
observe
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what is going on
what what are you doing
oh uh
marbles they're just I I gotta tell you
they're just so beautiful that I was
wondering what it would feel like in my
mouth like what would the marbles feel
like if they were in my mouth
that's you know
what
you know you know like just what would
it feel like if they were just kind of a
whole ton of marbles in my in my face
well don't do that
just
just don't do that yeah yeah of course
of course
why why what am I doing over here I mean
that's that's the thing that a child
would do you know you were saying
I was saying that lady Justice just
stands there in my office
looking at me
[Music]
forget the marbles boy
spit the marbles out please
there you go
well
all right
how many
really
do you have any
I'm gonna wait for the last
I'm assuming this yeah
I know there's another one in there
yep all right
I am I'm they're just so beautiful I
can't it's just these marbles I gotta
tell you you obviously don't take this
job here seriously sir it's just these
particular marbles I just needed to feel
what they felt like in my mouth I don't
know what is wrong with me no we do
serious business here right yes I do
know that I'm 100 aware of that yeah
because I've forgotten where I was you
were saying the justice is a dumb blind
old lady I heard everything yes no she's
not dumb
well she is blind
she's reminiscent of uh Kerry Washington
[Music]
good job
[Music]
[Applause]
it oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Janice
[Music]
sending the cleanup crew
another one fell for the marble trick
[Music]
[Applause]
okay guys
Gremlins 2.
I'm telling you this movie
should write itself the first one was a
classic this should be pretty
straightforward basically all we're
doing is maintaining the Integrity of
the original picture we want to do all
the stuff with the water
and the
uh can we help you I'm sorry
let me introduce myself hi y'all my name
is star magic Jackson Jr I'm the
Hollywood sequel doctor so studio just
brings me into oversee things when
they're about to drop a deuce so that's
why I'm here but don't mind me I'm just
going to be over here y'all do your
thing it's your movie
okay
uh let's brainstorm
Adam uh if it's going to take place in
an office building I was thinking what
if Gizmo gets wet from a water cooler
this time okay hold on on a second
I'm sorry I'm gonna have to step in here
just one second sweetheart so what's
wrong with y'all
y'all looking like a bunch of side sacks
this is G2 people we write in Gremlins
too it should be a party with pizza and
amps office pineapple just come on lift
up the spirits look okay I'm gonna put a
little bit of spice into the mixture
here what if we did this everybody here
gets to design their own Gremlin
um I don't see that the uh the gremlin
design is broken it's called
brainstorming I'm brain drizzling Sweet
Pea okay shut your mouth for a second
look here's the thing none of this is
finals so you mean like what if there
was like a brainy Grandma a brainy
Gremlin you talking about a gremlin wear
glasses who could talk and sing New York
New York that's brilliant it's in the
movie done
whoa whoa you said that nothing was
Final that was before I heard the words
brainy and Gremlin in the same sentence
together it's done I love it it's in the
movie Next
what about a uh Spider Gremlin you mean
a gremlin with eight legs and the four
racks just catching pretty ladies in a
web in an office building oh my God it's
in the movie I love it next what about a
bat gremlin
you mean a gremlin with leathery Wings
just flying around flip-flopping bust
through a wall make a perfect bat symbol
in the wall get outside get in some wet
concrete jump up on a building to just
dry in place like a gargoyle where
everything we are cooking with gas now I
love it it's in the movie Next
could there be a female gremlin
snipstick boobies [ __ ] you have me and
little Gremlin but JJ I love it so much
that it's not only in the movie but it's
definitely in the movie there's no
backseats on that one no Penny taxi yes
yes yes in the movie Dawn that's why we
need a woman in the writer's room next I
don't know
googly-eyed gremlin
you talking about a gremlin whose sole
purpose in this film is just that he
looks stupid as [ __ ] yes it can be in
the movie and it is in the movie done
next what about you Silver Fox oh
electricity Gremlin you just said noun
and Gremlin like you playing Mad Libs
you just like a child you have the brain
of a child you do not have a high IQ but
you haphazard who came up with a
gremliness is made out of bolts that are
zigzagging all over the room and it's
done completely in animation you a crazy
person and your ideas in the movie done
next can we put the hulkster in it what
yeah
[Music]
you talking about putting Hulk Hogan
professional wrestler turned actor
turned cultural icon in the movie where
he break the fourth wall of the movie
he's in by talking to the audience you
sir
that's it I don't even care anymore we
got the holster in this [ __ ] so it's
done I don't have any more time so let
me just recap right now it's raining
Gremlin spider Gremlin back Gremlin lady
gremlin Google that Gremlin electricity
Gremlin Hulk Hogan's gonna be an
adventure imma throw in a grandma myself
vegetable Gremlin just write it up I'm
having so much fun thank you it's all
gonna be in the actual film now I gotta
go put some cowboys and Back To The
Future Three sayonara y'all
[Music]
no okay you guys know that none of that
is gonna be in the actual movie
[Music]
I'm going to the bathroom okay
excuse me
excuse me
excuse me
excuse me
and excuse me
foreign
[Music]
where are you
you sh I'm looking for my boyfriend
I'm doing it right now dude me again
I'm searching you
Andre
Megan
Andre Megan come here Andre
Megan Andre
a go back to where you were before
Siri call Andre
a
what is wrong with you
where are you I'm fine will you FaceTime
me I'm not gonna do it right now
you were looking dark again I know
that's what I can't find you
have to turn around okay I'm gonna turn
around
I need to announce it just do it I'm
right there [ __ ]
[ __ ] stop yelling at me you can have you
sustained ahead of dream or had a stroke
in the last 10 minutes what do you mean
by that me can Dude put your phone away
yep OMG did you just hang up on me yes
I'm not talking to you sir I'm talking
to my boyfriend it's me Megan
get off me Mr director she's not the
director can you shine this light on the
audience I want to see my boyfriend let
me see something
yeah
don't stress me
your name
excuse me
excuse me and
usually
[Music]
I couldn't find the bathroom
excuse me I think we're ready to order
well
um I'm sorry that's not how things work
in this establishment someone will come
to you yes we're sorry no problem
what was that what well where was black
Jeff black Jeff what yeah
black Jeff
I read somewhere that when you dated
biracial guy you're supposed to get the
best of both worlds so there are white
Jeff situations and there are blackjev
situations and that was definitely a
black Jeff situation oh okay okay hi
folks I'm so sorry for the wait can I
get you bottled or tap water for the
table this evening how about I bottle
your ass and kick it down the stairs man
we've been waiting half an hour for one
of you mother
God I'm so I'm so sorry I'll get you a
bottle of our finest Premium Water on
the house that's what I said [ __ ] what
are you doing black Jeff that was black
Jeff but he was just trying to help us
oh so white white Jeff yeah
um
good evening I'm sorry to bother you too
I am the Mater D here at Trey honoree oh
yes uh what is it
I am so sorry to disturb you both but
our establishment has a certain dress
code and madame's um decolletage is
inappropriate oh my God we're we're very
sorry we didn't know there was a dress
code we'll certainly remember for the
next time but they ain't gonna be no
next time for you looking at my woman
and her her Deco choco Chocolat or
whatever you said man is there a problem
here okay see it was really a simple
misunderstanding it all started with
that [ __ ] right there was
disrespecting myself and my girl but we
really love this guy and he gave us
exceptional assertions we're gonna have
to ask you to leave you have to ask me
to leave oh you have to ask the black
man to leave huh actually you don't have
to ask us to leave I just want to see
ourselves out and we ain't never coming
back again though we really appreciate
your help that's it
what's your ass man let us reimburse you
for that breakage okay right after I'll
burn this whole place with a
[ __ ] around with everybody out
of it by which I mean you're going to
get a very negative review on Yelp
welcome back to the Morty Jepson show
I'm Marty Jepson we're here today
continuing our conversation with
unbelievable Mega Superstar young
business
now young business I gotta tell you
we've been tiptoeing around a particular
subject all day and I think it's time to
Broach it
you've separated recently with your your
actress girlfriend Tina bouquet no and
everybody wants to know more we ain't
going to talk about that I'm not here to
talk about that I just want to hear your
side of the story you don't want to use
money I told y'all [ __ ]
and lots of people understand that
you're talking about more experiences
more fans would like to know how what's
going on with you
I want to hear your side of the story
how about that yeah
done there's no need for the interview
to be open interviews over young [ __ ]
yeah all y'all [ __ ] young
business is no need for the language or
any of this we can just I told you our
[ __ ] wasn't going to talk about
that do you want to talk about the album
because I'll be more than happy to talk
about the album this is the c word more
it looks like it's well on its way to
going platinum or CD as it will the [ __ ]
away from Lewis Lewis
go well on its way to going Platinum we
can talk about this it's kind of a
double album when you say in here if
it's fine with me you want to talk about
the album we're talking about the um how
about the tanks of Truth tanks of Truth
is that A Treatise on the uh the
conflict of Isis I mean when it would
talk to me about this what
young business please sit down take a
deep breath and let's discuss no let's
discuss the album it's done Mark it's
done
I'm sorry
young business I would really love it if
you had a seat and we could just talk
together about anything anything you
want we don't I won't mention Tina's
name again young goodness
youthful Commerce how does where does it
go to Louis help
no get the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] off me
Louis Louis go leave it be exacerbating
the situation this [ __ ] attached to
why is it
if you let go of it
make it in there don't get in it don't
see trying to get around don't step on
my
desk 1500
why do we have black cords and a black
carpet all right well you [ __ ] I
told y'all
I wasn't gonna let Louis I swear to
[ __ ] God we're gonna take care of it
now you got my wife
don't you ain't
coffee
can I may I help you don't touch the
jacket I'm sorry I'm sorry okay just
raise your raise your knees right here
you gotta get now hold on I got poseidus
but here here's what we know okay have a
seat here put your family don't say
Fanny don't all right how do you do you
do it well you do this every don't you
ain't taking the pants off Nicole God
damn it where is Jerry this is some [ __ ]
right here same sound guy for 2017. all
right all right all right all right take
all right Lewis Lewis
hold that don't do anything but hold
that
okay no no you gotta put no [ __ ] you
gotta take the no you can't take the
pants off over the shoes you can't
you can't Lewis Lewis get your white ass
out the [ __ ] you ain't helping
nobody
all right all right I'm taking the shoes
off okay left one first
all right well [ __ ] do whatever you [ __ ]
you want then [ __ ] that's fine
thank you one
two thank you I told y'all I wasn't
gonna talk about that [ __ ]
I'll be right back with Alec Baldwin
don't that's a waste of money dog I
don't even understand how that's even in
the horror genre dog I mean that's the
least scared I've ever been man it's
like a like a romantic comedy it's like
a lullaby dog yeah for reals dog oh oh
where you parked at Ohana where are you
parked right yeah I'm all that way boy
are you all the way down there yeah well
I'm this way all right all right dog all
right
you know what I'm gonna say I'll walk
you to your car
yeah then I'll drive you back to your
car [ __ ]
a man's move me man a demon can possess
any inanimate object that's too General
to be scary I mean it's like how you
gonna have a demon posted up in a trash
can I mean you know it don't make no
sense
it's stupid it's stupid it's unrealistic
it's what it is it's like I ain't gonna
be scared of no trash can
yeah and then what was that other thing
they had with the uh the uh the demon
puddle oh yeah yeah that was the most
stupid part right there a demon could
pull you into hell if you step in a
puddle like we some morons I mean how
you gonna scare a couple adults with a
puddle stupid
and the demon got them hellhounds
roaming around everywhere bringing
humans to the demon alive to be
sacrificed
stupid yeah you know it's like it's lazy
storytelling yes yes it's what it is
it's a lot of things but scary is not
one of them
creepy kids in the whispering and
whatnot come on you just identified like
the stupidest part of the movie
and kids and Kids was talking about
so I will suck your asses okay yeah
let's do it right there you can stop
right now man please stop
cause it's stupid it was stupid as
stupid as hell it was stupid it's your
car it's me doing it yeah
yeah I hope uh there's not one of them
demons possessing your car
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
movie man you know that's how we go
that's how we're going
this is not just another streaming app
what this is so much comedy it's not
even funny are you choking me bro this
is daily late and lately this is real
roasted and raw give it to me now this
is great stand-up great movies and the
great cornholio are you threatening me
no this is one pump two pumps and three
pumps this is live sports breaking news
and a mountain of Comedy entertainment
Paramount plus now streaming
[Music]
oh yeah good victory guys good victory
hey hey come on good game slap ass man
hey good Game Stop ass yeah guys Reyes
man good games
[Applause]
hey who's next who hey Garcia come on
man get your thumb come on let's get
some slap ass over here nope
why why not
I said no Rafi he said enough Rafi
we've all had enough
of why enough of the damn ass slapping
fluffy
gracias
okay see yes
hi who [ __ ] cares how much I slap ass
so why that's not bad what's the deal
man I'm a [ __ ] baseball player that's
what we do we hit home runs and Slap Ass
come on huh Rafi that's not how we all
see baseball everybody does it all the
teams for that bad man if yo yeah you
slap ass Garcia like a couple of times a
game
I thought what man why the economy man
who knows how many times I forgot bass
or 427 times
okay time flies when you're having fun
man why our families come to these games
Rafi
my son is always asking me why letting
this man touch my butt so many times and
you say slap ass every time every time
okay hold on one second let's go to the
timeout
I'm from the Dominican Republic okay
all I know
since I was a little kid
is to catch fly balls and to say slap
ass every single time
Dominican Republic
nobody here has ever heard anyone say
slap ass
before you
quit playing man come on get yourself
ass okay
[Music]
okay
you right
I know you write about it
I have a problem okay
I know that
and I decided to stop right now when
gracias
but after I get that Garcia Slap Ass
come on
[Applause]
hey
come on yeah I'm fine all right fine I
get it
yeah
[Music]
do I not get it
hey Garcia man can I talk to you for a
second oh hold on hey Rafi what's up oh
man I just talked to the manager man
he thinks he's going to trade me man I
mean what the hell you know I got kids
too right here yeah but we all told you
what was going to happen if you hey
I really could use that at one Slap Ass
Man Rafi come on man just one Slap Ass
you know just one just for Old Times
Sake you know
get me back on my feet I mean just one
for the road man I could really use it
okay okay
good game slappy
I gotta get home to my kids
I [ __ ] you if you let me slap your ass
again
[Music]
[Music]
so uh your office is all the way down at
the end you have your own attached
bathroom by the way oh um here's one of
our best researchers dick hey
oh hello there
what's up dude glad to see there's
another brother in this stuffing place
so
um this is um going to be your assistant
Genevieve Genevieve um what is this The
Shining man all black people have the
shine you never shine with another black
person before no I grew up in a white
neighborhood and then went to Darkness
I've met other black people before but
not like this you got to get shined at
by another black person first and then
you get it it's kind of like Facebook
thank you
what up dudes
so every black person has this is Kobe
listening yo what up wow Denzel
Washington I'm here I'm present and I
will always be around Little John
excuse me little John welcome Ray
glad to have you on board oh
what's up Barack Obama
wouldn't that be something that Barack
Obama just showed up
your startup paperwork's right over here
man you got to be more careful learn to
use the shine tune in and out of it
otherwise you won't be able to sort out
who's talking [ __ ]
[Music]
is everything okay
right
listen for Morgan
Morgan Freeman he will guide you listen
to my voice right
now just stay calm and focus on that
white man
everything's going to be okay once you
finish up this paperwork bring it to
Jennifer my office
now
The Kill
that white man
I just finished episode four okay so the
Lannisters are the blonde people and the
female Lannister is married to Robert of
baranthian who is the king is it
baranthian or Baratheon right right and
then the other blonde girl
is the um
can I get you something oh uh I don't
know um three Kamikaze shots whatever
I can't believe he just did that what's
that served me before you guys I'm
really against that I'm so sorry that's
okay we uh we've got beers no I mean I'm
sorry about
everything well it's fine no no it's
been a hundred years of not fine I mean
20 years ago you guys wouldn't have even
been allowed in here 20 years that would
be 1992.
it was really beautiful
oh and said she's done that just
happened didn't it yeah oh amazing so
I'll go with the Lannisters okay the
she's the queen Jamie Lannister is the
other one Jamie yo yo what up man hey
give me another lager about me yeah I
spilled my last one on my tribe shirt
you believe that
but whatevs got this thing in 93
Midnight Marauders tour check that out
it's everywhere oh man hey uh who's your
favorite member of tribe
smoke smoke these no man yeah love him
dude I'm more behind the scenes but he
was like
all right good see you guys around
though cool okay one more one more one
more Come On Son boom
all right they always spun he's spun
second person to not wait for their
drink by the way yep okay let me ask you
this then
um what what's what's with the Barbarian
dude who looks like a huge Dave Navarro
okay it's that guy
oh I need a drink I just finished
Amistad I saw it three times and I'll
see you 100 more times because like I'm
happy to do it if that's what those guys
went through I'm happy to sit through it
you know 300 more times or whatever you
know it takes yeah it's it's a it's
pretty intense I see my thing is it's
like I don't think one person should own
another person
period I'm glad that that's what you
guys yes I mean I don't care when it
happened all right it should never
happen it should never occur but like
I'm preaching to the choir you guys know
what I'm talking about yeah I'm like
it's like why did anybody even do that
I'm like no you didn't no you didn't
what you doing girl man now you didn't
I'm ashamed you know what it's it's
really probably okay because you weren't
there okay well we can come up with
excuses all day all day
let's just not do that let's
hey bottom line we cool right yeah all
right yeah we're cool we're kicking a
cow yes what's that
nothing I didn't
all right four more years
hey if it makes you guys feel any better
A lot of people make me really
uncomfortable
Q
[Music]
oh well [ __ ] Mexican oh man do not
get me started on the Mexicans hey
I'll just say it
they hold the goddamn economy together
you know
damn straight if 12 of the Mexicans live
in this country stop working just 12
percent
damn I don't even care who hears me no
they they they they they work their
asses off and they got strong family
values essential immigrants hey speaking
of immigrants how about damn Asians [ __ ]
you know what brother you want to like
that foods and you better stand back
cause I got something I want to say
about those [ __ ] I got three
words for you it's studious hard-working
industrious damn straight Asians are the
highest income best educated and the
fastest growing racial group in the US
today plus got the highest percentage of
college graduates in the country good
for them and maybe this makes me sound
racist but those [ __ ]
They're Gonna Save the country there it
is you said you went and said it I just
said I just came right the [ __ ] out and
said it he was in everyone's mind but
I'm the one who said it hey and you know
what while we're at it I'm gonna break
my spine tip tap dancing Ransom prancing
around the elephant in the room blacks
[ __ ] blacks
[ __ ] blacks you know what you're done
doing dead you opened up the blood Gates
now my friend release the Kraken goddamn
victims the institutionalized racing
isn't it
[Applause]
they overcame the slavery and the
segregation just to become CEOs
and entrepreneurs hey one of them got
starring president and I mean that's
just true right there that's this
historical fact man can't even argue
that
oh how about the Indians [ __ ] Native
Americans
I don't know if I could get in trouble
these days for saying something like
this but they were here first it may be
unpopular but it's true we we came to
this country and we steamrolled on in
and we genocided them I mean hell we owe
them something there you go
I got to tell you man that's not bad for
a non-alcoholic beer not bad at all all
right I gotta go home take care of my
kids how many of them you got now just
adopted to the 11th oh can't help myself
man that's always what happens when you
volunteer for the earthquake relief in
Haiti
and with your boots gonna do you know my
wife makes two-thirds of what I mean
what y'all got the same job man that's
just patently unfair that's right we're
both Librarians nerves you all right I'm
okay
I said it right there I was like man's
like I was like you a woman I'm a man
that's a difference oh what
they bumping [ __ ] up in here here it
is it's going off yo hey
which one are y'all [ __ ]
I did
[ __ ] you gonna do it
oh I'll tell you what I'm gonna do about
it
oh yeah yeah what you lucky my friends
told me you lucky cause I'll take your
hat off don't hold me back do it don't
hold me back oh okay then don't worry
see I know though if I were to Lunge at
you right now my friend right here he
catch me at the last possible second no
no no I won't
foreign
but my friend does have the cognizance
to tell me I don't need to be going up
and committing capital murder up in a
club tonight oh no just knock him
unconscious Dog Bail
don't want to kill anybody no need for
that successful
let me finish my sentence sir
I will
uh oh snap you know what
you lucky my boys using his telekinetic
powers to hold me back right now no I'm
not well maybe
it's the type of telekinesis that's a
mutant power that you didn't realize you
had until the moment it started oh oh I
got it I see I see so you want me to
hold you
oh I'm a dragon oh oh yeah I don't want
to rip this I'm a lion I'm a tiger over
here I'm a bear oh my oh I go crazy on
you oh I can't believe it man he's like
he's like a tornado over here throwing
me back I can't even believe I can hold
it back don't even do it man can't
believe I'm this strong let me go look
at this house I'm one arm in it I can't
believe I'm this strong let me talk to
this man I'm gonna hold it back with one
finger he's like a little baby he can't
get past me he's like a little owl what
man with you I'm a little baby I'm
holding you back man this is stupid man
I got carried away I apologize which
means you gotta carried away you told me
hold you back I was holding you back
what do you want me to do in a fight
situation new means no and yes means yes
oh wait come on man ow come on that
hurts and you holding me back now thank
you very much for that okay we'll just
at least change it up oh okay now you
listen
[Music]
good evening my fellow Americans now
before I begin
I just want to say that I know a lot of
people out there seem to think that I
don't get angry
that's just not true I get angry a lot
it's just that the way I express passion
is different from most
so just so there's no more confusion
we've hired Luther here to be my anger
translator Luther
first off concerning the recent
developments in the Middle Eastern
region I just want to reiterate our
unflinching support for all people and
their right to a democratic process hey
all y'all dictators out there keep
messing around and see what happens just
see what happens watch also to the
governments of Iran and North Korea
we once again urge you to discontinue
your uranium enrichment program hey
Mahmoud Kim Jong I think golden Untold
both y'all 86 [ __ ] almost come over
there and do it for y'all please test me
and see what happens on the domestic
front
I just want to say to my critics I hear
your voices and I'm aware of your
concerns so maybe you can chill the hell
out like a like us then maybe I could
not goes for everybody
including members of the t-ball don't
even get me started on these
[ __ ] right here I want to
assure you that we will be looking for
new compromises with the GOP and
LaMontagne you know these mothers gonna
say no before I even see Jessica now I
know a lot of folks say that I haven't
done a good job at communicating my
accomplishments to the public
don't listen
uh since being in office we've created
three million new jobs 3 million new
jobs we ended the war in Iraq
remember that these achievements should
serve as a reminder that I am on your
side I am
not and that my intentions as your
president are coming from the right
place they're coming from Hawaii which
is where I'm from which is in the United
States of America y'all okay this is
ridiculous I have a birth certificate I
have a birth certificate I have a hot
diggity Mama say Mama saw a birth
certificate you dumbass crackers okay
Luther yeah yeah dial it back Luther
damn in conclusion uh last night I had a
conversation with Michelle
nope I did not say that I did not say
that
good evening my fellow Americans now
before we begin I'd like to once again
introduce you to my anger translator
Luther hi
now this November I want each and every
one of you to ask yourselves what has
changed in the last four years who
killed Osama Bin Laden
what does my Administration accomplished
did we accomplish killing America's
biggest enemy uh check did that boom in
2011 alone we created more jobs than
George W bush did in all eight years of
his office except Osama Bin Laden Hunter
because that job don't exist anymore
cause I went over there and I killed him
in his face we helped make Health Care
accessible to more Americans than ever
before I'm sorry what'd you say uh Your
World Trade Center hurts then why don't
you take two dead bin ladens and call me
in the morning [ __ ]
this election make the decision that you
think best serves the future of this
country or you can eat a dum-dum
sandwich and just vote for the person
who didn't kill Osama Bin Laden why
would you do it why would you do it
I plan to run a Clean Campaign one based
on the issues and the accomplishments of
my Administration but I'm going to tell
you right now if the Republicans if they
get caught Osama Bin Laden they wouldn't
even pay him actually man they just put
a crown on his head and give him a
castle and his time became America
Anatomy I said
yeah all right all right all right just
you know bring it down a notch there
come on Luther menu straight up out of
control brother well uh it's not that
bad okay don't beat yourself up it's
okay excuse me can a [ __ ] get a license
you can't say that word
oh actually it says right here I can say
it whenever I want
I guess I can say it too
good night
my [ __ ]
[Music]
with me as always is my anger translator
Luther what did it do oh as you know for
the past six years
I've received my fair share of criticism
from the Republican party I can't even
give Malia an allowance without them
accusing me of wealth redistribution
it's all part of rough and tumble
politics I hate you
in recent years I've also received a
good amount of criticism from my fellow
Democrats
right here I must oh
now I know
the right to express one's opinion about
the powers that be is the very thing
that makes this country great it's like
I ain't got enough to do we got a James
Bond building run in Russia I got a
congress full of tea baggers the Earth
is burning up and now I gotta deal with
all these whiny ass [ __ ] from our
old party
some have cited my inability to make
good on my campaign promise to uh
close Guantanamo Bay Tyler shut me down
I'm a president y'all I'm a president
not a king they checked and balanced my
ass I mean God damn
and then there are those on the left who
have criticized my continued usage of
drone strikes you know what y'all can't
have it both ways man what do you want
you can't have the soldiers coming home
hugging the moms and then also at the
same time have me killing with in the
caves it's like y'all should be
embracing this technology because it's
pretty amazing man it's awesome all you
do is pick up the phone say excuse me I
like to order two dead terrorists
it's amazing I mean we can murder people
we're flying around us well first it's
like we're in Star Wars World dog and
I'm Darth Vader for this [ __ ]
[Music]
what is wrong in your head why would you
compare the president to one of the
Lords of the Sith
thank you and good night
good evening my fellow Americans I just
want to thank you for your continued
faith and my ability
that's my anger translator Luther wow
yeah what's up
but I want to wish my opponent Mitt
Romney well he ran a good campaign
Now we move forward with pressing issues
we're going to pass Healthcare again now
what [ __ ] while we had huge turnout
from our faithful supporters thank you
black folks we made it to two elections
in
all your votes were crucial in this
Victory why people who voted for me
you're all now honor every black people
so thank you for your support and [ __ ]
you if you tried to [ __ ] me I mean how
much money they tried to spend to get
rid of this million son I said millions
but you couldn't get rid of it oh no
yeah
Luther what I tell you no Hammer dancing
I don't want you doing it wrong you got
to get it right if you're gonna do it
God bless America
now I told you homeboy you can't touch
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
forgive me Tommy
I can't believe the zombies
it wasn't a zombie
zombies raccoons right
loads of zombies
oh you just killed Tommy
let's go for your boy
don't you put your hands away
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
your whole mouth smells like an open
eyes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
penis
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
and now we have a special treat hold on
to your yamakas okay from east to west
you know they're the best getting you in
the zone for your Milestone is that cute
please welcome gavilta fresh and Dr
dreidels
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
when you see black people at a bar mitzv
it's very exciting it's like a scary
ride and the kids just love it right now
we are the number one bar slash Bob
Mitch for party motivators and all in
Nassau County I mean you got the bot
missiles yeah always to men you know all
of them coming through like a village
with the Recycled dress and I mean the
husband of these guys with the cocktail
stick it's it's a real Shonda what it's
supposed to be Simka yeah yeah it's
supposed to be a Simcoe
just really can't put a price on the
look on your child's face when they see
a black person for the first time
that's just magical really
is he getting back up or what we are not
technically chosen we're chosen by the
choseness and which is kind of better
than being just the chosen it's right
it's less responsibility Jews are like
black people but we were black people
before there were black people
um although I guess that's not true they
were just in a different part of the
world they're all black people coming to
get me help
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
but I'm spiritually intoxicating
you find it culturally fascinating
and we find it monetarily exhilarated
when we say Sarah you say schwartzman's
I mean the fact that we're willing to
put forth the extra time is what sets us
apart I mean how often is a 13 year old
gonna hear their own name
we learned that name
we rehearse it
[Applause]
Judaism can be a very somber religion
that's right you know something we
learned along the way is that the word
ghetto
means something very different to these
people
if I was a little nervous about the
whole thing and no not because they were
black but
because you never really know what those
kind of people are going to do
if we can have some fun some life some
color to a Jewish person's life when
they're still young they might not grow
up and run away from black people when
they see them maybe they won't or uh
fire people so willy-nilly
when they're older
we provide a service to these people
parties
that's what we do
that's what we do we motivate parties
[Music]
let's get this party started
ladies and gentlemen this is Paramount
Plus
Strokes of Genius beautiful games and
One Shining Moments this is Defenders
investigators and seven strangers picked
to live in a house this is Young
SpongeBob young Sheldon and the younger
this is everything you've been looking
for it's gonna leave a mark live sports
breaking news and a mountain of
entertainment all right this is
Paramount plus now streaming
hello you must be detective Hobbs
I am your new partner Joshua Tay
um
what you know uh your last partner uh
detective Jimenez I never met him but I
hear he he left some pretty big shoes to
fill let's get one thing straight
You're Never Gonna Fill him in as his
shoes
ever
Menace was a good man
better cop
Philly Menace his shoes the tip of your
dick couldn't fill a bottle cap
I I'm I'm very sorry if that came out
wrong I'm sure Jimenez was a great cop
the best
so these uh prostitute murders
um
seems like a serial killer could be I
actually worked out a theory I don't
give a Hobo's hat about your theory you
think Jimenez worked off a theories like
some kind of a needle dick Charles
Darwin not on your ass
and men has always shot straight from
the dick
you think you're a menace absolutely not
you're goddamn right should not
Jimenez with a busted 20 perks in the
time would take you to pull up your
pants over your itsy bitsy teeny weeny
yellow polka dot the pee pee
daughters raising them on his own you
want that job huh
Mr baby dick
you want to be there daddy no you know
what I think I think we got off on the
wrong foot 90 minutes oh Jimenez got off
on the right foot every goddamn day of
his goddamn life
just more than I can say for your Pebble
penis have an ass
wannabe I can assure you I don't want to
be a minute why not what's wrong with
him there's nothing wrong with him then
why wouldn't you want to be like I don't
know you said [ __ ] okay I'm out
I can't I can't make this work
Amanda is what I made it work
[Music]
come back from Florida so many minutes
[Music]
hey as far as I'm concerned this
Saturday night this is not even gonna be
a fight I'm on mercy kill this old man
but soon he will learn Madness
I will torture his body
so that his soul learns to be humble I'm
gonna dance around him while he tried to
hit me with his Cane oh man
God trust me for this fight
God is the teacher Derek is the student
and I am God's instrument
when I squeeze your lungs static and you
beg me for life
then your heart will open up to the Lord
I'm going to knock him out round one
[ __ ]
wait
what do you saying
that God chose him
that's a
doesn't even make sense really
when you eat through plastic too
when you are paralyzed from neck down
your family
will gather around your hospital bed
to sit in Newton
okay he know we just talking here right
I mean we just we just getting people
interested in the fight because I'm I'm
sorry is this so crazy
lessons
lessons are so beautiful
[Music]
guys lessons are beautiful I'm sorry who
put this fight together this is the well
how I do if y'all got an actual crazy
person to meet for me to fight well
that's not fair to me or him
[Music]
you can't find it
but where is he
yo man where my manager at Steve how's
it
[Music]
[Music]
oh
every American woman is more Infidel
than the last time
okay come on full frontal face only in
America
this is yours
what did you see
there's some foreign
[Music]
here we go here we go
little bully would you look at the leg
elbows on that one
two four six seconds
that's very important my friend I could
believe it another woman before I
thought it was a me yes she's like the
butthole of the belly
[Music]
oh what I wouldn't do it
show me show me
I'm sorry
come on
I owe you the world come on Shining
simmering Splendid don't do that close
your eyes yes princess yes
homosexual and American Devils give them
the whistle of disapproval I will right
now
that is my boy huh
[Music]
there's a lie and it shines within the
darkness of the sands of time
but the battle to be one is with the man
inside a man of God
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let the music in your heart give way to
the things that you believe
[Music]
is
[Music]
and the thing is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
exactly
[Music]
it's within the rhythms I believe
power
of wings
free at last free at last thank God
Almighty we are free at last
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome your
next speaker the Reverend Robert Jones
[Applause]
how am I supposed to follow that
can't nobody can follow that
house
oh
all right
good afternoon
um
that that is the the best speech I've
ever heard in my entire life
ever
I have never heard a better speech
and now it is my turn to speak
huh
we put this running order together right
you know um Dr King
he actually covered a lot a lot of what
I was gonna say
um you know my speech is uh uh you're
gonna find this funny y'all my speech
was actually called a vision for the
future I'm not saying that Dr King
copied my speech I'm
no no I'm I'm saying I'm not saying that
I'm not saying he tried to copy it once
I listen to what I'm
wow you know what no come on I'm just
saying I'm just saying I'm just saying
it's a joke did I not say it like a joke
okay
nope
[Music]
apparently I have six more minutes
let's see a red Red Hills of Georgia he
got that out there
okay you know what all right here here's
something here's something new here's
something brand new how okay this is off
me talking off the top of my head here
everybody uh why how about if we let uh
black people enslave white people for
okay you know that sounded a lot better
in my head before I said it
so that's a
that wouldn't work
is it warm
is anybody else warm
[Applause]
oh
okay okay okay here's what we're gonna
do here's what we're gonna do all right
Dr King talked about
um uh all the races coming together
right right so when I want every negro
to do here today is find the nearest
white person and give him a hug just
just give him a hug okay nope sir you're
not being attacked you're not being
attacked you're being hooked okay
everybody take it easy here okay
everybody relax you know what we don't
need 10 Negroes hugging one white person
okay let's just Let's YO that's the new
rule not 10 on one one-on-ones would it
take turns and everything okay so
everybody relax okay oh my goodness sir
she doesn't need to be defended she
doesn't need to be better she's okay
she's okay okay all right
oh come on
[Music]
then you're going to raise party
yeah I'm going you know Amy's gonna be
there
yeah I know things have been real good
with her man tonight could be the night
could be
dude you okay
not really dude what's wrong you're the
hottest girl at a party with no parents
you're definitely gonna hit that for
sure tonight man You're Gonna Lose That
V for good my penis is white
excuse me
I have a white penis what but you're
black
uh
I'm biracial
all the way went straight to my penis
what what you mean like like the the
color
oh
yeah but wait dude I mean
how bad could it be it's bad
how bad it's like a Snickers regular
refund size
which one do you get at Halloween
a fun size that's the one
I know
what am I gonna do I mean I
how am I gonna hit it with Amy with my
little white peanuts everyone's gonna
find out and I'm never gonna hear the
end of it Amy's White
she's not gonna care
really yeah
she's white yeah
it's right she's probably not even gonna
know difference oh man oh man white girl
white penis you're all good
[Music]
[Applause]
there he is how'd it go last night don't
want to talk about it well what happened
black vagina
folks I have a simple philosophy
that government should work for everyone
not just the elite
and that's why I helped pass the farm
bill
because I care about farmers
but I won't stop there
I will work for everyone
whether you are
Young
whether you are old whether you are
Asian Or Hispanic whether you are
straight or whether you are gay
I will work for all of you
and that's why I also support marriage
equality
folks don't choose to be gay
any more than I choose to be straight
could you imagine if someone told you
that you couldn't marry the person that
you loved
I'm sorry I think gays are people too
gays are not different
gays
they are just like us
they love
they fear
they raise their children they strive
for a better life
but there are those
who believe that being gay is an
abomination
that's absurd
the homosexual community
is a valuable community
in this country
they are doctors
they are lawyers
they are teachers
they are me
and they are you
and their contributions are no less
important
than any other group in this fine nation
of ours
so
turn to that gay person
near you
and see that they are no different than
you are
thank you
that's okay
this is not just another streaming app
what this is so much comedy it's not
even funny are you choking me bro this
is daily late and lately this is real
roasted and raw give it to me now this
is great stand-up great movies and the
great cornholio are you threatening me
no this is one pump two pumps and three
pumps this is live sports breaking news
and a mountain of Comedy entertainment
Paramount plus now streaming
foreign
[Applause]
you guys got bow and arrows yeah
oh yeah oh that's it yeah there it is
there that'll do it that's gonna do it
yep where the arrows at
yeah you guys got admitty's we don't
carry fireworks damn you have uh you
have something else that's explosive
that I could tape to the end of an arrow
we have shotgun shells but I feel I have
to ask are you planning to attach those
to arrows and use them as a weapon what
no what are you crazy
you think that would work though
what if I shot to explosive arrows to a
window to break them open
sir I feel like I have to ask you what
you're planning to use these for hold on
I'm not planning to do anything I'm just
just Christmas shopping you got zip
lines nope you got like Hooks and
anchors and cables we got some of those
things but I do not recommend
manufacturing your own zip line oh I'm
not doing that no
let's say somebody was manufacturing
their own zip line do you think if they
had busted some windows open on a
building somehow then fired the zip line
off a bow and arrow and it attached to
the wall of said building that they
could just ride there's a blind into the
building
I have no idea sir whatever you're
planning on doing please don't do it I'm
not I'm not doing anything I'm just
doing some Christmas shopping I'm trying
to get it out of the way you know bow
and arrows from her nephew the zip lines
for my
grandmother
Etc and whatnot you know what I'm saying
there it's nothing no big deal speaking
of other things do you guys have just
the top half of a knight in armor
first of all it's called the suit of
armor oh yep that's it that's right
that's what I meant to say we have one
but it's sold complete set yep yep yep
yeah well the person is four they only
need they don't need to they just need
the top half they don't need the legs
well what if somebody was shooting at
you what were the chances you think
they'd try to shoot your legs I feel
like I have to tell you that a suit of
armor will not deflect bullets
I'll take my church
with Christmas
which brings me uh to my next question
do you guys have roller skates I think
we have a pair around let me ask you a
question how fast do you think you have
to be going on roller skates you get
past a couple of armor guards and still
be going fast enough to smash through a
safe door one of those big Bank saves no
I don't know yeah yeah
oh hey you guys got one of those you
know it's one of those big bags with a
dollar sign on the side of it okay
you're gonna shoot arrows of shotgun
shells attached to them to a bank window
to blow out the glass then you're gonna
shoot a zip line through that window and
you're gonna slide on into the hallway
you're going to be wearing roller skates
so you can just skate on past the armed
guards who will be shooting at you and
you're going to hope that they both
won't hit your legs and if they are
aiming at your torso the suit of
medieval armor will deflect the bullets
then you're going to hope to gather
enough speed to burst through the big
bank vault at the end of the hallway
where you're going to collect the money
in a cartoon money bag
well no I'm just an uncles wanted for
Christmas and I uh I think I'll take my
business elsewhere Merry Christmas
it's April
anyone with a blue suitcase you may now
board finally no not you sir not me this
is a blue suitcase that's a blue
computer bag
[Music]
I read on the internet that it's not
against the law for me to go to the
bathroom while the fast and seat belt
sign is on so
what is it against the law though
the light is on
because it does the law
you see that there's a picture of a seat
belt on this
[Music]
holy shotsu massage
economy Plus
foreign
some leg room
um okay Max legroom you get yours
meanwhile I'm gonna go hating pant in
the Airy awesome Terrys especially when
they get froggy
ribbit ribbit
[Music]
you'll have to have your puppy the puppy
is what you're going to have okay oh
don't they serve that in the cafe across
the street
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yes
like go good but to stay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I have convinced this meeting
to find out what you are doing
why have we not taken a plane in 13
years
Colleen you don't even know
it is all because the cunning and mighty
TSA is always one step ahead of us I do
not believe it it's true
last month I attempted to take down a
plane with a pair of scissors five
inches long that sounds like a perfect
plan well why did it not work yes
this shrewd TSC
they made restrictions so you can only
take a 40 inch scissors four inches what
yes how could they know that the five
inch blade is a dangerous weapon in the
foreigners at every turn devils
you know it's the same way with the
liquid what what about the liquid yeah
we all know how much Devastation we can
reek with 3.5 ounces of liquid damage is
incalculable the crafty TSA they have
limited passengers to only 3.4 ounces
damn it
do none of you have a solution how to do
for us to approach this TSA
it's like you've been living in a
but here look the TFC they strike fear
into my heart
where barley has the shirts and the
Disposable rubber gloves and
they the sneaker shoes they are so
clever
yes they act as if they are listless
overweight employees who don't give a
[ __ ]
when in reality they are an Elite Force
of anti-terrorist Commandos oh cause the
brilliant TSA religion if I may think I
have a way to triumph over the wildly
TFA finally
I have a plan to put a bomb in a laptop
and it will get on it once you pull it
from this case
yes yes it is perfect planes were
running down from the sky onto the
infants
[Applause]
sneak in here for a second because I
don't I don't want to be the better or
bad news then don't be
as if the prophetic and all-knowing TSA
has predicted your plan
they make you take the laptop out of the
carrying case and put it in a separate
bin before you get on the plane come on
you've got to be kidding me you've got
to be kidding me are you kidding me this
is not a funny joke this is the job time
for kidding I wouldn't kid this oh my
God no I don't believe these mothers of
devils yeah
since you have all failed I will tell
you how we will destroy the
non-believers I have developed the
smallest bomb possible
and it fits perfectly
into this a full-sized tube of
toothpaste
yes it's really great isn't it I mean
it's a little fantastic what's going on
over here what's the situation over here
okay
is there a version of the toothpaste
balm that comes in travel size
you know what it's like the inner heads
oh yeah
they are stuck ahead of us every single
time
dignanigans
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
dialogue without dialogue absolutely I
feel like they're in my head
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
against
[Music]
dignanigans
[Music]
dignanigans
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
exploded nut syndrome is a condition
indicated by the presence of exploded
nuts which yours are
by the way I saw your show last night
amazing
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
must have been nothing
[Music]
[Music]
fact that he was clear
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now it's my turn to play
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Carol
[Applause]
I thought I killed you the first time Mr
I promise I will not make the same
mistake twice
[Music]
oh
you are a good cop Mr G
but a lousy fighter
[Music]
[Music]
oh snap
[Music]
oh
snap indeed
[Music]
you saved my life no Carol
you saved mine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
let me know
[Music]
[Applause]
you're ready
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what are we doing out there huh
because I don't know no seriously but
what are we doing
what are we doing
playing football okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's it man
fly your football yeah
yo exclusive thing you need to let the
medicine look at you man dude I'm all
right man I'm Fair
shoot hey I'm here
and I'm ready to do this man all right
what about you all man
do you want this yeah yeah do you want
that yeah yeah do you want that yeah
I mean all you had to do was ask man
there's plenty of apple pie to go around
you want some level five Brother come on
man you want a slice yo Exquisite team
ain't no apple pie man that's your
helmet
maybe you should just sit down next play
sit out next play yeah are you all
sitting up next Lane ah you will sit out
the next fight I didn't think so I don't
need to sit out the next Lane we'll tell
you why because all y'all cause I know
y'all got my back y'all know what I see
when I look at you I'ma tell you what I
see
bro remember
[Music]
what and just right there
a few seconds in complete darkness and
then I saw some little floaty specks of
Life getting the air up like this
Exquisite team who is that is that
cartoon slow I'm talking to me yeah I'm
here man oh yes you have a brain injury
you need to get some medical attention
hey I'm gonna tell you right now
cartoons flow who need some medical
attention is the true that's over there
right here we're playing the bruisers
okay listen y'all we need to remember
who we are okay
we're in a team of Destiny this year
we're the team everybody talking about
we entertain everybody afraid oh man we
got to remember who we are rhinos
[Music]
[Music]
oh my God somebody stole our horse
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys see anything
okay
we'll uh wait until dark
and then sneak back across the line
and rejoin our unit
did you guys hear something
oh hails
please Americans proved to be no
obstacle at all
search the hotel yeah
done well to secure this position
I could bode well for promotion
speaking of which
guess who I saw the market the other day
oh oh I don't know Adolf Hitler
I love Hitler who doesn't but you ever
see him in person oh yeah at the
Nuremberg rally it was
very inspirational I know it was I was
there everyone was there but up close
it's a whole different thing for
instance it was the weekend and the
little hairs had just started to grow on
the sides of the mustache like this soul
I walk up to Hitler casual and comment
down that's that's rude I'm in the
middle of the story you're not
interested in a story about our future
yeah okay good and Ava was there as well
taller than you think well hit the
shorter hard to say but anywho I'm
buying some bread Hitler's buying some
bread
um I must so I'm I'm assuming you've got
a better Hitler story but no but then
maybe don't interrupt
yes sir so I gave him a salute and he
gives me one of those half Hitler
salutes you know down low very cool
right you know here's what you forget
yeah he doesn't say Heil Hitler isn't
that funny
[Music]
I think maybe next time I'll tell him
how uninterested you are in my story
this is jealousy thing no no no you know
I didn't meet Hitler to hurt your
feelings it's it's
proceed of course
so I say to Hitler I've actually been
quite busy it laughs
and then says you and me both I mean
he's the funeral it's so funny because
it's an understatement I mean he's super
busy as Hitler was taking his leave I
have to interrupt you right do you speak
during the cinema the story has a build
but if you keep interrupting you kill
the momentum what I'm trying to tell you
that body is moving
that's ridiculous the Americans are all
dead
but if it keeps you from interrupting my
awesome Hitler story
I'll prove it to you
very good sir
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
insubordinate
cherlish
pity
[Music]
this is the best part of the story as
Hitler was taking his leave of me he
said well there's no point in getting
bread if you're not going to get and at
the same time Hitler said she's I said
cheese and then Hitler and Eyeball said
Jinx well there's just like two regular
everyday peoples you guys missed the
first part but this is all about Hitler
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone
I'm Joseph Carmichael
Otis is
was my father
but we are not here today to mourn his
death
but to celebrate his life
we knew Otis as a teacher a community
leader a role model A husband
and a father
now I thought it would be nice to share
something about him you all may not have
known
when my father was younger he was an
actor in Hollywood
going through my dad's things I found
this real
of his work as an actor
I haven't seen it yet but I thought it
would be fun to watch
here with all of you today
[Music]
where are my pies
Rebels where are the pies I put on my
windowsill
[Music]
mommy all delicious blueberry pie
[Music]
hey see to it you shine those shoes up
nice boy yes sir you best be believing I
will I'll shine your shoes blacker than
my mama's booty foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
in 1964 my father marched with Martin
Luther King Jr and Harry Belafonte along
with other renowned civil rights leaders
[Music]
[Music]
hello what oh snap yo let it know yo
Lando calerician oh hi yeah that's me
no Lando no yo yo you straight up
running Cloud City right now dog that's
you man you out there
ideally on an ideal situation I would be
doing like what you doing I'll be up
there like in the high chambers of cloud
city dog well see if it's nice to meet
you yo right on man cause they got me in
the Carbonite room right now son that's
[ __ ] right they got me working with
some pig dudes and whatnot y'all I ain't
no Pig you know and you ever notice man
there ain't a lot of brothers out here
man in space right it's like they're
trying to keep us down man you know I I
don't think that it's the policy I just
think it's really really difficult to
get to this level you've got to
understand the politics of the Empire
and at the same time all the motivations
of the rebels
all that all that all that all that but
ideally old man ideally what I'm talking
about is like me and you we should like
do something together though man because
if you think about it yo when I was
younger man I used to fly those land
Speeders all the time my friends was
like man you should be piloting in one
of the x-wings right and so that's like
disappointing man because I got here and
they just had me like cleaning up the R2
units after the x-wings come in see if I
gotta go you should probably oh man I'm
saying man have we contact one another
because that's the most important thing
that we contact one another yo look man
ideally though ideally though I would
get to fly somehow like the Millennium
Falcon like that would be cool and yo
let me get you my like my my I got my
card in here somewhere man I'm just
trying to find this pocket right here
sometimes these suits
just give your information to low Bud
here and we'll be in touch low Bot Man I
see how it is I gotta talk to your man
Droid right now man you little white ass
hair why you wearing a cake though huh
where you going the ice Planet hot
outrageous
[Music]
have you ever slept with a black guy no
but I really want to
do it in the ceiling yeah
oh way bigger penises right